Hallo Stefan.
Du siehst wieder schnick aus, was trägst du denn heute?
Vielen Dank, einen Leinenanzug mit einem gewissen Seitenanteil, also etwas ganz leichtes.
Du bist also auf den Klimawandel vorbereitet, auf das Wetter?
In der Tat. Ich glaube, man kann auch immer noch, wenn es sehr heiß ist, gut gekleidet sein. Und auch wenn man, wenn man so in die Öffentlichkeit geht, oft anderes feststellt und auch verwundert ist, warum Leute mit zunehmender Hitze alle Hemmungen verlieren. Ich bin da immer so ein bisschen erstaunt, denn man kann sich auch, wenn es sehr heiß ist, korrekt anziehen. Also man muss ja nicht mit dem Anzug rumlaufen, aber man kann auch mit so ein paar Basics eigentlich immer gut aussehen. Also ich sage mal, dunkle Hose, weißes Hemd funktioniert einfach immer. Da braucht man nicht irgendwas Verrücktes mit Aufdruck suchen, was dann eher peinlich wirkt, zumindest ab einem gewissen Alter. Es fällt auf, morgens sind Frühstücksräume in Hotels, wer da so alles reinmarschiert mit Aufdruck. Und da muss ich sagen, noch mal drüber nachdenken.
Genau, jetzt hast du die schwarz gekleidet mit Aufdruck angesprochen. Nein, die sind ja gar nicht schwarz gekleidet.
Das sind diese merkwürdigen T-Shirts mit ein bisschen Strass noch oben drauf. Das sind so Männer, die gerade Leila rauf und runter hören.
Ach ja, genau.
Wie meinte ich.
Genau, es assoziierte in meinem Kopf gerade, als du es sagtest. Zum einen, wir haben ja im November einen tollen Termin, wo ich dann auch das erste Mal gut aussehe, weil sich Leute um mich gekümmert haben. Wir beide haben uns ja um mich gekümmert die Tage.
Wir haben ja einen Anzug ausgesucht bzw. der wird jetzt dir geschneidert.
Er ist in der Mache, genau. Und im November lauten die Hashtags Zauberflöte, Mozart, Opa, erste Reihe, drei Leute im Anzug und so weiter. Bin gespannt, ob die Bühne mit uns mithalten kann, was geboten wird. Aber anderes Thema noch, apropos schwarz angekleidet. Ich hatte auch das erste Mal jetzt die Woche gedacht, Leute, so könnt ihr nicht rumlaufen. Denn es gibt tatsächlich wieder, also das will ich ausdrücklich sagen, es gibt wieder große Stadionkonzerte. Zum Glück. Zum Glück, also wahnsinnig zum Glück. Man kann das Glück gar nicht richtig in Worte fassen. Aber es gibt auch immer noch dieses Merchandising drumherum. Und es ist noch alberner als in den 90ern, als man schon begann. Es ist ironisch, nochmal mitzumachen, sich ein T-Shirt von der Veranstaltung zu holen. Warum man das 2022 immer noch macht, obwohl die T-Shirts mittlerweile irgendwie 35 Euro kosten, weil alle nochmal absahen wollen. Aber ich war spontan bei Iron Maiden, also das erste große Stadion Event für mich seit Corona. Und ich bin immer noch gerührt davon. Es war wirklich wahnsinnig toll. Keine Masken, außer so zwei, drei, wo man auch sieht, okay. Aber auch eben in so einer Art, dass man denkt, ja genau, jeder macht hier einfach mal, wie er will. Wir hatten ja das letzte Mal ein bisschen Ärger bekommen, weil einige missverstanden haben, wie wir das gemeint haben. Man fährt im Zug zum CSD, muss im Zug eine Maske tragen, beim CSD aber nicht. Und das einzige, was wir kritisiert haben oder was wir aufgegriffen haben, ist die Frage, darf denn derjenige, der mit einer Maske zum CSD fährt, nochmal andere Maßregeln, obwohl er dann selber die Maske absetzt? Gegen die Maskenpflicht, die ja im Nahverkehr und Fernverkehr noch ist, haben wir gar nichts gesagt. Ist dann auch immer, wie schnell die Kommentare auflaufen.
Aber man muss sich schon Gedanken darüber machen, was man dann eigentlich für eine Logik verfolgt, wenn man selbst dort nochmal das lobt, dass der Schaffner und der Zugführer durchgreift und das jetzt so richtig hart gegen die, die keine Maske aufhaben, sanktioniert wird und man selbst aber dann auf ein Fest fährt mit 1, 3 Millionen Menschen. Dann muss man sich schon fragen, ob da noch alles so zusammengeht in diesem Weltbild. Und ich glaube nicht, dass es diesen Journalisten darum ging, darauf hinzuweisen, dass man vulnerable Gruppen schützen soll oder so, sondern es war einfach diese Lust an der Durchsetzung von Regeln. Und diese Lust, die bei Twitter wiederkehrend ist, die beängstigt mich schon.
Genau, und ich will es gar nicht noch mal groß aufgreifen. Ich wollte nur noch mal ausdrücklich anmerken, die Erzählung, die wir so ganz lange hatten, dass die Masken die Allgemeinheit schützen, also dass der Selbstschutz gar nicht im Mittelpunkt stand, sondern immer dieser Fremdschutz. Das kann man jetzt sozusagen ins Kapitel 1, wir sind jetzt im Kapitel 2 angekommen, und wer sich selber schützen will, kann sich mit einer Maske schützen. Und zwar auch sicher, also auch die FFP2-Masken sind inzwischen wirklich Hochleistungsdinger, die auch noch mal Updates erfahren haben durch Corona. Das sind nicht diese ersten, ach, wir haben noch Lagerbestände und dann nutzen wir die mal, sondern da kann jetzt wirklich jeder machen, wie er will. Und ich glaube, wir müssen langsam anerkennen, nachdem ich jetzt auch so die Zahlen, also das füllt sich ja mit Leben, man hört so Zahlen, auf der einen Seite ist eine immens krasse Welle gerade, auf der anderen Seite kennt man viele, die Corona haben. Und ich glaube nicht mehr, dass man drum rumkommt, man muss jetzt in den sauren Apfel beißen, dass Corona in der Welt ist.
Aber man kennt kaum noch Leute, die Corona haben und das auch noch über den offiziellen Weg melden. Da kenne ich niemanden. Da sind ja diese Zahlen dann sowieso nochmal ganz andere. Und ich stelle aber fest, jetzt warst du bei Iron Maiden, das ist natürlich eine Truppe, die zieht und die sicherlich kein Problem damit haben, Karten zu verkaufen. Aber alles, was nicht Superstar-Level hat, hat es enorm schwer und man sieht es daran, dass man zum Beispiel in Opernhäusern, Theaterhäusern einfach an Karten kommt, selbst dann bei einer Zauberflöte oder sonst was, was früher eher schwierig war. Man sieht es bei den ganzen Festivals, die gerade sind den klassischen Festivals. Auch da kann man sehr kurzfristig super Karten noch kaufen. Und es ist wirklich sehr traurig zu sehen, wie eigentlich jetzt diese Veranstaltungsbranche immer noch, wie es im Spiegel hieß unter Long Covid, leiden. Wie da gerade die, die ohnehin nicht so wahnsinnig mit Erfolg gesegnet waren, weil sie ein bisschen unangepasst sind, weil die Musik ein bisschen zu komplex ist und was auch immer, wie sie straucheln und nach Publikum suchen und wenig nur finden. Also es ist ein ganz, ganz großes Problem. Und wir müssen wirklich aufpassen, dass wir auch diese einmalige Kulturlandschaft und Theater, Opernlandschaft, die wir haben, nicht jetzt kaputtgehen lassen. Deswegen wäre das auch hier mal als ganz deutlicher Appell von mir formuliert. Es sollen bitte mal wieder alle ins Konzert gehen, ins Theater gehen, in die Oper gehen. Und auch wenn sie zum ersten Mal da sind, dann kann das sehr, sehr ergreifend sein und kann dazu animieren, wieder hinzugehen. Denn, Stefan, wir waren ja in Frankfurt in der Oper, zwölf Tonmusik, Dalla Piccola. Und ich dachte, gut, wenn Stefan jetzt da mitkommt, dann habe ich ihn wahrscheinlich ewig für die Oper verloren, wenn er diese zwei Stunden übersteht. Aber keineswegs. Du warst begeistert und hast gar nicht gesagt, ich will jetzt eigentlich immer mitkommen. Und das sollte man einfach machen. Mal schauen, was kann man sich ansehen, anhören und einfach mal hingehen. Vielleicht sich vorher ein bisschen beschäftigen. Muss man nicht zwingend, aber kann man machen. Manchmal hört man, sieht man dann noch mal mehr. Und das ist ganz entscheidend. Gerade für Azubis Schüler, Studenten sind die Tickets günstig. Gerade im Schauspiel ist es so, dass du günstiger als Studenten ins Schauspiel gehen kannst als ins Kino. Ja, also das muss man auch sehen. Ich finde, zum Teil sind die Kartenpreise zu hoch bei der Oper. Aber da muss man auch immer schauen von Haus zu Haus, wie das da ist. Und wir haben diese Theater- und Opernlandschaft, für die uns die ganze Welt beneidet. Das gibt es so nirgends, dass wir so eine Dichte haben. Und ich kann nur jedem raten, dahin zu gehen. Und es ist auch interessant zu sehen, mit welcher großer Spielfreude, mit welcher Musizierfreude man diese Vorstellungen gerade sehen kann. Denn die sind alle wieder froh auftreten zu können. Ich war gestern Abend beim SWR-Vokalensemble, das konzertierte in Koblenz. Das ist so einer der besten Chöre Deutschlands oder vielleicht Europas. Und die haben einen neuen Dirigenten, Yuval Weinberg, ganz großartiger Dirigent, der dann danach auch noch mal einfach seine Dankbarkeit aussprach. Also dass er dann nach dem Schlussapplaus noch mal sich ans Publikum wendete und sagt, es sei einfach schön wieder vor Menschen auftreten zu können, singen zu können. Das hat man natürlich auch gleich gehört. Also das ist einfach so großartig, das zu erleben. Und es darf nicht kaputt gehen. Und ich kann nur jedem empfehlen, dahin zu gehen. Das sind übrigens meine Erfahrungen, aber ich gehe zu klassischen Konzerten, da sind eh die Leute älter. Aber meine Erfahrung ist, es sind nicht unbedingt die Alten, die jetzt zurückhaltend sind, sondern es sind so die jungen beziehungsweise so Mittelalten. Ich sitze ständig jetzt neben 80-Jährigen und ich füge hinzu, die tragen eigentlich nie eine Maske. Bei denen sitze ich und genieße diese großartige Musik. Deswegen kann ich es nur empfehlen, es mir gleich zu tun.
Genau, ich habe im Kalender mir auch schon eingetragen, das Theaterfest hier in Frankfurt. Ich habe es noch nie besucht, nachdem ich jetzt seit über zehn Jahren hier lebe. Aber diesen Herbst gehe ich mal hin. Freier Eintritt, das Schauspiel und das Opernhaus, die Oper daneben machen sozusagen so einen offenen Tag, irgendwie Tag der offenen Tür. Es gibt Programme und natürlich man kann dann gleich die Karten kaufen fürs Herbstprogramm. Und so es dauert. Es geht den ganzen Tag irgendwie 11 Uhr los, was dann auch bedeutet, da kann man auch mit den Kindern mal kurz vorbeischneiden, um ihnen zumindest mal die Säle zu zeigen. Da muss ja noch nicht mal was stattfinden, sondern die Säle allein machen es schon. Das allerdings war ein bisschen zweischneidig. Mir ist der Orchestergraben ein bisschen zu groß.
So, auf der anderen Seite müssen halt alle rein.
Genau, auf der anderen Seite sitzen da halt wirklich viele drin.
Sehr viele, 80, 90 Leute müssen da mit unter rein, wenn da Richard Strauss oder so gegeben wird.
Genau, bei dem Stück, was wir sahen, war ja der Orchestergraben voll. Und damit meine ich wirklich zwei Hafen, wo ich schon dachte, okay, zwei Hafen ist vielleicht echt so eine Dekadenzgrenze. Dass man in dem Orchestergraben noch mal vier Kontrabass versteckt. Das hat man ja nicht mal auf der Bühne, häufig. In der Hinsicht ganz gut, dass er groß ist, aber er ist halt groß und auf der Bühne war er ja echt getümmelt auf der Bühne. Das war ja nicht hier Kammerspiel oder so, sondern ein großer Opernchor, sehr viel auch Sound, 30-40 Leute, die da teilweise über die Bühne gerannt sind. Das war schon spektakulär. In der Hinsicht verkraftet man es auch sehr, sich dann in die Zwölftonmusik eine halbe Stunde reinzuhören, um dann das Gehirn drauf getrimmt zu haben, was hier noch so geschieht und womit man auf jeden Fall nicht überrascht wird, nämlich mit irgendwelchen Akzentuierungen, wo man erpicht darauf ist, dann vielleicht mal Szenenapplaus zu geben, sondern nein, man hört sich das dann in eigener Geruhsamkeit an, was auf der Bühne so abläuft und es ist toll. Aber ich freue mich auch sehr, dass wir dann beim nächsten Mal ein paar Harmonien geliefert bekommen und eine Königin der Nacht und so weiter und so fort, was halt auch dazu gehört irgendwie.
Dies Bildnis ist bezaubernd schön. Nun, eine Anmerkung noch für diejenigen, die vielleicht noch nie in der Oper oder im klassischen Konzert waren oder im Schauspiel waren oder im Ballett. Auch Ballett ist ja was ganz Wunderbares. Keine Schwellenangst. Bitte, man muss keine Angst haben, in diese Häuser hineinzugehen. Ich saß in der Dalla Piccola-Oper in Frankfurt ja auch, neben einem Mann im T-Shirt und das war Stefan. Und das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Weil es ganz viele Männer mit T-Shirt in der Oper gibt, da braucht man keine Angst haben. Auch sonst, man muss sich nicht irgendwie merkwürdig verhalten. Man wird auch nicht befragt.
Bloß nicht verkleiden. Auf der Bühne sind sie nur verkleidet.
Können sie mal den Tristan-Akkord aufschlüsseln oder so. Keine Sorge, passiert alles nicht. Es ist eher ein sehr offenes Publikum und man kann auch mit Leuten ins Gespräch kommen, wenn man das will. Also man muss da keine Sorgen haben.
Ja, vor allem, wenn man, also der gesungene Text läuft sowieso mit, man kann mitlesen und es gibt eine sehr gute Aufbereitung von dem ganzen inhaltlichen Kram. Man muss kein Programmheft lesen vorher, falls man sich inhaltlich dafür interessiert, was abläuft, sondern man kann einfach auf der Opernseite direkt die YouTube Videos anklicken. Also man kommt, die kommen einem da sehr entgegen. Das muss man einfach sagen. Die kümmern sich ums Publikum und wir auch. Genau. Wir kümmern uns auch ums Publikum. Wir haben hier eine Frage von Tom. Hallo zusammen, wäre es möglich, einmal eine kurze Erläuterung zu bekommen, wie man für Salon-Episoden, die aus den Episoden bekannten, äußerst nützlichen Kapitelmarken nutzen kann. Ich persönlich nutze keinen Spotify oder iTunes, sondern G-Potter. Ich wäre natürlich auch bereit, eine andere App auf dem Rechner zu verwenden. Vielen Dank und herzliche Grüße. Das ist besonders herausfordernd, weil er Podcasts auf seinem Computer hört. Auf dem Computer, klar, man kann einfach den Webbrowser aufrufen. Die Statisider hat einen Player, da kann man auf Play klicken. Der zeigt allerdings keine Kapitelmarken an, das ist ein Problem. Sein G-Potter, Podcastplayer wahrscheinlich auch nicht. Spotify würde die Kapitelmarken auch nicht anzeigen. Also der kurze Ritt ist, die Kapitelmarken sind auch im Salon drin. Macht ja auch Sinn, das sind 10 Texte auf drei Stunden. Man kann da hin und her springen, nur die Player müssen eben in der Datei die Metadaten auch entsprechend auslesen. Das machen alle Podcast-Apps, die man eigentlich auf dem Smartphone so bekommen kann. Ich kenne jetzt keinen, der das nicht macht. Und meine Empfehlung ist sowieso, das auf dem Smartphone zu hören. Ansonsten auf dem Computer sich die Datei runterladen im VLC-Player kann man machen. Dann sind die Kapitelmarken sichtbar. Oder wie auch immer, meine Empfehlung wäre, und das hier nochmal der deutliche Hinweis, weil das ist die häufigste Frage, der Salon ist ein Podcast wie jeder andere Podcast auch. Wenn man ein Abonnent ist, bekommt man ein RSS-Feed, wie bei jedem anderen Podcast auch, und kann sich das ganz normal pingen. Eine neue Podcast-Ausfolge da, soll sie automatisch runtergeladen werden? Ja, bitte. Sie liegt dann einfach im Podcast-Player, in ganz Standard, normalen Podcast-Player, den man auch ansonsten nutzt. Wer es auf dem Computer hören will, da wäre jetzt wirklich meine Empfehlung, auf der Steady-Seite einfach einen Browser aufrufen, wie auch immer. Also da ist ein Player drin, da hat eine feste URL, die kann man sich wegspeichern, wie auch immer. Und dann wollen wir nochmal über den kurzen Moment vorm Salon reden.
Genau, den Teaser.
Genau.
In diesem Teaser teasen wir in dem Sinne kaum das, was dann kommt. Also wir erwähnen kurz, was wir machen werden, bei welchen Texten wir sprechen werden. Aber eigentlich ist das nochmal so eine Mini-Ausgabe von den Neuen Zwanzigern. Das kann sein, dass ich mich mal über irgendwelche unsinnigen Corona-Regeln aufrege und das mit der Schweiz vergleiche. Es kann aber auch sinnvoller werden, indem wir irgendein aktuelles politisches Thema nochmal aufgreifen. Oder irgendwas aus der digitalen Welt, etwas, was wir noch sagen wollten, aber dann vergessen hatten und das aufgreifen. Das heißt, es ist noch mal ein kleiner Inhalt. Deswegen würden wir uns freuen, wenn ihr auch den Teaser ein bisschen mehr zur Kenntnis nehmt, als das der Fall ist. Oder ich glaube, viele denken einfach nur, es wird nur kurz gesagt, welche Texte wir lesen und gehen gleich in den Salon. Aber der Teaser ist einfach nochmal eine Mini-Ausgabe. Und wir können jetzt auch sagen, es war noch nie so leicht, in den Salon zu gelangen. Zumindest, wenn man bei Spotify ist.
Genau, das ist ein Wort zum Teaser-Sagen. Denn wir beide treffen uns ja so richtig vorm Salon. Das ist so ein Warm-Up-Gespräch. Und ich werde jetzt auch in den Titel, nachdem ich ja immer so das eine und das zweite Thema reinschreibe und dann Salon-Teaser groß schreibe, werde ich nochmal den Vormonat nennen und dann Recap reinschreiben. Weil wir gehen doch nochmal mit so einer Woche Abstand auf so ein paar Themen der Vorwoche vielleicht ein und sagen dann auch Sachen, auf die wir uns dann später wieder beziehen. Also vielleicht gehen doch Sachen verloren, wenn wir diese kleinen, was weiß ich, Lauterbach hat nochmal gesagt, ich trübe mein Haus auf Wissenschaftlichkeit, aber gebe dann meine eigene Empfehlung ab zum Thema Impfung oder so. Wenn wir das nochmal kommentieren und dann später darauf zurückzumachen, dann kam das nicht in einer großen Monatsausgabenfolge vor, sondern einfach im Recap vom Salon, weil sich da anbot und aktuell war. Genau und der Salon selber, das wolltest du ja gerade sagen.
Das ist nun jetzt was Neues, was uns sehr freut. Also es ist ja schon möglich, dass man den Salon jetzt auch über Apple buchen kann. Das heißt, wer den Apple-Podcatcher nutzt, also das über Apple hört, kann dort jetzt auch das intern buchen. Wir verstehen natürlich diese Bequemlichkeit, die das hat und das ist nutzbar. Steady ist nach wie vor ja auch so einfach eigentlich erreichbar, aber es war ja immer so, dass man dann ein RSS-Feed zugesendet bekam und dann auch oft Fragen kamen, ja, aber kann ich das dann auch bei Spotify trotzdem hören? Und nun ist es ganz simpel geworden, man kann über Spotify den Salon buchen, also indem man dann dort eine Anzeige hat. Du musst es jetzt genauer erklären, dass man zu Steady langt, aber es gibt jetzt keinen Umweg mehr, den man machen muss.
Genau, bei Apple ist ja so, wenn man schon die Neuen Zwanziger regulär abonniert, tauchen die Salon-Folgen dort in diesem schon abonnierten Feed als Salon-Folgen auf. Nur da kann man nicht direkt auf Play drücken, sondern man müsste erst 3, 50 Euro zahlen, denn Apple wäre ja 30% und dadurch haben wir es auch 30% teurer. Also bei Steady sind es 2, 50 Euro. Wer Geld sparen will, aber über Apple angefixt wird, der kann dann durchaus noch den Einklick zu Steady machen und dann einfach Geld sparen plus die Kapitelmarken noch angezeigt bekommen und das Cover-Bild. Ich weiß, wir haben das mit Apple besprochen. Es ist immer noch nicht nachgerüstet, dass man da auch mal den Schritt in die kleine Podcast Zukunft, die man so krass mitgeprägt hat, dann einfach mal geht. Bei Spotify ist es nun besonders easy, denn Spotify verlangt gar nichts extra. Spotify verlangt einfach nur, dass man sich als Steady-Kunde kurz zu erkennen gibt. Da klickt man einfach drauf und dann geht dieses typische Fenster auf. Möchtest du dich mit Steady authentifizieren, dann sagt man Ja. Und dann weiß Spotify, wer man ist und dann kann man einfach auf Play drücken. Nur es taucht eben nicht in dem regulären Feed beim Neuen Zwanziger auf, sondern der Salon ist einfach ein eigener Podcast.
Ach so.
Wir haben ihn verlinkt auf der Neuen Zwanziger.de Seite. Da kann man ihn aufrufen, man kann ihn über die Suche finden. Man erkennt ihn am Cover, das ist nämlich das normale Neuen Zwanziger Cover, nur dass oben noch mal Salon drin steht und dann hat man diesen Salon Feed. Da steht man einfach Abonnentenkram oder kostenpflichtig oder irgendwas steht da. Das sieht man dann. Da kann man nicht direkt Play drücken, sondern, aber da klickt man einfach drauf. Dann wird man gefragt, hast du einen Steady Account? Da sagt man ja. Und dann kann man einfach Play drücken. Also für alle, die den Spotify Player mögen. Und ich werde immer nur auf Spotify angesprochen. Es ist auch ein bisschen traurig, aber es ist, wie es ist. Wir haben uns dem ja auch geschlagen gegeben. Man kann über Spotify super bequem den Salon also hören.
Und ich habe mich natürlich gefragt, warum macht Spotify das eigentlich? Naja, es gibt schon viel mehr Podcast-Inhalt jetzt hinter der Paywall. Und wenn Spotify da so rausgedrängt wird und plötzlich Leute auf die Idee kommen, andere Podcatcher zu nutzen, dann ist das für die nicht gut. Und Spotify profitiert ja enorm von den Podcasts, weil sie ja den Podcastern nichts zahlen müssen.
Genau, kein Problem.
Das heißt, würden wir jetzt Lieder singen und wären bei Spotify, dann müsste Spotify ja jedes Mal uns Geld geben bzw. unserem Label. Und wenn man das mal so hochrechnet, ich weiß nicht, was man gerade bei Spotify zahlt, sagen wir mal 9 Euro, dann gehen da, wenn die Leute jetzt nur Musik hören würden, etwa 5 Euro davon an die Musikindustrie. Das heißt, die verdienen nicht viel. Wenn die Leute nur Podcast hören würden bei Spotify, dann muss Spotify ja nichts abdrücken. Und deswegen sind die sehr daran interessiert, eigentlich als Podcast-Plattform weiterhin wichtig zu sein. Zumal sie sich wohl auch mit so eigenen Großprojekten, wo man einfach viele Millionen auf berühmte Menschen geworfen hat, ein bisschen verhoben haben. Und vielleicht erkennen sie dann doch, dass das Podcast-Geschäft nicht einfach nur so ist, wir setzen zwei Prominente zusammen, die nichts zu sagen haben.
Ja, also mit Obama und Bruce Springsteen kann man genau drei Stunden füllen. Und dann ist das auserzählt. Die kümmern sich ja nicht um Clips und Aktualität und sonst irgendwas, sondern die quatschen halt aus ihrem Leben. Der Einzige, der das gut hinbekommt, ist, finde ich, Conan O'Brien. Deswegen, ich den noch die ganze Zeit höre. Und er für mich nicht leer zu quatschen ist. Aber bei diesen superprämonenten wie Prince Harry oder so ist das halt schwer.
Ich vermute aber, dass Conan O'Brien sich wahnsinnig gut darauf vorbereitet, dass es genauso ist, dass man denkt, er quatscht sich einfach nicht leer. Aber wahrscheinlich ist das doch wieder sehr harte Arbeit, die die anderen nicht leisten, denn die sagen, ich bin ja Prince Harry, das muss doch reichen.
Genau. Conan O'Brien kümmert sich auch darum, dass sein Team einfach am Start ist und gute Laune hat. Also der sitzt ja da nicht alleine und so. Und dann rufen die halt jemanden an oder jemand ist zu Gast. Die haben also das Gerede im Podcast einfach mal auf die Spitze getrieben. Wer Geselligkeit sucht, der hört bitte Conan O'Briens Podcast. Den kann ich wirklich nur wahnsinnig empfehlen. Selten so viel gute Unterhaltung bekommen.
Und dann gibt es ja immer noch das intellektuelle Fernsehen, Sternstunde, Philosophie. Und wir müssen jetzt über drei Clips sprechen. Da war nämlich der NASA Forschungsleiter zu Gast. Und dieses Gespräch hat mich auch ein bisschen mit Wolfram Eilenberger versöhnt, weil er das Interview wirklich ganz wunderbar führt. Thomas Zurbuchen, er ist der NASA Forschungsdirektor. Und ich habe jetzt drei Clips aus diesem fulminanten Gespräch mitgebracht. Also ich empfehle auch das komplett zu hören. Diese 60 Minuten sollte man sich gönnen. Aber was wir jetzt machen wollen, ist, dass wir diese Clips, die wir hören, mal dekontextualisieren. Wir wissen jetzt, wer er ist, aber wir versuchen das mal auf was zu übertragen.
Die einzige Art und Weise, eine Mission zu bauen, was auch auf den Mond, auf den Mars oder an einem anderen Planeten zu tun ist, ist das Zusammenkommen von verschiedenen Menschen, die andere Ansichten haben. Für mich ist eine Mission, ich habe immer gedacht, eine Mission sei so 70% Technologie und 30% Personal. Ich weiss, heute ist genau das umgekehrt.
Das Soziale ist viel wichtiger?
Absolut viel wichtiger. Wenn wir Probleme haben, ist ganz selten ist das Technologie fast immer zwischenmenschlich. Jawoll.
Das ist ein so kluger Satz, den wir übertragen müssen. Also 70% Technologie, dachte er, nee. Es sind 70% die Menschen, das Zwischenmenschliche, 30% die Technologie. Wenn jetzt Politiker, und wir sprechen ihn aus, wie Christian Lindner, ankommen und sagen, wir warten mal auf die Technologie, dann wird das schon mit dem Klimawandel alles noch funktionieren. Dann muss man sagen, ja, das kann sein, dass wir eine gute Technologie irgendwie entwickeln. Aber es kommt zum Beispiel darauf an, dass man dann einen Finanzminister hat, der will, dass diese umgesetzt werden, der Berater hat, die wollen, dass die umgesetzt werden, der sich mit den anderen Ressorts so abstimmen kann, dass es wirklich zum Besseren für uns ist. Und da kommt das Zwischenmenschliche rein. Und die Technologie löst für uns da überhaupt nichts, wenn das Zwischenmenschliche nicht stimmt. Aber das ist nicht der Fall.
Alles, was ich in dieser Art und Weise hier höre, ist sozusagen Wasser auf meinen Mühlen der Alfred Adler Lektüre-Erlebnisse, der das auch runterbricht, ganz radikal. Auf alle Probleme sind Beziehungsprobleme. Wenn sie Probleme haben, also wenn sie unter Problemen leiden in ihrem Leben, klar, wenn der Kühlschrank kaputt ist, ist das eine technische Herausforderung. Aber es wird erst ein Problem, wenn darum keine Beziehungen sind, um dieses Problem zu lösen. Wir kennen alle diesen Soziologenspruch, ein bisschen zynisch, aber absolut wahr. Wer Geld hat, braucht keine Freunde oder eben umgedreht. Wer Freunde hat, braucht kein Geld. Wir reden dann immer von sozial Schwachen und sagen, das sind die Armen. Aber nein, die sozial Schwachen, also die Armen müssen besonders sozial stark sein, um das eben auszugleichen. Und wenn er das nochmal in dieser Rocketscience-Technikdomäne sagt, wo wir immer drüber scherzen, das ist Rocketscience, das versteht man nicht und so. Und auch da gilt es aus seiner Erfahrung, umso ernster müssen wir das jetzt einfach künftig nehmen. Gerade wenn wir alle zusammenrücken wollen und uns eben die Frage stellen, wollen wir es technisch lösen? Also liegt ein Zukunftsentwurf für uns alle drin, dass Salzgitter nun wirklich schnell auf grünen Wasserstoff oben steigt? Oder kriegen wir es nochmal hin, so ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl, so eine Schicksalsgemeinschaftkeit zu finden, die sagt, ne, wir können auch einfach mal Energie sparen. Ich habe heute morgen wieder in den Fernsehnachrichten gehört, dass die Kalkulation so ist, dass die Amerikaner pro Tag pro Nase 8000 Kilokalorien verbrauchen. Schon allein dadurch, dass sie viel essen, Essen, für das auch wirklich vorher Kalorien verbraucht werden mussten, nämlich weil zum Beispiel irgendwelche Tiere, irgendwelches Getreide, erstmal en masse wegfuttern, damit am Ende ein bisschen Fleisch übrig bleibt und all solche Kalkulationen. Und ja, da hilft einfach ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl und Empathie sehr viel weiter. Und ich freue mich auch hier spekulativ natürlich erstmal anzukündigen, dass ich in der Alten Republik ein sehr originelles Argument mache, wo Gemeinschaftsgefühl herkommt und dass es nichts mit Gerede zu tun hat. Also wenn irgendwer in Deutschland anfängt, mit der Zusammenhalt wird auf einen Fall erstmal mit, ja, da muss man erstmal das Gerede umstrukturieren und erstmal das Deliberative und so weiter. Wir müssen aufeinander zugehen und auf der Beziehungsebene Gespräche darüber führen, ob man jetzt wirklich irgendwelchen Fake News glaubt oder wie auch immer. Ich sag nein, fangt nicht an mit Gerede. Es sind die Gesten, die man einander, wie in der Tierwelt eigentlich. Also wir Menschen sind in Sachen Gemeinschaftsgefühl vielleicht doch ganz anders gestrickt, als wir immer glaubten, als wir dachten, noch mal eine Diskussion anbrauen und dann lösen wir das Problem. Wird so wahrscheinlich nicht kommen. Also in der Ansicht guter Mann und das ohne Kontext zu betrachten, aber zu wissen, dass es Rocketscience ist, ist natürlich bringt dir einen echten Mehrwert.
Wir bleiben jetzt dabei, man muss nämlich auch Nein sagen können.
Sie haben sogar in Ihrem Team zwei Menschen angestellt, habe ich gelesen, die Ihnen die ganze Zeit sagen, Thomas du hast nicht recht, das könnte anders sein. Es ist ein interessantes managerielles Unterfangen zu sagen, ich stelle mir zwei Leute an, die mir immer widersprechen.
Ja, das Problem, das wir haben, ist unglaublich wichtig, wie die Art und Weise, wie Anase aufgebaut ist. Wir nehmen sehr viel Risiko. In der letzten Weihnachten war ich in Kuru und war dort für einen Raketenstart.
Da gibt es eine Raumfahrtstation in Kuru.
Genau, und da waren 10 Milliarden Investitionen von der Menschheit oben drauf, 8, 5 Milliarden von Amerika. Es gibt nur eine Person, die einen Zeit trifft, wir sind bereit, wir gehen. Am Schluss ist das ich. Der Grund dafür ist, wenn wir 20 Menschen in den Raum stellen, eine Person sagt, nein, wie gehen wir mit dem um? Wir haben nur eine. Diese Verantwortung, natürlich, ich höre allen 20 zu. Es ist absolut dumm, wenn ich das nicht tue. Aber die Tatsache ist, es gibt einen Fehler. Ich habe eine Schwäche, ich bin nicht sehr geduldig. Und ich weiss das. Und was ich brauche, ist, dass ich Menschen habe, obwohl ich den zuhöre, die sagen, du gehst zu schnell. Oder Moment, du musst mehr hören, du hast noch nicht alles gehört. Etwas, was ich gelernt habe, ist, ich habe mehrere Dinge getan in meinem Leben, wo ich wirklich stolz drauf bin. Erstens gesagt, 80% dieser Ideen waren nicht meine Ideen. Und zweitens war nur erfolgreich, wenn ich einen Menschen hatte, der nicht mehr sagen wollte.
Wir dekontextualisieren das jetzt wieder. Stellen wir uns jetzt mal vor, wir hätten einen Minister, vielleicht einen Finanzminister, da sitzen, der sowas von sich geben würde, der sagen würde, ja, ich brauche Leute, die nein zu mir sagen. Die mich mit dem konfrontieren, was ich eigentlich nicht sehen will. Was haben wir, wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel ins Finanzministerium gucken? Als Berater sitzt da Lars Feld, der genau das noch mal sagt, was Lindner ohnehin schon denkt. Also der sich einfach nur noch ein Spiegelbild mitgebracht hat. Jetzt müssen wir aber hier auch klar machen. Es gibt diese Unterscheidung. Die Sphäre der Politik ist eine Sphäre der Interessen. Das ist nicht unbedingt eine Erkenntnis geleitetes Fähre. Während wir es hier mit einer Sphäre zu tun haben, die natürlich auf Erkenntnisse aus ist und diese nur über diesen Weg des Neinsagens, des Hinterfragens erzielen kann. Aber hier können wir noch mal deutlich den Unterschied machen zwischen der Sphäre der Wissenschaft und der Sphäre der Politik, weil ja gerne jetzt so gesagt wird, ja Politik listen to the science, aber so einfach ist das nicht, weil wir da eine andere Sphäre haben. Also ich würde mir auch wünschen, dass eine solche Kultur auch in der Politik stattfindet. Aber die Sphäre der Politik verunmöglicht das in gewisser Weise auch, weil es um Interessen geht.
Genau, am Ende will man ja nicht seine Arbeitshypothese bestätigen, sondern man sucht ja die Synthese. Und die führt ja über Bande, nämlich über die Antithese, also das ganz klassische hegelianische, dialektische Prinzip. Resonanz nur über Widerstände und nicht einfach nur, ja dann ist halt so die Suppe und dann löffelt man die halt gemeinsam aus. Und dieser Spruch aus, ich würde mal sagen so Grundschule, dass Lehrer vor einem stehen und sagen, so jetzt basteln wir, macht mal das und das. Übrigens, der Fantasie sind keine Grenzen gesetzt, ist das dümmste überhaupt. Denn dann braucht man ja auch keine Fantasie, wenn keine Grenzen zu überwinden sind. Und die haben ja nun wirklich, und das ist ja eigentlich auch ziemlich paradox, dass wir auf der einen Seite diese Wissenschaftlichkeit hier drin haben, also die wirklich hardcore runterbrechbare Physik, die sich aber eben nur nutzen lässt, wenn man sie, wie wir im ersten Clip gehört haben, gemeinschaftlich angeht und da das Tina-Prinzip zu vermeiden. Also nur weil es für alle so, das ist ja krass, also wenn wir das Wasser hier oben reingießen, kommt das unten raus. Wir sind uns dadurch alle einig. Und dann trotzdem jemanden daneben zu stellen, der sagt, ja, aber können wir nicht trotzdem noch mal in die Reflektion gehen. Also überall noch mal eine Supervision einzubauen, überall noch mal das einzubauen, was im Homeoffice so verloren gegangen ist. Das Gespräch in der Küche, wo man sich und dann können gar nicht genug Köche den Brei verderben über 1000 Ecken noch mal um ein Problem herumtanzt und so. Ja, vielleicht sollte man wirklich mehr auf den, also wenn Rocketscience über soziologische Probleme sprechen, ist es vielleicht besonders interessant.
Ich glaube auch, denn jetzt kommt noch ein eigentlich soziologisches Problem, das er anspricht. Wir haben ja immer mal wieder in den letzten Monaten, Jahren gehört von Aufnahmen, die da gemacht wurden von möglicherweise Außerirdischen, die uns besuchen kommen. Und das interessante ist jetzt, dass man da so eine Bulvardeske-Berichterstattung hatte, aber dann so eine seriöse, die sagte, naja, das ist Quatsch eigentlich. Und hier ist aber jemand, der durchaus diesen Zweifel zulässt und das auch interessant findet. Thomas Zurbuchen wagt sich hier Folgendes zu sagen. Und auch das können wir, glaube ich, wieder ganz gut auch auf andere Terrainz übertragen.
Schau, wie das fliegt. Sie haben sich diese Aufnahmen sicher auch angesehen. Was denken Sie, wenn Sie das sehen?
Das ist unglaublich interessant. Das ist nicht die einzige Aufnahme. Wir haben jetzt über 400 solche Aufnahmen vom amerikanischen Militär. Was interessant ist, dass drei Viertel von denen erst in den letzten paar Jahren rausgekommen sind. Der Grund dafür ist natürlich, dass es okay ist, darüber zu sprechen. Vorher gab es viele solche Aufnahmen, die keiner je darüber gesprochen hat, weil es peinlich war, etwas zu sagen, das andere verlacht haben.
Es war eine Scham, darüber zu sprechen.
Absolut. Das passiert öfters, wenn man an die Grenze geht, an dem, was man versteht.
Das finde ich ganz bemerkenswert, dass du hier sagst, da gab es schon immer diese Aufnahmen, oder schon länger diese Aufnahmen, aber es war nicht so okay, das zu sagen. Wir haben beide Thomas Kuhn gelesen, der von diesem Paradigmenwechsel immer wieder schreibt, wie das in der Wissenschaft stattfinden kann. Da gibt es ja auch dann die These, dass eigentlich das Neue in die Wissenschaft kommt, in dem das Alte ausstirbt, nicht in dem es überwunden wird oder sich überzeugen lässt. Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen das, was man auch gerade in der Ökonomik erleben kann. Also es gibt noch die Ordo-Liberalen, die da noch festhalten, und die kriegen vielleicht auch noch die eine oder andere Professur jetzt zugeschustert. Aber eigentlich ändert sich da jetzt gerade so viel, dass das erneuert wird von innen heraus, beziehungsweise nicht von innen heraus, sondern dass einfach neue Leute kommen, die mit den Alten nichts mehr zu tun haben wollen. Und dann gibt es aber jetzt noch diese Scham, also dass man irgendwas jetzt noch gerade nicht sagt. Und das hat mich natürlich schon daran erinnert, dass wir immer wieder so hegemoniale Diskurse haben, bis dann mal jemand sagt, na ja, aber eigentlich können wir es auch mal so und so noch betrachten. Und das ist etwas, was wir auch, glaube ich, mitnehmen können, wenn wir über diese ganzen unsinnigen Diskussionen, Kenstl Culture und so weiter reden. Ich glaube, viel wichtiger als über diesen Begriff zu reden, ist darüber zu reden, was ist gerade hegemonial? Also das heißt, welche Art des Denkens, Palierens über Dinge ist gerade dominant? Und ist diese Dominanz gerechtfertigt oder muss sie auch hinterfragt werden? Und wir können das auch bei den Naturwissenschaften sehr gut sehen, wenn wir auf den Klimawandel blicken. Da gab es zunächst einmal einsame Rufer in der Wüste und die wurden dann irgendwann hegemonial, in dem jetzt wohl kein Wissenschaftler, der was auf sich hält, sagen würde, nö, stimmt alles nicht mit dem Klimawandel. Aber dass es immer auch so diese Charmgrenzen gibt bei verschiedenen Dingen. Auch glaube ich jetzt ganz stark bei Leuten, die klimaaktivistisch oder klimawissenschaftlich unterwegs sind, zu sagen, naja, wir werden das mit dem 1, 5 Grad Ziel wohl nicht schaffen, deswegen müssten wir jetzt so ein Paradigmenwechsel, wie umgehen mit der Hitze, wie umgehen mit dies und das. Das müsste man eigentlich jetzt viel mehr thematisieren. Aber da kriegt man sehr schnell eins drüber. Das hat ja dann z.B. Jonathan Franzen erlebt, der so einen Essay veröffentlicht hat, wo er sagte, wir müssen jetzt mal gucken, wie wir damit umgehen. Dann wurde er gleich so dargestellt, als wollte er einfach sagen, du bist ein Fatalist und so. Nein, das ist vielleicht eine andere Blickweise. Wenn das hier in dieser Forschung, die erst mal so bis aus der Sphäre der Macht ja draußen zu sein scheint, die reden jetzt da, könnten da Flugkörper sein. Aber natürlich gibt es auch da wieder Interessenkonflikte. Auch die Wissenschaft ist nicht frei von Interessen und auch von Machtstrukturen. Da ist das schon erstaunlich, wenn das hier mal so offen gesagt wird. Naja, da hat man sich lange Zeit auch gar nicht getraut zu sagen, naja, das könnte vielleicht auch was Außerirdisches sein. Und das finde ich, sollte man immer bedenken, wenn man auch so darüber spricht, dass man rechtlich oder so alles sagen kann. Natürlich fast alles. Und die paar Dinge, die verboten sind, sind zu Recht verboten. Aber es gibt natürlich diese hegemonialen Strukturen. Und da, glaube ich, muss man viel vorsichtiger sein.
Genau, es erfordert jedenfalls viel auch nicht nur wissenschaftliche Reputation, sondern auch Prominenz, so ein gewisses Standing zu haben. Wie Harald Lesch. Dann einfach zu sagen, ja, ich bin ein gläubiger Mensch.
Ja, er übrigens auch, Thomas Zurbuchen.
Genau, und dann einfach ins Publikum zurückzufragen, wenn jemand mit der Stirn runzelt, ja, dann erklären sie mir doch mal, was ist denn hier die Grundlage von allem? Wie kann das denn alles möglich sein?
Das ist ein sehr religiöser Haushalt und stellt sich sehr interessante Fragen. Also wie gesagt, das Gespräch muss man sich anhören.
Umso mehr die eben den Wahnsinn des Funktionierens der Welt feststellen, umso mehr fragen sie sich halt in diesem faustischen Sinne, ja, was ist denn nun die Grundlage des Pudels Kern? Und klar, wir können jetzt mit diesem James-Webb-Teleskop da irgendwie, und diese Bilder, die jetzt im Juli kamen, waren ja wirklich ein Spektakel, da irgendwie 15 Milliarden Jahre zurückgucken, aber eben nicht 15, x Milliarden, um dann wirklich mal die eigentliche Frage zu klären, weil wir können es nur noch mal anders und besser visualisieren, was ja von dem wir wissen, dass es da ist. Nur bisher waren die Linsen nicht gut genug, aber darüber hinaus kann man dann auch nicht. Schließen wir doch diesen Themenblock ab mit der Nachricht, die diese Woche kam. Die ISS, die ja nun das alles so ein bisschen manifestiert, was wir hier besprochen haben, wird also ab 2024 auf Russland verzichten müssen. Die Russen haben den Rückzieher gemacht, der wirklich eine Zäsur ist, weil der ganze Kalte Krieg über stand das außer Frage, auch wenn es über Sputnik und so weiter begann, dass man da zusammenarbeitet. Und eventuell werden sie sogar ihre russischen Bauteile abkoppeln von der ISS, um daraus eine eigene Anlage im Weltraum zu bauen. Also das sind natürlich alles abenteuerliche. Vielleicht haben sie auch 2024 genannt, um noch ein bisschen Zeit ins Land gehen zu lassen bis dahin.
Man kann es nur hoffen, weil sich ja auch das Zurbuchen auch immer so was Utopisches darin zu erkennen gab. Nämlich, dass man zwar hier auf Erden in einem kalten Krieg sich befindet, dass aber doch eigentlich so ein Bewusstsein für eine gemeinsame Menschheit da ist. Und dass man das wenigstens noch als übergeordnete Struktur lässt und dann symbolisiert dadurch, dass man gemeinsam im All forscht, das ist wirklich sehr bitter, wenn das jetzt wegfallen würde.
Genau, also gerade da, wir hören ja von Astro Alex, das ist ja seine einzige Botschaft, wenn man einmal da oben ist und die Erde sieht auch mit ihren Grenzen, dass man dann anders über das innerhalb der Grenzen nachdenkt, aber scheint nicht mehr so oft zu funktionieren. Naja, die örtlichen Probleme, wir kennen sie, Waldbrände. Und sie haben uns jetzt auch in Deutschland erreicht. Bislang hatten wir ja nur so Interstellar-Bilder, wenn wir sahen, wie irgendwelche Riesenmetrischer Brandenburg abmähen. Und dann eine Staubwolke entsteht, von der wir auch irgendwie die Angst haben, dass sie uns irgendwann in den Abender richten, weil sie auch vom Satellitenbild noch erkennbar sind, uns angezeigt werden. Jetzt allerdings auch die Waldbrände. Es hatte sich ein bisschen angekündigt. Wir hören hier mal Annalena Baerbock bei ihrem Besuch in Prag.
Für Annalena Baerbock die passende Vorlage, um für Energiewende und Klimaschutz zu werben.
Und wie dringend das nötig ist, das riechen wir förmlich gerade an diesem Morgen hier auch in Prag. Mit Blick auf die furchtbaren Waldbrände in der bürmischen Schweiz, die sich ja ausweiten auf die sächsische Schweiz.
So, inzwischen ist das ja in die sächsische Schweiz alles rübergeschwappt. Und wie wir darüber reden, ist ganz interessant. Zum einen hier mal dieser Blick nach Frankreich, auch vom Deutschlandfunk.
Die Feuerwehrmänner, die seit Tagen gegen die Brände rund um das Becken von Akashan kämpfen, sprechen von einem Inferno. Sie berichten von Flammen, die teils bis zu 100 Meter hoch schlagen. Die beiden Großbrände bei Londiras und La Teste Buche sind nicht zu kontrollieren, sagt Jean-Louis Glaise, Präsident des Departements Gironde. Ich gebe Ihnen ein Beispiel. Das Feuer, das bei Londiras ausgebrochen ist, erstreckt sich nun über ein Gebiet von 66 Kilometern. Wir schaffen es derzeit nicht, die Flammen zu stoppen. Die Feuerwehrmänner sind hier mit Bränden konfrontiert, die sich ständig bewegen. Der Wind dreht und sobald sie an einer Front angekommen sind, brennt es an der nächsten. Die Feuer werden ständig größer.
Also Feuerwehrleute, die sich mit ihrer Materie auskennen, wie die Astronauten und Physiker mit ihren Raketen und dem Weltraum und so weiter sagen, Inferno, Kontrollverlust. Wir haben es hier gerade nicht unter Kontrolle. Sie sehen das im Fernsehen. Wir sind vor Ort und wir können ja einfach nur sagen, wir können das hier nur brennen lassen. Im gleichen Zuge, also wirklich in der gleichen Berichterstattung, hören wir allerdings auch die Tourismus-Chefs.
Bei dem gesamten Becken von Acachon liegt dichter Rauch. Die beliebte Urlaubsregion ist nun ein Katastrophengebiet. Fünf Campingplätze nahe der berühmten Dune du Pilar wurden fast komplett zerstört. Zehntausende Menschen, Anwohner, aber auch viele Touristen wurden in Sicherheit gebracht. Und noch immer werden Ortschaften evakuiert. Es versteht sich von selbst, dass Urlaub in der Brandregion nicht möglich ist, sagt Éric González, Leiter des Tourismusbüros der Gironde. Der ganze Sektor ist gesperrt, außer den Einsatzkräften hat niemand mehr Zugang. Aber wenn die Menschen bei uns Urlaub machen wollen, dann können sie das im Norden des Departements oder weiter im Landesinneren. Dort ist auch noch nicht alles ausgebucht und wir können Urlauber empfangen. Können, wollen und müssen, sagt González.
Und am Abend, wenn es dunkel ist, sieht man dann einen etwas erröteten Himmel oder wie sieht das aus?
Also wir haben Annalena Baerbock, die in Prag steht und sagt, na gut, Prag brennt gerade nicht, aber wir riechen das hier ganz deutlich. So, und jetzt ist das Argument, dort in den Urlaub zu fahren mit, naja, es brennt ja nicht, kommt da, wo sie gerade sind, wo ihr Hotel steht, aber dass da vielleicht so Rauchwolken drüber und dass da auch Infrastruktur vielleicht ein bisschen am Arsch ist oder so, das ist da alles egal in diesem Moment. Und da fragt man sich ja schon, was ist das für eine Herangehensweise? Also muss man nicht dann doch mal auch im deutschen Fernsehen zum Beispiel drüber nachdenken, die Berichterstattung so umzubauen. Wir hatten ja häufig Klimawandel, da wird uns der Eisbär gezeigt. Und jetzt haben wir Waldbrände.
Und das sagt aber jeder süß, aber man ist ja selbst kein Eisbär, hat auch kein Zuhause und denkt, naja, aber es ist auch weit weg.
Genau, nicht wir, nicht hier. Und jetzt hat man diese Waldbrände und denkt sich so in den Redaktionen, naja, Tourismus. So, die erste Register des Feldes, ja, Tourismus. Müssen wir erstmal 30 Sekunden mit Tourismus reden. Und über Waldbrände sollte man aber intensiver sprechen, zum Beispiel mit Georg Goldamer, der war auch diese Woche in den Nachrichten, habe ich gehört. Dort allerdings ein bisschen zurückhaltender als hier im Juni schon. Letzten Monat habe ich es dann doch nicht gespielt, aus Zeitgründen, aber jetzt passt es irgendwie ganz gut. Jetzt wurden Brandenburg und Sachsen dann tatsächlich brennen. Georg Goldamer ist der einzige Professor für Feuerökologie. In Deutschland gewesen, glaube ich. Er blickt auf eine gewisse Berufsgeschichte zurück, die für uns ganz interessant ist. Denn wir müssen diese Feuer jetzt irgendwie löschen. Und er sagte Ende Juni das hier.
In Anbetracht dieser Situation, dass genau solche Brände sehr gefährlich sein können, hat die öffentliche Hand in Brandenburg in den Jahren 2010 bis 2014 ein Entwicklungs- und Forschungsvorhaben geführt, das ich zusammen durchgeführt habe unter der administrativen Führung des Landkreises Telto-Fleming mit verschiedenen Partnern. Und bei diesem Vorhaben, was finanziert wurde vom Naturschutzfonds Brandenburg und auch aus Mitteln der Europäischen Kommission, wurden Verfahren getestet und Technologien entwickelt, die am Schluss ergaben, dass ehemalige Kampf- und Kommandopanzer umgerüstet wurden als Löschpanzer, aber auch als Panzer, die Feuer legen können. Also gegen Feuer legen können oder diese sogenannte kontrollierte Brennung durchführen können bei gleichzeitiger Absicherung des Personals. Und diese Gesellschaften stehen zur Verfügung seit 2013, 2014.
So, wenn wir das mal runterbrechen, hören wir ja hier krass innovatives Zeug. Wir reden über die Feuerwehr, die aber links nicht mit einem Feuerwehrauto und Wasser anrückt, sondern die einfach mit einem Panzer kommt, der Feuer legt. Wie die Firefighter in den USA. Genau, um das einfach mal zu kontrollieren. Dann fackelt man so ein Feld lieber ab, hat dann eine Schneise, und dann sind zwei Waldstücke wirklich voneinander entkoppelt, was Feuergefahr angeht. So, und jetzt sagt er, das haben wir 2010-11 gemacht, Unterstützung der Europäischen Kommission. Brandenburg stand dahinter, diese Dinger stehen also breit, man könnte sie einsetzen. Warum werden sie nicht eingesetzt? Und jetzt sind wir wieder bei dem NASA-Ingenieur. Ja, wir haben eben eine technische Herausforderung und eine soziale Herausforderung. Und dann hast du schon Lindner häufiger angebracht. Und genau sowas ist hier das Problem.
Die Verantwortung und damit auch die Finanzierung des Brand- und Katastrophenschutzes liegt bei den Gemeinden und bei den Landkreisen. Dann letztendlich beim Bundesland. Der Bund, also die Bundesrepublik Deutschland, hat da praktisch aufgrund des föderalen Systems keine Eingreifmöglichkeiten. Derjenige, das ist so ein Motto hinter Brandbekämpfung, derjenige, der bestellt, also ein Gerät ordert, wie zum Beispiel ein Hubschrauber oder ein Löschpanzer, der muss bezahlen. Und das ist die Gemeinde bzw. der Landkreis. Diese Mittel sind einfach nicht da, aufgrund der wirtschaftlichen Lage.
Und wir wollen die Kommunen nicht entschulden. Das steht im Koalitionsvertrag so ganz nebulös drin. Man muss immer darüber nachdenken. Und die schwer Verschuldeten, also man kann einfach sagen, sind alle verschuldet, außer vielleicht so drei Superorte, die 15 Millionäre auf einmal haben. Aber sonst, muss man sagen, sind die alle verschuldet. Und das ist das große Problem. Und da ist die Bundesregierung, die das blockiert. Also anders kann man das ja nicht sagen. Also zwar ist jetzt die hierarchische Struktur so, dass das dann nicht der Bund machen kann. Aber der Bund sperrt die finanziellen Mittel. Dadurch können die Kommunen das nicht machen. Die Kommunen sind aber die einzigen, die sagen können, los mit den Panzern. Schwerer Waffen jetzt. Und das passiert aber nicht. Da kann man ja auch mal schöne Talkshows machen. Weil die könnten ja ihr Vokabular beibehalten. Die drei enttäuschten. Wir nennen sie nicht beim Namen.
Eigentlich müsste man in so einer Talkshow mal den Landrat oder was auch immer aus Weißerich. Weißerich heißt glaube ich der Ort mit dem höchsten Gewerbschaftssteueraufkommen in Deutschland. Ungefähr 30.000 Euro pro Nase pro Jahr. Also damit kann man einfach mal ordentlich Schwimmbäder betreiben und so. Wie kommt's? Porsche Teststrecke in der Gemeinde. So und dann haben wir halt in Brandenburg diese entvölkerten, da leben nur noch 100-jährige und ganz kleine Gemeinde, also wirklich super kleiner, was weiß ich 100 Seelenort oder so, aber riesige Wälder. So, wenn das da brennt und die rufen bei der Feuerwehr an und sagen ich bestelle jetzt hier mal eine Feuerwehr, dann sagen die halt ja, sie kennen ja den Preis und dann guckt dann seine Gemeindekasse, sieht da irgendwie 100 Euro rumlegen und denkt, kann ich ja gar nicht, macht das also auch nicht. Und deswegen brennt das da einfach ab.
Also hier unser Tipp an Redakteure von Talkshows, die ich ja nicht gucke, aber man könnte sich immer was einfallen lassen. Also man könnte jetzt sagen, vielleicht brauchen wir für die nächsten Wochen eine kleine Pause von Strackzimmermann und Hofreiter. Und stattdessen nur noch Landräte. Ich möchte nur noch Landräte abends sehen. Wir fünf Landräte und Oberbürgermeister. Und die sollen jetzt mal wochenlang über all diese Probleme sprechen.
Gerne anfangen wir mit Peter Feldmann. Dann hat man auch ein bisschen Action inhaltlich. Aber dann über die richtigen Themen sprechen. Und das ist wirklich crazy, dass wir in der Böhmischen Schweiz einen Waldbrand haben und wir uns nicht darauf strukturell vorbereiten, dass der Löschpanzer, der vorhanden ist, vielleicht in der sächsischen Schwanz mal das Tor hoch macht, rausrückt und einfach mal kontrolliert ein paar Felder abfackelt, damit es da nicht lichterloh brennt. Also das ist wirklich bekloppt. Und da wir jetzt schon gehört haben, das ist ja verrückt.
Ich will noch eine Sache sagen zu diesem Ökonomischen. Ich halte es auch für problematisch, wenn man jetzt den Klimawandel nur bekämpfen will, um das BIP weiter aufrechtzuhalten. Aber ich finde, dass das bei vielen die einzige Argumentation ist, die noch irgendwie ankommt. Deswegen finde ich das manchmal strategisch ganz klug, das zu bedienen. Letztlich bedeuten Wohlstandsverluste für uns alle Wohlstandsverluste. Und wir wissen, wer die Wohlstandsverluste immer am härtesten tragen muss. Das sehen wir jetzt auch bei der Energiekrise. Das sind nämlich die, die ohnehin schon nicht viel haben und die leiden dann doppelt. Die haben dann kein Geld und es ist zu heiß. Und deswegen ist das ökonomische Argument wichtig. Ich empfehle hier sehr, wir werden ja heute nicht drüber sprechen, glaube ich über USA, was da passiert ist mit dem Build Back Better Act von Joe Biden. Das hat sich in dem Sinne in Luft aufgelöst. Es sind ein paar Dinge noch geblieben, die aber irrelevant sind, wenn man das eigentliche Problem sich ansieht. Es gibt im Schadbook da von Adam Toos einen wirklich sehr guten Text, der das aufdröselt und der geht am Ende, macht er genau das Richtige. Er zeigt, was bei den Demokraten los ist. Es ist nicht nur Joe Menschen, sondern es sind dann auch andere Zentristen, die da alles blockiert haben. Biden wird als der schwächste Präsident wahrscheinlich in der demokratischen Laufbahn angehen. Also Adam Toos heißt, es wird wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal das sein, was Bill Clinton noch an Sozialem und so geschafft hat. Und das war ja schon wenig, ganz absurd. Aber er geht dann am Ende zum BIP und sagt dann, naja, es wird sich im eurasischen Raum viel tun für die Bekämpfung des Klimawandels. Und das wird Investoren anziehen, das wird sehr viel für die Wirtschaft tun. Der amerikanische Kapitalismus wird jetzt nicht kaputtgehen, aber das wird sehr bitter werden für Amerika, für das BIP von Amerika. Und das ist keine dumme Argumentation, auch mal genau auf diese Schiene zu gehen.
Ich finde sowieso, wenn man an politischen Diskussionen teilnimmt, bei denen man feststellt, es kocht irgendwie emotional in mir, weil die armen Kinder, die keine Lehrer haben, die armen Alten, die keine Pfleger haben, wie auch immer, ja, das kann man alles noch tausendmal sagen, dass einem das wirklich super leid tut und man da wirklich leidet und dass das ja auch moralisch voll herausfordernd ist. Aber es gibt dafür immer eine volkswirtschaftliche Argumentation. Wenn wir keine Lehrer haben, dann haben diejenigen, die in zehn Jahren eine Rente wollen, einfach ein Erwerbspersonenpotenzial, das nicht ordentlich ausgebildet ist. Wenn wir keine Pfleger haben, müssen das alles Privatleute machen, die dann dem Arbeitsmarkt nicht zur Verfügung stehen. Also jedes Unternehmen kann sich ja überlegen, will man in zehn Jahren gut ausgebildete Fachkräfte haben oder will man Leute, die sich gerade so zum Hauptschulabschluss gebracht haben und dann eben erst mal zehn Jahre blockiert sind, weil sie die Oma pflegen müssen. Und das kann man ja volkswirtschaftlich einfach mal runterbrechen und sich fragen, was steht denn da unter dem Strich? So. Und so ist das eben auch beim Klima. Wenn es für alle blöd ist, ist es eben für alle blöd. Also dann fallen auch irgendwann die Profite da aus. Und unter der Maßgabe, finde ich, sollten wir alle anders über Hitze, Waldbrände usw. reden. Und einer, der es ja immer ein bisschen vormacht, ist dann Jörg Kachelmann, unser allseits geliebter Wettermann, dessen Website ich sehr schätze, weil er doch das Wetter immer noch mal besser voraussagt als diese ganzen Apps, die einem die ganze Zeit angeboten werden. Ja, also ich gucke nur noch bei Kachelmann, ob es jetzt wirklich regnet oder nicht, weil er eindeutig dazu sagt, guck dir die nächsten sechs Stunden an, danach ist es bei uns auch nur Spekulation, aber für die nächsten sechs Stunden haut es irgendwie hin und ich denke mir immer, ja, es haut wirklich irgendwie hin. Also ich kann das wirklich sehr empfehlen, kachelmannwetter.de. Und Jörg Kachelmann ist hier mal im Gespräch über, na was wohl, es ist warm, es ist trocken und er dröselt das alles mal so ein bisschen auf im Deutschlandfunk und spart da auch nicht an... Na gut, es ist nicht der Ton, den man von Twitter kennt, aber er ist halt recht deutlich. Und er verwendet gute Worte.
Das ist ganz sicher Klimawandel, da müssen wir glaube ich gar nicht debattieren und diskutieren.
Und hier geht es um die Waldbrände, danach geht es dann auch noch mal um die Hitze.
Wir haben einander ja zum 24. Juli 2019 schon mal mit der Frage gehört und da war die Antwort ganz klar und sie ist es wieder. Ich würde auch ein bisschen anschärfen im Vergleich zu damals, weil man sehen, wie schnell das voranschreitet, dass das doch eher Klimakrise ist, was wir im Moment erleben.
Ja, also redet nicht mehr vom Klimawandel, sondern wir sind jetzt in der durch den Klimawandel herauf vorgerufenen Klimakrise. Wir können jetzt dieses zweite Kapitel einfach aufmachen. Wir sind jetzt da bei diesem ständigen Berichterstatten zum Thema es ist wirklich sehr dürr in Deutschland, es fehlt ja überall an Wasser. Und dann wird uns am Ende immer gesagt, wie viel es jetzt regnen müsste. So, dann heißt es irgendwie ein halbes Jahr Dauerregen oder so. Die Frage ist aber, ja kommt der denn? Und auf die Frage antwortet die der Kachelmann dann einfach. Nee, der wird einfach nicht kommen.
Gibt es Aussicht auf Regen, gerade da wo es besonders trocken ist zumindest?
Nein, das gibt es nicht. Die neuen langfristigen Aussichten zeigen, dass eigentlich bis Ende August nur örtliche Schau- oder Gewitterregen zu erwarten sind.
So, es wird kein Regen geben. Es ist also trocken. Es ist Waldbrandgefahr. Gut, es ist ja gerade Sommer, da ist ja Waldbrandgefahr besonders blöde, weil dann will man ja auch mal grillen oder so und darf es dann nicht. Ist der Waldbrand nur ein Sommerproblem? Nein, natürlich nicht.
Jeder, der ihnen bei Twitter folgt, bekommt das mit, dass sie sich da sehr pointiert äußern. Und sie betonen auch immer wieder das extreme Hitze keine Ursache für Waldbrände ist, sondern eben die Trockenheit. In diesem Zusammenhang haben sie neulich übrigens auch den Deutschlandfunk als strunzblöde bezeichnet. Hat für mich jetzt natürlich den Vorteil, dass ich jetzt ganz ungeniert und strunzblöde nachfragen kann. Wieso hat extreme Hitze nichts mit Waldbränden zu tun? Die sorgt ja auch für Trockenheit.
Weil die Hitze nicht das Entscheidende ist, wie auch bei den Menschen, die überleben müssen. Wenn sie ein paar Wochen Dürre haben, wie wir das im Moment erleben, dann haben sie nichts mehr, um zu verdunsten. Und trockene Wärme reicht völlig, um einen Wald trocken zu machen. Wir haben Waldbrände auch im Winter. Das ist eine große Gefahr. Und diese Fehlkommunikation Waldbrände in den Sommer zu verlegen, weil sie etwas mit Hitze zu tun hätten, führt dazu, dass wir viele Waldbrände außerhalb der Saison haben. Die Hochsaison für Waldbrände ist im Frühling.
Ja, es gibt auch November, in denen es nicht regnet. Und die Hochsaison ist im Frühling. Und nur weil es im Sommer halt so warm ist, dass wir dann auch mal im Wald sind und deswegen Bezüge dazu herstellen, die wir im Winter nicht herstellen, heißt das noch nicht, dass es im Winter mehr gibt zum Verdunsten, sondern die sind dann einfach auch ausgetrocknet. Das ist ein ganzes Jahresproblem.
Bei mir zeigt sich das immer sehr schön. Ich wohne ja am Rhein, wie der Rhein gerade steht. Und dann kann das sein, dass man einen Wintermonat hat und da ist kaum noch Wasser drin. Und das heißt dann auch, dass es nicht geregnet hat. Insofern ist das ja richtig. Ich finde das ja im Übrigen sehr sympathisch, wenn Kachelmann so loslegt und da saublöde schreibt. Er hat mich ja auch kürzlich angegriffen, als ich die Schweiz als positives Beispiel davor rupe. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was er geschrieben hat, aber das amüsiert mich. Ich will eigentlich mehr Diskussionen mit Schmackes haben.
Wir hatten ihn ja auch mal im Aufwarn-Podcast, wo wir ein bisschen im Streit auseinander sind. Und ich ihm dann aber nochmal Studien, die ihn klar widerlegten, zeigen konnte. Ich finde das auch amüsant, wenn es einfach zur Sache geht. Und jetzt eben dieser ganz wichtige Punkt. Nicht nur ist es eben nicht einfach die Hitze, die ein Wald in große Feuerinfernos entfacht, sondern es kommt noch ein bisschen was dazu, über das man häufiger mal reden sollte.
Sie brauchen für einen Waldbrand 250 bis 300 Grad. Keine Lufttemperatur der Welt hat Gott sei Dank diese Höhe. Es brennt nichts ohne 250 bis 300 Grad. Die Temperatur kann noch so hoch sein. Und ich verstehe immer nie, wie die Leute sich vorstellen, wie es eine Sauna gibt mit 90 Grad, in der es Holzbänke gibt. Wie die Menschen das gleichzeitig aushalten. Und deswegen, ich bitte um Verzeihung für das Wort, aber bitte bebildern Sie nicht Hitze mit Waldbränden, weil das hat nichts miteinander zu tun. Wenn es einen Waldbrand gibt, ist das, wenn kein Gewitter da ist, ganz sicher Brandstiftung und Polizeidienststellen sollten sich nicht hinter komischen Schwurbedingen wie Glasscherben und Selbstentzündungen verstecken können.
So Waldbrände sind sehr wahrscheinlich immer Brandstiftung.
Und wir wissen, auch die Polizei hat Personalnot und die wird die Polizei mit Sicherheit nicht mal so prophylaktisch groß in den Wald schicken, oder?
Brandstiftung, vielleicht gibt es auch ein unabsichtliches Phänomen, dass man irgendwie dann doch mal da nur eigentlich grillen wollte oder am Ende flog irgendwas, sondern hat es entfacht.
Braucher wahrscheinlich, Kippe.
Genau, es ist eben sehr häufig auch dieses, ja, jemand macht sich einen Spaß und zündet einfach den Wald an.
Und im Waldrauchen ist ja eh verboten, nehme ich an. Ich muss gerade, ich denke gerade, wann ich das letzte Mal in einem Wald war. Und ich weiß es gar nicht mehr, solange es das her ist. Es ist mindestens zehn Jahre her.
Wald und unter Bäumen sein ist ja auch nochmal was anderes wahrscheinlich. Warst du damals nur in Plantagen, Baumplantagen und gar nicht richtig im Wald.
Doch, ich bin schon mal durch den Wald spaziert. Also aber nicht richtig gewandert, aber ich habe keinen Wald mehr gesehen seit zehn Jahren.
Ja, ich bin regelmäßig im Wald. Und Wälder, wenn sie brennen, das ist Brandstiftung. Wenn wir das jetzt einmal abstrahieren, können wir hier sagen, diese ganz konkreten Waldbrände, wo sich Klimawandel wirklich manifestiert, sind menschengemacht. So wie der Klimawandel allgemein ist auch der Waldbrand menschengemacht. Das hieße, dass wir, wenn wir Notlagen und Gefahrensituationen feststellen, wie hier, dass wir dann eben sagen, ja autofreier Sonntag. Wir müssen die Wälder dann wirklich sperren. Also da kennt man ja hier auch in den ganzen forstwirtschaftlichen genutzten Dingern. Da ist dann einfach wirklich abgesperrt und steht heute ist hier Jagd. Gehen sie nicht in den Wald. Dann denkt man so, ja gut, dann gehe ich auch lieber nicht rein, bevor hier noch angeschlossen werde und so. Aber könnten wir es uns in Deutschland vorstellen, dass wir einfach Wälder haben oder Baumplantagen, die wir so schützen wollen, dass wir einfach sagen, die können wir uns leider nicht mehr betreten. Wir müssen die Menschen jetzt raushalten aus dem Wald, was wir ja generell so machen. Aber dieser Rückzug muss jetzt einfach angetreten werden. Jetzt ist Not am Mann und an der Frau. Und da Kachelmann einfach immer ein Spektakel ist, hören wir noch kurz, was er zum Thema Hitze sagte. Er unterscheidet ja stark, haben wir ja gehört, zwischen Waldbrand ist das eine. Hitze ist nochmal ein ganz eigenes Thema. Und ich fand es einfach sehr bezeichnend, wie deutlich und wie häufig, und wir haben es auch eben schon gehört, bei Ihnen das Thema Hitze mit dem Thema Tod verbunden wird. Nicht irgendwie mit, ja dann leidet man aber und es ist auch unangenehm oder sowas. Sondern nein, das ist einfach tödlich. Hitze ist tödlich. Und da beginnen wir mal hier bei der Frage, Herr Kachelmann, Sie sind auch schon alt. Und ein Hitzetag in Deutschland heißt 40 Grad plus. Frankreich hat schon 45 Tage gehabt letztes Jahr. In Deutschland steht das Jahr noch aus. Werden wir es noch erleben zu Kachelmanns Lebzeit?
Einige Meteorologen haben letzte Woche noch Temperaturen in Teilen Deutschlands von bis zu 45 Grad für möglich gehalten. Das sind tatsächlich Szenarien, auf die wir uns mehr und mehr einstellen müssen.
Das war unseriöses Wichtig-Tun mit den 45 Grad. Das hat ein Modell zu einem Zeitpunkt mal gezeigt. Aber 100 andere Modellläufe haben das nicht gezeigt. Und man bekommt natürlich heute viel Aufmerksamkeit, wenn man solche wilden Zahlen sagt. Aber was sie schon richtig sagen, das ist im Bereich des Denkbaren. Also wenn die perfekte Luftmasse im perfekten Moment zu uns kommt und wir schon lange trockene Böden haben, dann sind 45 Grad nicht mehr außer Frage. Ich bin jetzt 64 geworden. Das ist möglicherweise schon noch das, was zu meinen Lebzeiten stattfinden wird. Weil eben bei so einer Wetterlage auch wichtig ist, wie warm ist das Mittelmeer? Das Mittelmeer ist im Moment 5 Grad, zum Teil 10 Grad wärmer als im Durchschnitt der letzten 30 Jahre. Und das spielt natürlich alles eine Rolle.
So, wenn es die Modelle schon zeigen, heißt es, das sind vielleicht dann nicht Prognosen für morgen, aber vielleicht für nächstes Jahr. Die Tendenz ist ja irgendwie klar, gerade wenn das Mittelmeer, ich meine 5 Grad zu viel, das ist ja wirklich, wenn man sich überlegt, wie viel Energie da gespeichert ist, also wie viel mehr Wasser noch abkann als Luft und so. Wenn das als Speicher irgendwann ausgereizt ist und die Luft kann es einfach nicht mehr abgeben ans Wasser, also dann ist einfach der Weg offen von Afrika hier rüber mit den Luftmassen und so. Und ich, weil er so sagt, ja so 45 Grad vielleicht später normal, wenn man in Frankfurt, und ich hab's jetzt im Juli auch wieder gemacht, 12 Uhr, 30, 13 Uhr, wenn die Sonne wirklich oben steht, ja, es ist am Ende des Tages immer noch wärmer als in dieser Mittagssitze, aber weil die Sonne eben noch so brennt, über diesen schwarzen Asphalt Richtung Hauptbahnhof fährt, wo die Sonne nun wirklich von vorne... Frauenhaft. Ich hab echt gedacht, wenn ich hier anhalte, bleibt mein Fahrrad kleben auf dem Boden. Und ich schaff's vielleicht nicht bis zum Straßenrand, wo es Wasser gibt.
Ich war ja dort im Hotel, als wir in der Oper waren, und ich muss sagen, die Stadt stinkt ja dann auch fürchterlich bei dieser Hitze, es ist richtig schlimm. Und was auch so interessant war, ich schaute aus meinem Hotel raus, auf lauter Luxusapartments. Und ich guckte dann mal im Internet, was die so kosten. Und dann ist man da bei horrenden Beträgen. Also wenn man jetzt mietet oder kauft, also es ist einfach nicht bezahlbar. Und man denkt ja, aber die sind jetzt da in so einer Betonwüste und es stinkt und man kann eigentlich sich nur alles runterlassen und sagen, ich dreh die Klimaanlage jetzt voll auf und bleib jetzt da und hare aus. Dann denk ich mir, und dafür hat man jetzt so viel Geld ausgegeben, also dann sieht man auch wieder, wie wenig der Markt regelt und wie ein sinnvolles Wohnen eigentlich aussehen müsste.
Ganz genau.
Das ist so absurd. Also selbst wenn man jetzt reich ist und sagen kann, ja ich kann mir natürlich hier dreieinhalbtausend Euro Miete für eine kleine Wohnung im Monat leisten da in Frankfurt, dann denkt man ja, aber wo besteht jetzt dein Luxus? Dann sagst du toll, du gibst dreieinhalbtausend Euro aus, aber welchen Luxus genießt du jetzt gerade? Du bist in einer Betonwüste und es stinkt.
Genau, die Vorzeichen werden sich glaube ich schneller als uns lieb ist. Also mir ist es egal, aber es gibt Investoren, die würden sich schneller umkehren als sie lieb ist. Denn in Frankfurt werden ja sehr viele Wohnhochhäuser gebaut. So, die auch alle im Balkon haben, was ganz fetzig aussieht, weil die auch bewaldet dann, also nicht bewaldet, aber begrünt werden. Also die sollen wirklich grün leuchten. Das kühlt natürlich, es ist allerdings trotzdem mitten in der Innenstadt. Das heißt, man geht unten auf die Straße. Und es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn man da einen Thermometer an zwei Meter Höhe hängt, dass das einfach wirklich 50 Grad anzeigt. Und in der Sonne nochmal mehr. Das fände ich nicht überraschend. Wir haben ja sowieso ein paar Probleme mit Frischluftzufuhr an der Stadt. Also nur der Main kann es liefern, aber eigentlich müsste noch was vom Norden kommen. Und da wird ja jetzt auch ein neuer Stadtteil geplant, wo eigentlich die Luft so ein bisschen noch in die Stadt strömt. Also, naja, die Stadt wächst halt dann da doch ein bisschen zu schnell. Aber noch ist es eben...
Es geht so heiter weiter. Wir hatten das vor ein paar Jahren in Koblenz. Da war ein Platz, den hat man immer vergammeln lassen. Und der ist ziemlich groß. Und dann dachte man, wenn man da noch was abreißt, vielleicht könnte man da doch eigentlich mal einen schönen Stadtpark machen. Und was haben dann die anliegenden Geschäfte und diese Schwachköpfe von der Stadt und sowas? Da werden dann bestimmt auch Drogenabhängige oder so kummeln. Das war die Angst. Was ist, wenn ich da ausgeraubt werde? Und was hat man stattdessen gemacht? Man hat eine Betonfläche und hat da zwei Malls draufgebaut. Der eine Mall ist eine überdimensionierte Bibliothek, die nicht genügend frequentiert wird. Und ein Rhein-Museum, wo ich sagen würde, werft das Geld lieber an den Rhein. Da haben die Reintöchter was davon, bevor ihr in das Museum geht. Das andere ist eine riesige Shopping-Mall, wo man die immer selben Ketten drin besuchen kann, die aber die jungen Leute gar nicht mehr besuchen, weil die ja im Internet schon bestellt haben. Also gehen die einfach dahin, um sich in diesem klimatisierten Ding ein bisschen abzukühlen. Das hat man da errichtet, statt eines schönen Stadtparks.
Ja, es ist Anfang 2022 hier in Frankfurt das demnächst neue höchste Haus der Stadt und damit auch Deutschlands verkauft worden. Für erstmals wurde in Deutschland ein Gebäude für über eine Milliarde Euro verkauft. Dann ging ein paar Tage ins Land und es begann der Krieg in der Ukraine. Dann ging noch ein paar Tage ins Land und es war diese Hitzewelle. Ich frage mich, was man als Investor so denkt. Wie das so die nächsten Jahre weitergeht. Aber noch sind die Preise entsprechend und es ist ziemlich bekloppt. Dankbarerweise, Kachelmann, das ist natürlich, man würde es am liebsten noch in die Alten Republik mit reinschreiben. In der Hinsicht sorgen wir einfach für Archive, die uns dann trotzdem zur Verfügung stehen. Kachelmann spricht ganz ausführlich über die Hitze und ihre Tödlichkeit.
Was für alte Menschen einfach wichtig ist, dass alle diese Tipps, die man so liest, von Fenstern zumachen und tagsüber verrammeln und so, das ist für viele alte Menschen ein Todesurteil. Viele alte Menschen sterben, weil sie leider solche Tipps bekommen. Das Gegenteil ist richtig, durchzumachen Oma und Opa je einen Ventilator vor die Nase, weil der Player beim Überleben ist nicht die Temperatur, sondern die Luftfeuchtigkeit. Und diese Luftfeuchtigkeit, die muss abgeführt werden, weggebracht werden. Das ist genauso pervers, wenn man den Leuten rät, als ob man den Menschen sagen würde, die keine Klimaanlage im Auto haben, ihr müsst jetzt das Fenster zu haben im Auto, sobald es draußen heißer ist als drin. Das ist nicht nur in Autos, sondern das ist auch in Wohnungen, vor allem in kleinen Wohnungen ein Todesurteil. Und da müssen wir noch sehr viel an uns arbeiten.
Ja, das ist eigentlich super interessant. Man muss es immer noch mal eine Ebene abstrahieren. Was er hier sagt ist, sie können eine Wohnung aktiv kühlen, aber sie können nicht die Hitze draußen behalten. Ja, es ist dann drin kühler, aber sie haben halt Folgeprobleme und die sind bei ihm einfach der Tod. Er sagt dann, er hoffnet, er ist dann tödlich, wenn sie das machen. Also es gibt, und ja, wir hören immer in Portugal, die bauen da Häuser ohne Heizung, aber was machen die dann im Winter? Irgendwann heißt es ja, wir bauen hier Wohnung ohne Klimaanlage. Was machen die dann im Sommer? Also irgendwann werden wir da auf diesem Track dann aufgesprungen sein. Du empfiehlst ja auch immer die Klimaanlage. Mal gucken, was das dann energetisch bedeutet. So insgesamt, aber es ist tödlich. Und Kachelmann kommt nicht nur bei den Alten immer wieder auf den Tod und die ernsthafte, auch irreversible Gesundheitsgefahr zu sprechen.
Wir haben katastrophale Ozonwerte schon jetzt. Zum Teil im Westerwald 163 Mikrogramm pro Kubikmeter Luft. Jetzt im Moment, das wird auch noch örtlich über 200 gehen. Das ist für Kinder und Jugendliche wirklich gefährlich. Mit zum Teil irreversiblen Schäden für die Lunge. Niemand spricht mehr über das Ozon. Es würde ein Tempolimit nicht nur da außerordentlich helfen. Wir sind nicht hitzefest. Irgendwann müssen wir auch darüber reden, dass man vielleicht zumindest in Krankenhäusern, Pflegeeinrichtungen, Klimaanlagen hat. Es geht sicher darum, die Klimakrise zu verhindern, so gut es geht, aber wir können nicht mehr alles verhindern. Wir müssen auch darüber reden, was man mit den Menschen tut, die unter ihr leiden.
Nicht mehr Klimawandel, sondern die Klimakrise. Als Folge des Klimawandels, aber sie ist jetzt Klimakrise. Und die Gefahr, die uns droht, ist der Tod. Und nicht irgendwas anderes. Keine Spirenzchen mehr um irgendwelche BIP-Sachen oder so, sondern es ist einfach der Tod, der uns droht.
Und wenn man auch darüber nachdenkt, mit Klimakrise und dem Umgang damit, dann ergeben sich auch andere Fragen, nicht nur was die Klimatisierung von Räumen betrifft, sondern auch, wie werden eigentlich diese Häuser entworfen? Denn wir haben diese unglaublichen Glasmonster überall. Ich hab's ja schon immer gehasst. Ich finde ja eigentlich nahezu fensterlose Häuser gut. Und ich hab das aber nie kapiert, wenn alle immer sagen, es ist so offen und freundlich. Und ich dachte mir, ja, genau, dann ist es unerträglich im Sommer. Und so hat man Bürokomplexe gebaut. Die Frankfurter Oper, wir saßen dort, bevor es losging, und nach zehn Minuten sind wir da weggegangen, weil die Sonne reinschien. Und es war gar nicht so heiß an dem Tag. Und es ist wie ein Brutkasten. Also auch das muss jemand gebaut haben, der nie einen vernünftigen Gedanken sich gemacht hat über Klimawandel. Ich glaube, der Architekt ist ziemlich berühmt, aber offenbar nicht besonders clever.
Ja, es gibt halt die Ästhetik und dann alle anderen Fragen, die man auch noch klären kann. Wir hören den letzten Clip von Kachelmando, weil er dann auch nochmal auf seinen eigenen Tod zu sprechen kommt.
Ich bin altersmäßig auch schon fast Opa. Und ich habe einfach das, was man braucht, zu überlegen. Ich habe Durchzug und ich habe einen Ventilator, Tag und Nacht vor der Nase, die mich anbläst. Weil auch das ist das Komische in Deutschland, dass man an so Dinge wie steife Nacken und das Durchzug krank macht, glaubt. Ich habe diese Krankheit an sowas zu glauben nicht und werde den Tag entsprechend auch überleben, so Gott will.
Jaja, das habe ich auch nicht verstanden, warum die Leute immer...
Und da hat sich die kleine Poante nochmal gegönnt. Sofern Gott will, es liegt also in Gottes Hand. Ich referiere nur kurz, dass sie in den Fernsehnachrichten tatsächlich davon sprachen, dass die trockene Hitze das schlimmste aller Unwetter ist. Das war so eine Expertenmeinung. Und man redet vom stillen Killer. Und das fand ich besonders bezeichnend, weil das eben wirklich eine Woche nach einem Jahr A und Erft Flutkatastrophe war. Wenn man den Leuten nochmal sagt, ja, aber es war zum Glück nur eine Flut. Das hatte ich nur einen Tag und alles war weg. Aber es ist eben die Hitze, die uns jetzt allen droht. Und die Trockenheit und so weiter. Da wird es dann halt ein bisschen anders in der Kalkulation. Und apropos Kalkulation. Die Bundesregierung hat jetzt mal selber nachgerechnet.
Der Klimawandel macht sich schon jetzt auch in Deutschland finanziell bemerkbar. Das zeigt eine aktuelle Studie des Bundeswirtschafts- und Klimaschutzministeriums.
Allein die Hitzesommer 2018 und 2019 und die Flutkatastrophe im rheinland-pfälzischen Ahrtal und in Nordrhein-Westfalen vergangenes Jahr haben der Studie zufolge mehr als 80 Milliarden Euro gekostet.
80 Milliarden Euro, das ist ja schon budgetauffällig. Das kann man ja durchaus mal mit reinnehmen, so Kalkulation. Und man muss halt immer wieder dazusagen, die Hitze, also wir reden bei 2018, 2019 von drei, vier Tagen über 40 Grad. Nicht von wochenlangem, sondern das sind dann wenige Tage. Und RfA, das war halt drei Tage Regen. Da ist noch ein bisschen Potenzial, um das sehr viel schlimmer zu machen. Und Dürre ist da noch gar nicht so eingepreist, aber die EU hat ja auch mal nachgeschaut.
Fast die Hälfte des Gebiets der Europäischen Union ist nach Expertenangaben derzeit von Dürre bedroht.
Für einen beträchtlichen Teil, konkret 46 Prozent des EU-Gebiets, gilt aktuell eine Dürre-Warnstufe. Das geht aus dem Bericht der gemeinsamen Forschungsstelle der EU-Kommission zur Trockenheit im Juli hervor. Für weitere 11 Prozent gilt demnach sogar eine Dürre-Alarmstufe. Mangelnder Regen habe dort schon Folgen für Vegetation und Ernte. Frankreich, Rumänien, Spanien, Portugal und Italien werden wahrscheinlich mit einem Rückgang der Ernteerträge zu kämpfen haben, erklären die Expertinnen und Experten des Forschungszentrums. In gewissem Maße seien auch weitere Länder betroffen, darunter auch Deutschland. Insgesamt sprechen die Fachleute von einer atemberaubenden Entwicklung.
Ja, also mehr als die Hälfte der EU ist Dürre-Gebiet, ausgewiesenermaßen nun. Das ist natürlich ein Drama und zum Abschluss nur zwei Clips. John Dürr ist, glaube ich, Partner bei Kleiner Perkins, oder wie das heißt, dieser riesige Investmentbude da am Silicon Valley. Er war im Podcast bei Kara Swisher zu Gast in Swae. Und sie fragte ihn so, ja, wie machen wir das jetzt mit der Klimakrise und so weiter? Und es ist wirklich verrückt. Für ihn ist das alles super easy. Also wir tauchen jetzt ganz tief ein in die völlig verfehlte und bescheuerte Ideologie, die da so durchgepeitscht wird in drei Clips. Zum einen, ja, wir brauchen nur neue Benchmarks und jemanden, der sie setzt.
Und alle, die einmal ausgemacht werden, werden vielleicht fünf oder zehn Jahre dauern.
Also ich kenne die weltweite Finanzorganisation, die internationale Monat, die Weltbank, um Kukikutter-Template zu entwickeln, damit sie den ersten Partei-Kranken erledigen können.
Die USA hat keine gute Gründe, Renewable zu erzeugen, wenn wir sie auf der Werte wollen.
Er beschreibt die Logik, die gerade gescheitert ist. Wir haben es ja hier auch. Blackrock, die alles revidiert haben. So klar, in gut Wetterlagen kann man diese Briefe schreiben im Januar und dann CEOs der Welt aufrufen. Aber wenn irgendwie Salzgitter droht, das Gas und damit die Energiegrundlage für die Stahlproduktion zu verlieren, dann schalten wir sogar Kohlekraftwerke ein. Und es war diese Woche besonders witzig, wie die Grünen nicht mehr ausschließen, die Atomkraftwerke auch weiter zu verwenden. Also da.
Na ja, und auch die Deals, die alle gemacht werden, ich meine, wir haben jetzt mit Aserbaidschan haben wir jetzt ein Gastdeal anbekommen. Und mit Ägypten.
Ägypten ist der Gastgeber der kommenden Klimakonferenz. Und Annalena Baerbock und die Bundesregierung haben den Klimadialog, also diesen Petersberger Klimadialog, den die dabei bei Bonn gemacht haben, genutzt, um schon mal mit Ägypten darüber zu reden, welche Gasvorkommen man da jetzt anzapft, als Vorbereitung für den Klimagipfel. In den UN-Klimagipfel in Ägypten, das ist wirklich die beste Gelegenheit, die beste Veranstaltung, um so ein Deal da einzufüllen.
Aber auch mit Aserbaidschan, das war so interessant, dass dann auch sehr viele, die ja ganz auf diesem Kurs sind, so Masalla, Bachmann und so weiter, Twitterkurs, auch dann so die linksliberalen, dann entschuldigen und sagen, wir müssen ja gucken, wo unsere Verbündeten sind. Und dann muss man aber sagen, dann könnt ihr nicht mehr sagen, es geht uns jetzt um die Menschenrechte, sondern dann sind das Interessenkonflikte zwischen Großmächten und wir zählen uns zu den einen und wir gehen militärische Bündnisse ein. Dann geht es einfach nur um Interessen und dann kann man das auch vertreten wegen mir und sagen, wir gehören halt zu dieser Seite und nicht zu der anderen. Aber dann kommt nicht mehr diese Menschenrechts-Skitsch an, denn ich habe ja ein gutes Gedächtnis, was manchmal sehr störend ist, wenn man nichts vergessen kann. Aber zumindest hatte ich in Erinnerung, es gab da noch von der Journalistin Anna Arizanyan, die sich sehr mit Aserbaidschan beschäftigt, einen Tweet Anfang April. 3. April schrieb sie, ahnen, was im Krieg als nächstes passiert, weil Putin fast eins zu eins Aliyevskrieg in Bergkarabach 2020 kopiert. Also was Aserbaidschan damals tat, kann man sehr schön vergleichen. Und dann zählt sie auf bisher. Angriff auf Zivilisten, Streu- und Phosphorbomben, Bomben auf Krankenhäusern, Kultureinrichtungen, Mirror-Propaganda, Söldner Hinrichtungen, Blockaden von Fluchtwingen. Und dann zählt sie jetzt alles auf. Also was damals geschah und was jetzt auch da bei Putin geschieht und was ihre Prognose ist, was kommen wird. Das hat sie am 3. April aufgeschrieben. Und das ist nun ein neuer Verbündeter. Ja, es ist absurd.
Die Puzzleteile fallen halt dann leider durch den Wind der Geschichte so, wie sie fallen. Und John Doerr, er hat uns hier den ersten Vorschlag gemacht, einfach Blackrock zur Besinnung bringen, damit die für uns die Investitionsanreize anders legen. Und wir wissen, genau das ist gerade gescheitert, nachdem Blackrock selber die Welt damit überrascht hat, dass sie es eigentlich machen wollten. Zweite Möglichkeit, ja, wir beschimpfen einfach die Konzerne, die das Klima schädigen.
So, one of the things that I think about is shaming. You know, shaming and taxing.
Do you think it's an effective tool to do that?
Also, dass man glaubt, dass das solche Riesen ins Wangen bringt.
Unglaublich.
Das mag für irgendein kleines Startup gelten, dass sich Grün auf die Fahnen schreibt und dann stellt sich heraus, nee, ist doch Schmutz. Dann kann man die damit vielleicht zugrunde richten. Aber was soll man auch damit, was soll man da aufklären? Also soll man sagen, eine Ölfirma ist nicht ökologisch? Oder wen soll man damit jetzt hinter dem Ofen erfolgen? Im Gegenteil, es gab schon, ich glaube, es war Ende 2021 einen längeren Artikel in der Wirtschaftswoche, dass gerade die Aktien von schmutzigen Konzernen unglaublich tolle Dividenden ausgeschüttet haben und dass sich so viele wieder auf diese Aktien verlassen. Noch verrückter, es bilden sich Fonds, die nur so schmutzige Aktien drin haben, die dann aber noch mit so einer rechten Identitätspolitik angefüttert werden. Zum Beispiel, wir haben in unserem Fonds nur Konzerne, bei denen die Chefs gegen Abtreibung sind. Sowas gibt es und nicht unerfolgreich.
Ja, und da steckt ja auch eine Logik dahinter. Also jetzt nicht bei dem, was du zuletzt genannt hast. Das ist dann so Ideologie. Aber bei diesem Geld sucht einen sicheren Hafen. Es droht eine Rezension. Wo soll es hin? Und dann schaut man sich genau an, wer wird hier eigentlich gerade wie versorgt? Wer hat gerade ein offenes Ohr bei der Bundesregierung? Und wenn man dann hört, BASF verbraucht 5% des ganzen Gases, was in Deutschland ankommt. Es ist einfach mega. Und dann sieht man aber den BASF-Chef im Fernsehstudio, weil er sich dann wirklich mal einen hat einladen lassen. Und Christian Sievers im CDF fragt ihn halt, können sie da nicht auf irgendwas und so weiter verzichten und umbauen? Und wie auch immer. Dann macht er gar keine Umschweife, sondern sagt einfach, das, was wir hier herstellen, braucht ganz Deutschland. Deswegen machen wir da auch kein Marketing oder sowas für, sondern das ist halt gebraucht. Und da können sie jetzt nicht kommen mit irgendwie Pipapo und so. Und da kann man so richtig fühlen, wie so ein Investor sich denkt, krass, ich geh jetzt mal in BASF. Egal, was passiert mit der Rezension, die müssen liefern. Weil ansonsten, also die sind so am Anfang der Lieferketten. Wenn die die Rohstoffe nicht liefern, dann ist die Deutschland AG einfach am Ende. Also wenn ein was hier durcharbeitet und wo der Scholz selber anruft, um zu fragen, ob der Laden läuft, das ist dann so BASF und so.
Ja, da muss dann selbst noch Porsche, muss da sich noch klein machen gegen BASF.
Absolut, da ist dann auch die Automobilindustrie, muss dann mal kurz warten mit ihren neuen Designer-Carbon und so. Wenn dann Audi irgendwie ihren neuen 3, die Zukunft des Automobils und so weiter, was man jetzt überall sieht. Ja, die brauchen halt Marketing, weil da könnte sich ein Kunde auch anders entscheiden. Das ist halt, wenn in Salzgitter da Stahl hergestellt wird oder BASF da irgendwas zusammenrührt in diesem Chemiezeug, das ist halt anders. Und in deren Sicht gibt es da, also Shaming ist, also da erreichst du bei BASF irgendwie so gar nichts.
Nee, das Geldtum zwischen sich und Hafen, wir werden ja gleich mal ein internationales Beispiel aufgreifen, wo man das gut sehen kann. Und da hat das mit Moral und Shaming und das sind überhaupt gar keine Kategorien. Das sind auch dann gerade bei diesen ganzen passiv gemanagten Sachen und so, das sind Automatismen, wirkliche Automatismen, die sich einstellen, dass man sagt, ach, da gehen wir jetzt hin. Das hat keine ideologische Erwägung mehr.
So und jetzt hören wir John Doerr zum dritten Mal und das ist sozusagen der Kicker. Er meinte eben noch Shaming ist über die moralische Linie fahren, über die öffentliche Meinung und so weiter. Das wärs, das müssten wir eigentlich machen. Und jetzt kriegt er eine super Frage von Kara Swisher, die nämlich einfach fragt, wer schafft es jetzt eigentlich besser? China mit ihrem restriktiven Modell, wo einfach zentral angesagt wird oder Amerika, wo man das über Profite orientiert. Und dass er, nachdem er so viel moral hier reingebracht hat und Black Hawk sollte ja mal und so weiter, also gegen jede ökonomische Logik BWL und VWL, diese Frage nicht eindeutig beantwortet. Aufgrund eines Ideologien, also wirklich dann mal, würde ich sagen, nimm dir lieber eine Ideologie zu der du stehst, aber dann stehe auch dazu, sondern hier so mal gucken. Ja, er ist unentschieden.
Aber es ist ein Wettbewerb, aber man glaubt wohl, dass sie sich in dieser Sache einig sind. Nee, man sieht das ja jetzt schon, dass wenn es im Weltraum schon nicht mehr zusammen funktioniert, dann mit Russland oder so, dann ist natürlich diese Konfrontation der Machtblöcke, die sorgt dafür, dass Kooperationen auf der Ebene des gesamten Weltklimas auch nicht möglich sind, weil man diese Interessen ja hat. Das sieht man ja jetzt auch gerade, dass wir sagen, wir müssen uns jetzt irgendwoher Gas beschaffen, um weiterhin auch konkurrenzfähig zu sein. Also das ist natürlich eine Logik, die überhaupt nicht mit der Klimakrise angemessen umgeht.
Ja, und wir kommen nachher noch mal kurz auf China zurück. Aber bei der Frage, lieber das Klima retten, aber dann in dem chinesischen System leben oder halt fröhlich in den Untergang, da wäre ich ein bisschen unentschieden, ehrlich gesagt. Weil nun dieses chinesische Modell...
Man muss natürlich noch mal sagen, also wir dürfen jetzt auch nicht in dieses apokalyptische Sprechen verfallen.
In das du das letzte Mal reinfielst?
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Ich meine, mein apokalyptisches Sprechen ist, dass ich nicht glaube, dass die Politik das maßgeblich ändern wird. Aber ich gehöre nicht zu den Leuten, die sagen, wir haben keine Zeit mehr, wir sind die letzte Generation. Also ich weiß schon, dass hier ein Leben möglich sein wird, auch mit den entsprechenden Hitzen. Ich glaube nur, dass wir darauf vorbereitet sein müssen. Und wir haben mal wieder das Privileg, dann eigentlich Geld dafür zu haben, um darauf vorbereitet zu sein. Und auch sind wir relativ gut geografisch gelegen. Ich bin gegen diese Untergangsstimmung zu sagen, und bald gehen hier die Lichter aus, und dann sind wir alle verbrannt auf der Erde. Ich glaube, dass diese extrem apokalyptischen Bilder nicht weiterhelfen. Ich wäre nur pessimistisch, was jetzt die Schritte der Politik anbelangt. Und da würde ich auch sagen, dass man mit einem gewissen Hedonismus für sich selbst, also der nicht meint, ich nehme jetzt auch mal ein Privatjet, wie Friedrich Merz, wenn ich zur nächsten Hochzeitsflüge... Ein Propellerflugzeug, aber es sei unglaublich ökologisch toll, das zu machen. So natürlich nicht, aber dass man jetzt nicht in so eine Stimmung reingerät, dass man sagt, es ist alles zu spät, wir haben keine Chance mehr und so. Das Leben hat auch sehr schöne Seiten und man kann zum Beispiel mal ins Konzert gehen. Also das ist etwas, wo ich sehr dagegen bin. Aber grundsätzlich müssen wir, glaube ich, diesen Umgang mit der Klimakrise viel mehr politisieren. Also das ist eigentlich das, was jetzt verlangt werden muss. Also die müssen gewählt werden, die für die Klimaanlagen sorgen, die für die Stadtparks sorgen. Das ist eigentlich das, was man jetzt verstehen muss. Na ja, wir blicken mal in einen anderen Teil der Welt, nämlich nach Sri Lanka. Und hören einen kurzen Clip aus dem ARD-Welt-Spiegel.
Es ist wirklich unbegreiflich, wir haben gar nicht mehr daran geglaubt, aber es ist genau das, was wir wollten. Seit mehr als 90 Tagen warten wir auf genau diesen Tag. Jeder Mensch in Sri Lanka freut sich gerade. Wir sind so glücklich und stolz.
Was ist in Sri Lanka passiert? Worauf ist man stolz? Wir hören nun Susanne Daupner in der Tagesschau, die das kurz zusammenfasst. Übrigens meine Lieblings-Tagesschau-Sprecherin.
Wegen ihrer etwas tieferen, deutlicheren autoritären Stimme.
Es gibt niemanden, der so toll spricht wie Susanne Daupner. Ich bin ein ganz, ganz großer Fan.
In der Hauptstadt Sri Lankas, Colombo, haben tausende Menschen den Rücktritt des geflüchteten Präsidenten Raja Paksa gefeiert. Der 73-Jährige soll sein offizielles Rücktrittsschreiben an das Parlament Sri Lankas geschickt haben. Es soll morgen veröffentlicht werden. Raja Paksa war am Samstag mit seiner Frau in einer Militärmaschine auf die Malediven geflohen. Nach Protesten gegen seine Aufnahme dort flog er heute weiter nach Singapur.
Es muss immer so ein bisschen so klingen, wie Deutsch ist meine erste Fremdsprache. Bei einem guten Sprecher.
Ja, ich weiß, was du meinst.
Das macht sie wirklich perfekt. Aber wir wollen ja jetzt nicht Stilkritik, sondern...
Doch lass mich noch mal nennen, weil Judith Rakas...
Nein.
spricht nun ein ganz hervorragendes, sauberes, fast maschinenartiges Deutsch, das eben nicht als überhaupt ist das Muttersprache, es ist Fremdsprache, nee, es könnte fast synthetisch sein.
Genau, aber das ist nämlich so interessant.
Ja, ich find's halt...
Ich würde sagen, das kann auch Siri.
Also ich verstehe, warum du da überhaupt bevorzugst.
Wir wollen, wie Susanne auch mal, ganz, ganz klar. Nun, also in Sri Lanka hat es einen Machtwechsel gegeben, die wütenden Bürger, die Demonstranten, die sich über sehr viele politische und auch ethnische Grenzen hinweg zusammengesetzt haben, haben nun diesen Palast gestürmt. Und sie haben es geschafft, dass der Präsident Gautabhaya Paksa geflohen ist und dass er dann auch zurückgetreten ist. Er ist der Bruder von Mahinder Raya Paksa. Das ist ja ein Familienclan, der seit 70 Jahren dort die Geschicke des Landes lenkt. Und nun gibt es einen neuen, ich hoffe, ich spreche den Namen nur halbwegs richtig aus, also der neue Präsident heißt Ranil Vikram Singh, der aber auch zum Teil dieses politischen Kaders gehört. Also es wäre vielleicht ein bisschen so, wie wenn Scholz zurücktreten würde und sagt ab sofort macht es Sigma Gabriel oder so. Ja, also dann hat man nicht was wirklich Neues bekommen. Das hatten wir doch mal.
Also Sigma Gabriel zurücktreten und Martin Schulz macht es.
Genau, also so eine Mischung ist das da. Also das wird die Demonstranten nicht gänzlich froh stimmen. Was ist da überhaupt los in Sri Lanka? Denn es ist ja so, dass dieser Raya Paksas Clan nicht immer unbeliebt war, sondern diese Familie war eine Zeit lang sehr beliebt. Das liegt auch daran, dass sie es geschafft haben, diesen seit 1983 andauernden Bürgerkrieg gegen die Liberation Tigers auf Tamil-Ilam, dass sie den beenden konnten. Also es gibt da diese Minderheit der Tamil-Bevölkerung und da hat man lange Zeit Krieg geführt. 2009 ist das dann geglückt, diesen Krieg zu beenden. Allerdings alles sehr blutig und Kriegsverbrechen und so. Müssen wir jetzt gar nicht von reden. Aber was sich durchgesetzt hat dann, eigentlich in den Zehnerjahren, war so ein singalesisch-buddhistischer Nationalismus. Also wir sehen hier wieder mal, wir haben ja schon über Modi gesprochen und Bolsonaro und so, wir sehen hier wieder mal, die Identität plötzlich zum politischen Kampffeld zu machen und zu sagen, wir sorgen dafür, dass unsere Identität, eure Identität erhalten bleibt und laden das auch noch religiös auf. Das ist das, was also diese Brüder Mahinda und Gotabaya gemacht haben. Das haben sie auch erfolgreich gemacht, weil sie ja weiterhin regiert haben. Aber nun ist dieses Land von vielen, vielen Krisen gerüttelt und geschüttelt. Einmal kann man sich vorstellen, da ist viel Korruption. Teilweise waren da 40 Familienmitglieder der Rayapaksas in der Regierung oder in anderen hohen Ämtern besetzt. Aber es gibt natürlich auch die Weltkrisen, die sich niederschlagen auf Sri Lanka. Und wir hören hier nochmal ein Clip aus dem Weltspiegel.
Im Moment gibt es niemanden, der für dieses Land verantwortlich ist. Ein Beispiel. Im letzten Jahr hat die Regierung sich über Nacht entschieden, nur organische Düngemittel dürfen in der Landwirtschaft eingesetzt werden. Es gab einen Aufschrei. Die Entscheidung war einfach falsch. Ich weiß gar nicht, wer sie unterstützt hatte. Dann, vor zwei, drei Monaten, reagiert der Präsident. Okay, ich hab die falsche Entscheidung getroffen. Aber wer ist dafür verantwortlich?
Jetzt geht uns die Nahrung aus.
Wir brauchen einen Systemwechsel.
Sag uns doch mal kurz, Sri Lanka ist ja dieser kleine Zippel vor Indien. Indien ist ja häufiger Thema hier bei uns.
Kommen wir noch zu, denn sowohl Indien ist natürlich an Sri Lankas Wohlergehen interessiert wie auch China und der Westen hat da auch eigene Absichten. Wir haben jetzt hier gehört, da gibt es ja mal irgendein Gesetz. Zunächst einmal könnte man denken, das ist ja gut so organischer Landbau, aber man hat überhaupt die Leute nicht darauf eingestellt und hat dann damit wieder eine kleine Katastrophe produziert. Die Inflationsrate lag bei 39 Prozent im Mai. Es gibt sehr viele YouTuber, ich habe aber diese Clips jetzt nicht mitgebracht, Travel-Influencer, die dorthin reisen und dann jetzt ihr Geld dort tauschen und sehen, was sie dann bekommen, wenn sie da 100 Dollar abgeben oder dann auch erfahren, nee, bitte zahlen sie nur noch in Dollar. Es gibt dann Travel-Influencer, die versuchen, ein Taxi zu bekommen, dann lassen sie sich nachher von so einer Rikscha durch die Gegend fahren. Also das wird dann ja so ein neuer Content, der da produziert wird. Krisen, Travel-Influencer, ganz fürchterlich. Auch da gibt es nie so eine Abstraktion mal über etwas. Das ist so ein bisschen wie diese ganzen Reportagen, die immer nur ganz nah ran zoomen, aber nie mal das Eigentliche erklären, worum geht es hier. Aber wir wollen dem ein bisschen auf die Spur kommen. Erst mal so zur Einordnung zu dieser Familie. Raja Paksa hören wir Andrea Sparlinger im NZZ Podcast Akzente.
Die Raja Pakses erreichten dann so ihren definitiven Aufstieg oder Höhepunkt schon fast 2005, als Mahinder Raja Paksa, der Bruder von Gotterbaier, zum Präsidenten gewählt wurde.
Und was macht er dann, dass er das oberste Amt erreicht?
Er setzt als Erstes sehr viele seiner Brüder in wichtige Ämter, also mehrere Brüder werden Minister. Unter anderem wird eben auch Gotterbaier nicht Minister, aber halt so die wichtigste Figur im Verteidigungsministerium und kontrolliert damit das Militär und den Geheimdienst.
Also das ist so eine Art Familienunternehmen, gleich von Anfang an, als Mahinder Präsident wird, 2005.
Genau.
Familienunternehmen, wir kennen das aus vielen anderen Ländern, zum Beispiel in der Türkei ist das auch so. Das ist so eine Rocketsstruktur, die sich dann da einschleicht und sich immer mehr verhärtet. Deswegen ist für Andrea Spallinger auch überhaupt nicht klar, ob es jetzt tatsächlich der Machtwechsel ist.
Nur weil jetzt Gott dabei ja weg ist, heißt natürlich noch lange nicht, dass sein Klan jetzt einfach verschwunden ist. Also die sind zwar jetzt verdrängt worden oder mussten zurücktreten. Sie sind aber natürlich die ganze Familie, die ganze Familie ist immer noch sehr präsent im Staat, in verschiedenen wichtigen Funktionen. Es bringt sich auch jetzt der Sohn von Mahinda in Stellung so als der natürliche Nachfolger.
Also die dritte Generation.
Die dritte Generation, genau. Und ja, die warten natürlich ab und hoffen. Aber ich glaube, es könnte doch sein, dass man es jetzt schafft, dass es da irgendwie einen Wandel gibt.
In Le Monde Diplomatique war über die Rajapaksa-Brüder folgendes zu lesen, jetzt auch in der aktuellen Ausgabe. Ihre Popularität bei den buddhistischen Singhalesen, die über 70 Prozent der Bevölkerung stellen, gründete sich auf den Sieg der Armee über die Tamilischen Rebellen im Mai 2009. Auf die Instrumentalisierung des Buddhismus und eine Rückkehr zu einer fanatisierten kulturellen Authentizität. Also sehr ähnlich wie das, was wir in vielen Ländern erleben können. Zu den Erfolgsrezepten des Raja-Paksaklans gehörte ab 2015 auch die Förderung eines extremistischen Buddhismus nach dem Vorbild Miamas. Als inneren Feind wird jetzt statt der besiegten Tamilen die muslimische Minderheit, die machen 8 Prozent der Bevölkerung aus, denunziert und vor einem angeblichen Erstarken des Islamismus gewarnt. Also da können wir schon sehen, warum Indien da ein ganz guter Kooperationspartner werden könnte. Oder China auch.
Das stimmt. Das sind ja sowohl Abgrenzung zu Pakistan als auch eben dann mit den Uiguren und so. Immer wieder dieser Islamo-Voge.
Tatsächlich gibt es Anschläge auf christliche Kirchen zum Beispiel oder auch auf Hotels. Also bei einem islamistischen Anschlag im Ostern 2019 kamen 258 Menschen ums Leben. Und das hat dann einen enormen Aufwind verschafft. Auch interessant, wie wenig wir davon mitbekommen. Ich lese auch dann hier laufend Zahlen und Fakten, wo ich denke, ja, aber das ist vor drei Jahren passiert. Warum weiß ich das nicht? Also warum ist das zumindest nicht in meinem Gedächtnis? In der NZZ war noch zu lesen, Gotter Bayer sorgte als starker Mann im Verteidigungsministerium für Angst und Schrecken bei Regierungskritikern. Dutzende von Journalisten und Aktivisten wurden entführt, gefoltert und ermordet. Politische Konkurrenten mit Killer-Kommandos aus dem Weg geräumt. Also in dieser Art wird da gearbeitet. Jetzt funktioniert das Wesentliche nicht mehr. Ich muss sogar noch mal die Infektionsrate ein bisschen erhöhen. Wenn wir auf den Juni blicken, da liegt die sogar bei 54 Prozent inzwischen. Und jetzt bei der BBC konnte man Folgendes vonnehmen.
Hi, this is Imran from Colombo, Sri Lanka. Right now people are suffering without any basic needs. Essential services are not running. One of the most important essential services of the country is the ambulance. None of the ambulances are operational because there is no fuel, when people cannot be rushed to a hospital in case of emergency. So they need to first stabilize the economy. They need to give the basic needs like gas, fuel, electricity. And then they have to slowly get on to increasing our exports, which bring revenue for the country so we can develop the economy. My car is parked at home for the last maybe 10, 12 days easily. There is no fuel. Personal lives are very much affected because even to get the basics, we cannot go out to the closest supermarket. And some items are not available. So, you know, it's very expensive for us to get even by certain day-to-day needs. And especially daily wage earners are struggling really bad. They can't even afford to buy a meal now.
Ich hab dann bei einem Travel Influencer gesehen, der fragte dann das Personal am Flughafen, wie sie das denn jetzt machen mit dieser Inflationsrate und sagten, die, naja, eine Mahlzeit weniger essen. Das ist dann die Antwort tatsächlich.
Genau, 50% Inflation kann man dann wirklich auf so ein Tageskonzert weniger kaufen. Kann man so einfach umrechnen? Na ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Also es ist alles 50% teurer. Also kann man ein Drittel weniger kaufen, irgendwie so. Aber es ist halt eine Mahlzeit.
Ja, ein Tuktuk-Fahrer äußert sich hier im Welt-Spiegel.
Benzin bedeutet für uns, dass wir Geld einnehmen können. Wir brauchen das. Es ist unsere einzige Chance. Wir finden woanders keinen Job. Keiner stellt mich an. Das ist die Situation, in der wir hier leben.
Touristen kommen natürlich auch jetzt weniger, aber nicht nur durch diese Krise, sondern durch die Anschläge, durch Corona. Es gab eine sehr restriktive Zero-Covid-Politik dort. Allerdings muss man auch sagen, die Reisefreude war eh nicht besonders groß. Also da haben die extrem drunter gelitten. Das bedeutet, wenn jetzt keine Energie da ist, denn das wird ja auch mal so ein bisschen hier aufs Duschen und Heizung runterdrehen reduziert. Nee, wenn keine Energie da ist, dann ist auch so was.
Das geht schon viel zu lange so. Es gibt keine Schulbusse, keine Autos, die uns fahren könnten. Alles wegen dieser Krise.
Die Schule fällt aus, weil die nicht in die Schule kommen. Es ist einfach keine Möglichkeit, dahin zu gelangen.
Ich denke mir ja immer, wir haben jetzt so viel Corona, Berichterstattung, hinsichtlich die Modellierer sagen und so. Das fehlt ja im Grunde gerade bei diesem Gasknappheiten, die erwartet werden, dass man einfach mal ein Modell sieht, davon es einfach durch simulieren. Also 15 Prozent weniger, worauf sich jetzt die EU geeinigt hat, oder 20 Prozent weniger, was wünschenswert wird, oder 30 Prozent weniger, was droht. Wie funktioniert dann die Volkswirtschaft? Ja, also fährt dann einfach jeder 30 Prozent weniger, also 30 Prozent weniger Mobilität und so weiter. Werden sie ja bei Corona eigentlich alles mal so aufgeschlüsselt bekommen. An dieser Art von Simulation fehlt. Und jetzt hört man sowas hier und denkt sich, ja, wenn die Modellierer das nicht machen, wo sind die Politikwissenschaftler, die uns mal vergleichend hier einfach Sri Lanka mal auch ein bisschen nahebringen irgendwie.
Es gab eine Steuerreform und da hören wir mal was aus dem Wall Street Journal.
Das hat die Räume, die die Räume in die Hand haben, immer noch sehr viel Geld in die Hand.
Da sind jetzt viele Informationen drin. Erst einmal wollte man mit Steuerreduktionen, mit dieser Steuerreform Investoren anlocken. Wir kennen dieses Symptom aus vielen Ländern. Nun hat das hier schon sowieso nicht so richtig funktioniert. Das liegt auch daran, dass in Sri Lanka zum Beispiel keine Ressourcen im Boden sind, die man jetzt besonders nutzen kann. Da ist einfach nicht viel, was sich lohnen würde. Wenn man sich ansieht, wie eigentlich das BIP verteilt ist, dann stellt sich heraus, 28 Prozent ist Industrie, mehr nicht. Und 59 Prozent ist Service. Und da können wir ja in Klammern dahinter schreiben Tourismus. Und dann gibt es noch sieben Prozent Landwirtschaft. Und das war's. Also wir haben hier ganz klar eine Wirtschaft, die eine Dienstleistungsgesellschaft ist. Und das macht es für Investoren dann vielleicht auch schwerer, da zu kommen und was interessantes rausholen. Oder es ist dann nicht genug, was man da rausholen kann. Nun haben wir auch noch gehört, sie verschulden sich. Sie müssen Zinsen zahlen, müssen sich wieder verschulden, um Zinsen zu zahlen. Auf diese Verschuldungsspirale kommen wir jetzt noch zu sprechen. Das muss nämlich sehr differenziert betrachtet werden. Erst noch mal so ein Eindruck, wie das schon in den letzten Monaten die ganze Zeit verlaufen ist. Noch mal Wall Street Journal.
Das war ein Punkt, wo die Energieverkaufung weniger verläuflich geworden ist.
Es ist sehr selten für relativ mittlere Familien, komplett aus dem Fühl und dem Öl zu sein.
Ein sehr trübsinniges Dasein, was da geführt wird. Und diese Blackouts haben sich immer mehr verlängert, bis dann 12 Stunden gar nichts mehr geht. Nun, wer ist denn eigentlich schuld? Also wir sehen jetzt schon, dieser Familienclan ist nicht darauf aus, eine besonders resiliente Wirtschaft auszubauen, sondern möchte eher sich selbst bereichern. Das ist schon mal klar. Aber das ist natürlich nicht das Einzige, was wir hier betrachten müssen. Noch mal Wortschritt Journal zum IWF, also Internationalen Währungsfonds, der da auch eine Rolle spielt.
Das Land ist aktuell in Gesprächen mit dem internationalen Monat für eine multibillionen Dollar Ausgabe, die die Regierung die Fonds, die es braucht, um die Wirtschaft stabilisieren zu können.
Kirchenklocken? Die erleiden wir jetzt einfach.
Die erleiden wir. Die warten wir nicht ab, sondern erleiden.
Nun gibt es ja dann noch was zu sparen.
Der internationale Währungsfonds kommt nämlich dann natürlich auf Ideen, nämlich man könnte jedenfalls mal sehr viel mehr privatisieren. Das ist ja etwas, was der internationale Währungsfonds eigentlich immer vorhat. Und warum nicht da weitermachen? Natürlich versucht der internationale Währungsfonds, nicht nur jetzt zu gucken, wie solide wirtschaftet das Land, sondern es geht natürlich um geopolitische Interessen. Ich empfehle da sehr einen Artikel, auch aus dem aktuellen Le Monde, die Geldverteilerbericht aus dem Innern des IWF von Renaud Lambert, der beschreibt sehr gut, wie der internationale Währungsfonds arbeitet und wie sehr er eigentlich auch immer mehr das geopolitische in den Mittelpunkt rückt und dann natürlich sagt, naja, wenn wir jetzt da den Erleichterung geben, kann dann China davon profitieren. Also lassen wir das doch lieber mal. Strauss-Kahn hat ja schon immer gern betont, wir sind keine Wohltätigkeitsorganisation. Und das kann man ganz deutlich sehen, wenn man sich das ansieht, wie mit Ländern wie Sri Lanka umgesprungen wird. Es ist also eine politische Sache und es geht dann hier so weit, der Wissenschaftler Freeland heißt es in dem Artikel, hat für diese Tradition, also wo investiert wird und so eine andere Erklärung. Er sagt, weil kleinere Länder eine etwaige Opposition zu den USA nicht durch Blockabstimmungen zum Ausdruck bringen können, müssen sie diese jeweils einzeln äußern. Die Macht, die die USA nicht nur im EWF, sondern generell besitzen, schüchtert diese Akteure tendenziell ein. Und deswegen wird man jetzt sehr genau auf Sri Lanka blicken, wie sie sich zu zum Beispiel China verhalten. Denn China hat jetzt gerade, das kam heute noch als Meldung, Angeboten, finanzielle Unterstützung Sri Lanka zu geben. Und Indien ist ja selbst interessiert. Wenn Indien interessiert ist, dann sind das quasi unsere Verbündeten. Und dann wäre der EWF dem wieder sehr gut gesonnen. Hier gibt es noch ein anderes Zitat von Paolo Noguiero Battista, der saß für Brasilien und zehn weitere Länder im Direktorium. Es ist also auch interessant, dass immer nur ganz wenige Länder so einen Hauptsitz haben, also USA, Frankreich, Großbritannien, Deutschland, Japan, Saudi-Arabien und China. Und die anderen müssen sich das immer so teilen. Und der sagt, der EWF ist eine hochgradig technische Institution. Seine Kreditvergabe erfolgt im Rahmen kodifizierter Verfahren, die von vornherein jegliche Willkür ausschließen. Doch wenn die politischen Prioritäten eines der mächtigen Länder ins Spiel kommen, tritt der Fonds seine eigenen Regeln mit Füßen. Und wir müssen deswegen erst mal das alles so mit Vorsicht genießen, wenn ihr gesagt wird, naja, Sri Lanka, die haben diese ganze Misswirtschaft vertrieben und das ist alles auch China schuld. Wir hören mal weiter, was die beim Welt-Spiegel im Podcast dazu sagen.
Es gab jetzt hier Gespräche mit dem Internationalen Währungsfonds und von diesen Gesprächen ist bekannt geworden, dass die Vertreter des Internationalen Währungsfonds anschließend gesagt haben, wir konnten kein Konzept erkennen, wie Sri Lanka schlüssigerweise diese Schulden in absehbarer Zeit zurückzahlen könnte. Und das ist das Hauptproblem. Eigentlich braucht Sri Lanka Geld, um wieder Güter zu importieren ins Land, aber auf der anderen Seite will keiner Geld geben, weil keiner weiß, wie er dieses Geld so schnell zurückbekommen könnte.
Na ja, werden die überhaupt das Geld zurückbekommen?
Ich meine, klar, das ist so die Logik des IWFs und so. Wir wollen, wir verstehen das als Investition. Nur China baut ja nun wirklich auch eigene Institutionen nach Vorbild von IWF und Weltbank auf, aber eben mit politischen Anliegen, denen dieses Return an Investment erst mal so ein bisschen egal ist, weil die ja selber 1, 4 Milliarden Menschen haben. Ob dann irgendwo noch mal ein paar Millionen Menschen eine Rendite erwirtschaften, ist ja wirklich nebensächlich, wenn man dafür Einflusssphären und so weiter gewinnt.
Nun, es gab einen Artikel von Jerome Phleps in Tribune Magazin und da sagt er, dass man sich eigentlich schon davon verabschieden kann, dass die jetzt mal gucken, einen schönen Plan aufstellen, wie sie diese Schulden zurückzahlen. Er sagt ganz klar hier folgendes, westliche Banken, Hedgefonds und Ölhändler, die aufgrund des Risikos hohe Zinsen gezahlt haben, weigern sich zu akzeptieren, dass die Pandemie und die Nahrungsmittel und Treibstoffkrise bedeuten, dass sie ihr Spiel verloren haben. Also man muss einfach sagen, die haben da auch Gelder gegeben und andere haben Gelder gegeben. Na ja, und dann kommen halt jetzt diese ganzen Krisen aufeinander. Sri Lanka stellt fast nichts her, importiert fast alles, was es ist und sonst so verbraucht. Übrigens 45 Prozent aus Ukraine und Russland. Ja, und da kommt alles jetzt zusammen und sagt er, ja, die haben das Spiel verloren. In den meisten Fällen erhalten sie weiterhin die von ihnen geforderten Rückzahlungen und Zinsen, während die Menschen in den einkommensschwächeren Ländern nur noch eine Mahlzeit pro Tag zu sich nehmen, um über die Runden zu kommen. Tatsächlich haben viele Gläubiger die Schulden wegen der Wahrscheinlichkeit von Zahlungsausfällen zu Schleuderpreisen gekauft. Bei vollständiger Bezahlung könnte BlackRock 110 Prozent gewinnen, mit seinen sambischen Schulden machen. Und dann heißt es weiter, durch diese Situation kann nicht von Dauer sein. Es ist unvorstellbar, dass Länder mit niedrigem Einkommen die Profitmacherei von BlackRock auf unbestimmte Zeit unterstützen, während ihre Bevölkerung ihre Lebensgrundlage verliert und sich nicht selbst ernähren kann. Viele Länder werden von Protestwellen erschüttert und die Regierung von Sri Lanka wird wahrscheinlich nicht die Letzte sein, die stürzt. Der Schuldenerlass ist eine Forderung der Demonstranten. In Tunesien verhindert die mächtige Gewerkschaftsbewegung, dass die autoritäre Regierung vor den Sparauflagen des IWF kapituliert und stärkt damit ihre Position in den laufenden Verhandlungen. In Argentinien hat ein Abkommen mit dem IWF die Regierung gespalten und Demonstranten gegen die Einhaltung der Auflagen mobilisiert. Also wir sehen eigentlich jetzt so einen globalen Protest gegen die IWF-Ideologie und damit aber auch eine westliche Hegemonie, die ausdrückt sich über Schulden. Also das ist unser Krieg, den wir da, wir haben ja schon über den wirtschaftlichen, den Finanzkrieg und alles gesprochen. Das ist unser Krieg, den wir gegen diese armen Länder führen. Und Flaps schreibt dann ein System, das es den Ländern ermöglicht, im Falle extremer Schocks die Rückzahlung ihrer Schulden auszusetzen und im Falle eines Bankrotts die Schulden zu erlassen, ist für die Bewältigung der Klimakrise sowie der Nahrungsmittel- und Treibstoffkrise unerlässlich. Die Welt kann nicht weiter in dem Wahn leben, dass alle Schulden bezahlt werden können und müssen, egal wie groß die Notlage ist. David Graeber lässt grüßen, sag ich mal.
Genau, also diese Entschuldung auf vielen Ebenen ist ja sowieso dringend nötig. Aber auch dieses Bild, das fand ich ja super albern von Habeck, der jetzt auch Russland immer unterstellt. Die tricksen ja mit ihrer Turbine und ist ja eigentlich gar nicht kaputt und so weiter. Und dann kommt mit diesem, wir werden hier von Putin ökonomisch angegriffen. Also Putin reagiert hier auf einen ökonomischen Angriff. Wir haben den mit den Sanktionen und so weiter gemacht. Und es steckt so tief drin in unserem ganz normalen, ja so machen wir das halt. Natürlich machen wir das überschulden, dass wir diese Amoralität, die da drinsteht, und eben, wie wir jetzt feststellen, dann auch diese gewisse Diss-Funktionalität. Denn was haben wir denn davon, wenn Sri Lanka da in Asien vor Indien und mit China da nicht weiterkommt? Was haben wir denn davon, wenn wir einfach einen riesigen Schuldenstand, inklusive so einer Forderung, ja, könnten die echt mal zurückzahlen? Und wir haben keine Idee, wie sie es zurückzahlen. Ja, dann müssen sie arm bleiben. Also, dass das nicht so bleiben wird, nur weil wir das so wollen, liegt da irgendwie auch auf der Hand.
Es ist traurig, vor allen Dingen, wenn man sich diese Konstellation China-Indien mal so gemütet wird, hier im Welt-Spiegel-Podcast.
Herr Heinze, kommen wir gleich zum Punkt. Wieso springen China und Indien zu Hilfe?
Sri Lanka, die Perle im Indischen Ozean, ist natürlich für beide Länder von hoher strategischer Bedeutung. Sowohl für Indien, das ja die Vormachtstellung hier in der Region hat, als auch für China, das Sri Lanka als wichtigen Ort sieht, um auch im Indischen Ozean Präsenz zeigen zu können. Mit Sri Lanka hätte China einen wichtigen Standort, wo auch mit Blick auf die Seewege, auf den Blick auf internationalen Handel China eine wichtige Zwischenstation hätte. China hat auch mit Blick auf Seehäfen, mit Blick auf Wirtschaftsstandort in Sri Lanka investiert und hofft natürlich auch so auf den indischen Subkontinent Einfluss ausüben zu können.
Und wieso hat Indien das Angebot erhöht?
Ja, für Indien ist natürlich Sri Lanka direkt vor der Haustür. Indien, welches ja auch ein relativ schwieriges Verhältnis mit China hat. Es gibt ja immer noch die Grenzstreitigkeit zwischen China und Indien. Es ist natürlich wichtig, dass der Einfluss an China in Südasien begrenzt bleibt.
So und nun hat China wohl den Zuschlag bekommen beziehungsweise haben die jetzt gesagt heute, dass sie Sri Lanka unterstützen werden. Man wird sehen, wie sich das entwickelt. Da kann man auch nichts genaues sagen. Wichtig ist aber auch anzuerkennen, da wurde richtig viel Misswirtschaft auch betrieben. Also es ist jetzt keineswegs so, dass Sri Lanka nur aufgrund von westlicher Finanzhegämonie oder so arm dran ist oder aufgrund von Chinas Machtambitionen, sondern vieles ist auch hausgemacht wurde, aber dann durch Kreditgeber aus dem Ausland unterstützt. Wir hören jetzt hier Emily Schmoll vom New York Times Podcast.
And at the same time that they were taking out billions of dollars in loans, they were using some of this money on projects in their home district, this place called Hamantota in the south of Sri Lanka, where there are no tourists, there are no famous beaches, but they used Chinese loans to build a cricket stadium named after the president, Mahinda Rajapaksa. In their home district, and they built an airport and they built a shipping port.
And did people come to the cricket stadium? Did people come to the things that they built in their home district?
No, they didn't then and they still don't.
Keisterstätte wurden da errichtet. Da sind Investoren ja auch gerne mal dabei, sowas zu machen und dann zieht man sie gleichzeitig raus und jetzt haben die da irgendein cricket Stadion, das niemand nutzt. Jetzt hat sie so deutlich gemacht, naja, das war dann mit chinesischen Geldern. Ich kann das jetzt nicht im Detail ausführen, das würde zu langwierig werden. Aber ich empfehle einen Artikel, der heißt The Chinese Dead Trap is a Myth. Und zwar ist der in The Atlantic erschienen von Deborah Proetigam und Mac Rithmire. Und die sagen schon ziemlich am Anfang des Artikels, die Trump-Regierung verwies auf Hambantota, also das ist diese Ort da, von der gerade die Rede war, um vor Chinas strategischer Nutzung von Schulden zu warnen. Im Jahr 2018 bezeichnete der ehemalige Vizepräsident Mike Pence dies als Schuldenfallendiplomatie, eine Formulierung, die er in den letzten Tagen der Regierung verwendete und als Beweis für Chinas militärische Ambitionen ansah. Dies ist eine Lüge. Und dann wird das im Detail ausgeführt, inwieweit das da sehr wohl mit rechten Dingen zugegangen ist und man da auch China nicht den großen Vorwurf machen kann. Zumal man wissen muss, ja Sri Lanka ist auch in China verschuldet, aber mit 10 Prozent und auch mit 10 Prozent in Japan. Und wenn man den Westen mitsamt seinen Verbündeten sieht, dann muss man sagen, die sind, Sri Lanka ist zu 81 Prozent im Westen mit seinen Verbündeten verschuldet und es ist nicht China und 5 Prozent sind in der chinesischen Währung die Verschuldung Yuan, aber 65 Prozent in US-Dollar. Also das gehört dazu. Ich kann diesen Artikel in The Atlantic empfehlen. Der ist schon, ich glaube, zwei Jahre alt, aber zeigt das nochmal sehr gut auf und wir hören aber trotzdem nochmal den New York Times Podcast, denn es geht hier nochmal um den Ukraine-Krieg. Sri Lanka. Ist hier auch nur auf einen Artikel verweisen. Er ist im neuen Deutschland erschienen von Stefan Kaufmann, einer meiner Lieblingswirtschaftsjournalisten. Der hat die Überschrift Europa saugt Gas aus der Welt. Und dieser Artikel zeigt sehr gut, wie sich die Preise entwickelt haben. Wir ächzen ja jetzt auch, wie teuer wird das Heizen. Und das ist ja auch alles berechtigt, das auszusprechen. Und das wird eine schlimme Belastung sein für die Haushalte. Aber Fakt ist auch, es ist ja nicht einfach plötzlich mehr Gas da, sondern wir kaufen das weg. Wir kaufen das von Ländern, die das brauchen, weg. Und die haben ohnehin schon eine hohe Inflation. Er sagt, hier, Kaufmann, damit stehen diese Länder nicht nur vor einer Energiekrise, sondern vor einer sozialen Krise und einer Finanzkrise. Ähnlich wie Sri Lanka, das bereits im Mai seine Auslandsschulden nicht mehr bedienen konnte, wo die Bevölkerung angesichts der explodierenden Lebenshaltungskosten die Regierung aus dem Amt gejagt hat. An den Finanzmärkten gilt es derzeit, eine ganze Reihe von Ländern des globalen Südens als pleitegefährdet. Von Pakistan und Laos über Äthiopien, Ghana, Kenia und Tunesien bis Äquador, El Salvador oder auch Argentinien, wo zehn Prozent der Bevölkerung unter der Armutsgrenze leben, die Inflation 70 Prozent überschritten hat und die Regierung die Dollarreserven ausgehen. So und da hat natürlich unsere Politik, wir beschaffen uns einfach mal das Gas und so kommen wir über den Winter, einen ganz klaren Effekt hier auf diese Länder und zwar ein extrem Das ist ein extrem drastischen Reflekt. Also die Volksaufstände, von denen Baerbock hier gewarnt hat, die finden in anderen Ländern genau deshalb schon statt.
Genau, man kann sich ja die Preisentwicklung angucken. Wie wir jammern über 9 Prozent allgemeine Inflation und Vervierfachung von Gaspreisen, da ist natürlich anders. Ist ja immer so perfide, dass ja eigentlich nicht weniger Gas gefördert wird. Nur weil die Verwertungsketten so durch verwirbelt sind. Ist das ja...
Die können noch mal ordentlich Gewinne abschatten, die nutzen das ja.
Genau, einige Länder, die krass profitieren. Saudi-Arabien verkauft gerade besonders viel selbst gefördertes Öl, weil sie für den eigenen Verbrauch das Importierte nehmen aus Russland, das ja irgendwo hin muss, jetzt wo es keiner mehr kauft. Also kaufen die wahnsinnig billig Öl ein und verkaufen wahnsinnig teuer ihr eigenes Öl dann nach draußen. Und dieses Geld fehlt ja dann auch woanders. Das sind ja alles diese Kalkulationen, die dann...
Und das ist so der Punkt, an dem ich denke, wir finden das ja beide sehr gut, dass man eine Kriegsführung hat, wo man sagt, wir schicken nicht unsere Leute ins Feld, sondern machen das über wirtschaftliche Sanktionen. Aber hier treffen wir ja zwar auch mit diesen Sanktionen Russland, das ist ja unbestritten jetzt so, da gibt es jetzt ja auch immer mehr Fakten, dass man sagt, das schmerzt die schon. Das sah ja anfangs so ein bisschen aus, wie erholen die sich da so schnell davon oder was? Nee, das trifft, aber wenn wir sehen, wie jetzt, dass wir sagen, nee, kein Gas mehr am liebsten aus Russland, kein Öl mehr aus Russland und so, was das für Folgen für diese ganzen Länder hat und für die Menschen dort, dann ist schon fast zu fragen, ob man das machen darf. Also ob das eigentlich richtig ist, ob man nicht sagen muss, ja, langfristig muss das Ziel natürlich sein, davon loszukommen, aber das ist dann auch eines der ökologischen Transformationen geschuldetes Ziel. Aber wie können wir eigentlich das noch rechtfertigen, dass wir diese Politik jetzt der Sanktionen machen, wo die anderen viel stärker noch drunter leiden als die Russen?
Genau, ich komme immer wieder auf diesen Bildband zu Detroit zu sprechen, wo nach 30 Jahren und dann sieht man so diese Fotografien einfach ununterscheidbar ist, ob da eine Bombe einschlug oder einfach nur ein ökonomischer Niedergang fotografiert wurde. Diese Fabriken sehen einfach genau gleich aus. Die sind einfach in sich zusammengestürzt. In deren Sicht werden diese Folgen dieser ökonomischen Intervention einfach radikal unterschätzt und auch nicht ausreichend thematisiert. Also wie gesagt, das habe ich hier einfach behaupten kann, wir würden von Russland angegriffen, nachdem wir jetzt 100 Tage und was für ein Wirtschaftskrieg dafür in gegen Russland, da müssen die Journalisten auch nochmal drüber nachdenken, wie konnte das passieren, dass der Habeck so reden kann, ohne dass es auffällt, wie absurd das ist?
Womit man ja gar nicht sagen muss, dass das Falsches zurückgeht, aber man muss auch sagen, es ist halt ein Krieg, in dem man sich befindet. Also ich kann mich auch nicht wundern, wenn ich auf dem Tennisplatz stehe, dass dann schon mal der Ball zurückkommt, den ich losgespielt habe. Wir hören noch einen Clip aus dem Bloomberg Podcast, Siyat Dahood über den Haircut für Sri Lanka. Das ist ein großer Frage, ob wir schnell eine Verstrukturung von Geld haben können. Es braucht einen Hitschreiber von 50%.
Also jeder, der Geld aus Sri Lanka lehnt, verliert nur eine Hälfte ihres ehemaligen Investments?
Aber wenn man sich die historischen Episoden der Schuldrestruktur von 1998 bis 2010 anschaut, ist das eigentlich im Mittelpunkt. Aber auch, also Sri Lanka ist kein Erleiter in diesem Sinne. Also es sind noch erste Tage für Sri Lanka. Ja, da lacht der Moderator, das ist aber hart. Man muss auch sagen, die sind zu Boom-Zeiten auf die Idee gekommen, ach, vielleicht können wir da auch noch ein paar Dollar schnell machen. Und sind da reingegangen und jetzt, wo es ein bisschen unsicher wird, sagen die alle, na, jetzt wollen wir aber mal wieder schnell das Geld haben oder ganz hohe Zinsen haben. Das ist eine Investorenlogik, die man aus der Investorenlogik heraus verstehen kann, aber die muss man nicht zum Maßstab von allem machen.
Ich finde auch, wenn der darüber lacht, dass sie dann auf 50 Prozent ihres Vermögens, was auch immer das bedeutet, verzichten sollen, ich würde sagen, man kann genauso darüber lachen, dass da noch jemand diese Renditeerwartung aufrechterhält. Ja, weil das ist ja eh, wo soll es denn herkommen? Wenn jetzt alle feststellen, ja, es kann nirgendwo herkommen, dann gibt es das einfach nicht, auch wenn das noch in den Büchern steht. Dann kann man auch der Realität mal ins Auge sehen.
Und gewisserweise haben sie es ja selbst produziert, wenn sie ja selbst ihr Geld abziehen, um in die sicheren Häfen zu gehen. Dann können sie sich ja dann nicht wundern, dass das, was noch in den Entwicklungsländern in den Schwellenländern ist, dass das nicht mehr funktioniert. Also das ist so perfide. Es ist einfach, man möchte immer nur es wie die Sonnenuhr machen, nur die schönen Stunden zählen. Ja, und das geht halt nicht. Sondern man kann ja auch sagen, wer sagt, ich muss da mal ein Bauprojekt in Sri Lanka da investieren oder so, da geht natürlich ein Risiko ein. Er hofft sich aber auch entsprechende Profite. Aber das ist ja auch dann quasi eingepreist, das Risiko. Also ich kann ja auch nicht einfach irgendjemand auf der Straße anfangen, mein Geld zu verteilen, der Hoffnung, dass der mir immer da ordentliche Renditen bringt. Das ist total absurd. Und es ist nur dann so ein System wie IWF oder so und die Macht der westlichen Staaten, die das unterstützt, dass es überhaupt, dass die das noch einfordern können. Also dass die nicht einfach sagen können, ja, was denn?
Das stimmt, wenn der IWF sich da komplett rausziehen würde, dann können es alle nur noch einsehen einfach.
Ja, aber das wird vermutlich nicht kommen. Jetzt noch vier Clips von dem YouTube-Kanal Money and Macro. Da geht es jetzt mal um die Frage, was hat es eigentlich jetzt mit der USA zu tun, was da gerade in Sri Lanka passiert?
Denn sicher ist Sri Lanka ziemlich weit von den USA. Jedoch, wie die meisten erhebenden Marken, ist Sri Lanka auf der globalen, dollarbasierten Finanzsystem zu fundieren. Und das ist das, was die USA zu der Todeszeit der Sri Lankan Wirtschaft verbindet. In der Linie mit US-Ekonomie, ist Sri Lanka in etwa 2001 mit den Kapitalkontrollen und dem Verkaufsrat entspannt.
Die FED als die Zentralbank der Welt, so hat die Aldo Tus beschrieben. Da hängt dann alles an Amerika.
Ganz genau.
Das erste Problem ist, dass die globalen privaten Investoren nicht unbedingt um die Projekte, die makro-ökonomisch nachhaltig sind, um sich die Rechnungen schnell zu erlangen. Es gibt also vieles von diesen privaten Investoren in Sri Lankaner boomenden Marktstöcken und Inhalte.
Die nicht sofort helfen, wenn man einen großen Verlustverlust hat.
Das zweite Problem ist, dass die internationale private Kapital. Global financial booms such as these tend to be boosted by low interest rates in the United States. Conversely, dollar-based private finance tends to run home when the US raises interest rates, setting in motion a bust everywhere. So did US interest rate hikes scare international private investors into killing Sri Lanka's economy?
Wir konstatieren, die Politik der Zentralbanken, FED, allen voran, aber auch EZB, sorgt jetzt dafür, dass es nicht nur hier für Häuslebau oder so schwer wird, sondern auch dafür, dass überall Geld abgezogen wird aus Ländern, die es eigentlich brauchen können, da die Zinsen steigen, die Kredite nicht bedient werden können und die Bevölkerung darunter leidet.
Genau, und gerade zu diesem sicheren Hafenargument, was er eben brachte, wenn die Zinswende da ist, und sie ist ja nun da ein halber Prozent mehr hier in Europa, heißt eben, jeder guckt noch mal auf sein Portfolio und sieht dann irgendwie, ja, vielleicht brauche ich doch mal ein bisschen Sicherheit, jetzt wo alles eine Turbulenz ist. Deswegen dieses Spreads, dass die Italiener da wieder Sorgen haben, ist irre und es ist wieder mal crazy, dass wir innerhalb eines Monats, also dieser Tage war die erste wahrscheinlich einzige Anhörung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts, wo die Kläger noch mal vorstellig werden durften, wegen diesen 750 Milliarden, erstmals verschuldet sich die Europäische Kommission.
Ein schöner Tagesschaubericht habe ich gesehen.
Genau, wir bekommen also irgendwann demnächst so ein Urteil, wo wieder gesagt wird, ja, das hat die EU-Kommission schon nicht so richtig gemacht und wir uns dann wieder fragen, ja, und soll sie es jetzt zurückzahlen? Also wir werden, das ist ja genau wie da im Mai 2020.
Das wird dann wieder so kommentiert. Aber sicher ist auch, dass das eher die Ausnahme bleiben soll. Weil man denkt, nein, jetzt beginnt es erst richtig mit den Ausnahmen.
Genau, und es wird auch wieder so ein Urteil sein, das kann man ja jetzt schon sich vor seinem geistigen Auge vorstellen. Ja, das Bundesverfassungsgericht gibt den Klägern erst mal Recht, aber der Bundestag kann das Problem einfach lösen, indem sie nochmal bei der EU-Kommission nachfragen, ob das Geld dann auch vernünftig verwendet wurde. Die EU-Kommission kriegt also nochmal so eine Berichtspflicht oder sowas und der Bundestag sagt dann, ja, das haben sie sehr gut verwendet und damit, wie beim letzten Mal, sind sie dann fein raus. Aber bedeutet eben, wir verhandeln sowas gerade in Deutschland, während die EU-Kommission natürlich schon daran arbeitet, bzw. in dem Fall dann die EZB, aber das kann sie ja auch nur sozusagen unter Aufsicht der EU-Kommission so ein bisschen machen Europas, dass natürlich demnächst die Anlauer-Kaufprogramme nicht mehr symmetrisch laufen, sondern bevorzugt erstmalig dann italienische Dinge aufgekauft werden, um diese Zinsunterschiede wieder einzufangen. Und da war ja schon der Ton entsprechend im deutschen Fernsehen. Ja, das sind so fragwürdige Vorschläge, das ist ja umstritten und so.
Das ist mir jetzt auch aufgefallen. Ich habe mit einer bekannten Tagesschau geguckt. Zufällig hatte sich das ergeben und da gab es diesen Beitrag über das, was da jetzt gerade in Karlsruhe verhandelt wird. War das jetzt alles rechtens? Und es war ein Beitrag, bei dem ich ja meine Bekannte, die keine Ahnung von diesen Dingen hat und da nicht drin ist, also die jetzt weiß, was in Karlsruhe verhandelt wird und die weiß, was die EZB ist, aber die wusste jetzt nicht, worum es da eigentlich geht. Und dann habe ich sie danach sofort gefragt, hast du den Beitrag verstanden? Also weißt du, worum es geht? Dann sagte sie nein, überhaupt nicht. Und dann haben wir so darüber gesprochen und was sich eigentlich nur rauskristallisiert aus diesen Beiträgen mit solchen Flippen wie wir müssen aber sehen, dass dies eine Ausnahme bleibt. Und diesem Tonfall ist das einzige, was sich daraus kristallisiert ist, die machen da wieder irgendwas. Ja, die machen da wieder so Dinge. Das ist für uns Deutsche nicht gut. Also man könnte eigentlich auch noch so lancieren, mit der D-Mark, das war damals noch was. Ja, also das ist eigentlich der Thema. Und ich finde das wirklich beschämend, wie diese Berichterstattung da in der angeblich renommiertesten Nachrichtensendung stattfindet. Den Inflationsberichterstattung wollen wir gar nicht sprechen. Du hast es ja im Fernsehpodcast angesprochen, wenn dann immer gesagt wird, die Inflation von 1923 liegt den Deutschen im kollektiven Gedächtnis. Nein, die holt ihr jeden Tag medial hervor. Deswegen denken die Leute daran. Das war ja auch bei diesem Aspektebeitrag, diesem ganzen Feature, wo Ulle und ich vorkamen zum Thema Inflation. Da waren ja viele kompetente Leute, damit meine ich nicht uns zu Gast, zum Beispiel Aaron Sauer oder Adam Toos. Und dann hat man Adam Toos, das ist wahrscheinlich der bedeutendste Wirtschaftshistoriker unserer Tage. Und das einzige, was man ihm machen lässt, ist, dass er noch mal einen Satz sagen kann, ja, es war damals furchtbar mit der Inflation. Das kann man sich ja vorstellen. So, mehr darf er nicht sagen. Dafür brauche ich aber nicht Adam Toos in einem Videocall.
Es sind einfach körperliche Schmerzen, die man durchleidet, wenn man diese Nachrichten schaut. Wolfgang, ja, du hast kein Smartphone.
Nein, doch, ich habe eins. Du weißt, dass ich nur für Instagram und habe bin damit nicht als ich hab keinen Vertrag.
Du hast es nicht unterwegs. Genau.
Du hast es nicht bei dir, wenn du mobil bist, sondern habe es schon mal mitgenommen, weil ich ja dann, wenn ich im Hotel bin, mich auch mit dem Laptop dann da so verbinden kann, wenn ich was bei Instagram posten muss.
Na ja, dann klären wir jetzt, dass du demnächst – wir wissen nicht genau wann, aber es dauert nicht mehr lang – keine Person mehr bist.
Wie?
Du bist dann zwar in Gesellschaft, unterwegs, irgendwo, aber du wirst vorstellig werden und sagen, hallo, ich bin Wolfgang Schmidt. Dann sagen sie, ja, dann zeigen sie mal ihre Papiere. Und dieses Zeigen sie mal ihre Papiere wird jetzt geupgraded auf, ja dann zeigen sie mal ihr Smartphone. Und du wirst keins haben. Und damit werden sie dir sagen, sorry, dann können wir sie hier nicht. Wir wissen gar nicht, wer sie sind. Kann ja jeder behaupten.
Es bieten sich also nur zwei Möglichkeiten an. Entweder schaffe ich mir dann auch ein Smartphone an. Oder ich sehe zu, dass ich so gesichtsprominent werde, dass alle sagen und hier ist er natürlich Wolfgang Schmidt.
Auch da machen wir gleich einen historischen Abriss. Kann durchaus sein, dass du wieder erkennbar bist. Aber deine Kleidung alleine wird dir so wenig helfen, wie irgendwann, als die Fugger die Macht übernommen haben, die ästhetische Herrlichkeit des Fürsten. Das zählt dann einfach alles nicht mehr. Und wir wissen ja gerade, in welchem Zustand das Silicon Valley so ist. Ich trage mal aus dem Social Media Watch Blog ein paar Zahlen vor. Nachdem es gigantische Beschäftigungswachstüme gab in den letzten zehn Jahren, also irgendwie Facebook von 50 auf 100.000 Mitarbeiter und so was, Google strebt irgendwie auf die 200.000 Mitarbeiter zu und so weiter, das erste Mal Kündigungswellen. Google hat einen Einstellungsstopp und zwar so richtig, ach du Scheiße, wir haben unsere Zahlen gesehen, E-Mail an alle, die nächsten zwei Wochen wird hier niemand eingestellt, wir müssen alles nochmal begutachten und so weiter. Krasse Kommunikation.
Bei Meta sowieso.
Also bei Meta vor allem, da hat der Head of Engineering, Maher Sabah, wirklich harte Mails geschrieben an die Leute und bei Google hat sich Sundar Pichai selbst zu Wort gemeldet und die Mitarbeiter nochmal zur Disziplin und Ordnung gerufen. Also das Lotterleben hat ein bisschen ein Ende. Snap, Spotify, Microsoft, alle reduzieren die Zahl, mit denen sie Einstellungen machen. Entlassungswelle bei Netflix, 300 Leute sind da gegangen.
Obwohl Netflix dann noch ein bisschen besser performt hat, als gedacht. Also man dachte, die verlieren vielleicht zwei Millionen Abonnenten, haben dann nur knapp eine Million verloren. Aber das ist immer noch ein Verlust. Und die werfen sehr viel Geld in große Töpfe. Und das versickert aber dann da. Also damit meine ich jetzt mit großen Töpfen. So Filme wie The Grey Man mit Ryan Gosling, der Hauptmodell, ist eine Netflix-Produktion. Ist gleichzeitig auch im Kino gestartet, sollte dann so ein Hype werden. Ist total gefloppt. Kann ich auch verstehen. Ich habe den Film gesehen. Es taugt wirklich überhaupt nichts. Und Netflix versucht ja auch jetzt wieder, sich ein neues Modell zu überlegen, in dem sie mit Werbung arbeiten wollen.
Da sind ja alle sehr skeptisch.
Also werden Leute bereit sein, Netflix zu nutzen für einen verminderten Betrag oder fast keinen Betrag und dafür Werbung über sich hergehen lassen. Funktioniert dann dieses Modell noch? Ich meine, Amazon Prime arbeitet ja auch mit Werbung, dass sie so Flächen in Serien zum Beispiel verkaufen. Also dass du dann in einer Serie werben kannst und auch für eine gewisse Zeitung kommt das wieder weg. Also du merkst auch, da gibt es dann auch nicht mehr das Original irgendwann der einer Serie, sondern die endet sich dann mit der entsprechenden Werbung. Aber das ist natürlich ein Modell für Netflix, obwohl die ja ohnehin schon ganz viel mit Product Placement machen. Aber wenn es jetzt wirklich so Werbung ist im Sinne von, wie man guckt YouTube und hat da Werbung, dann frage ich mich, ob das angenommen wird. Also dass Leute sagen, ja, ich war nie bereit, zehn Euro zu zahlen, aber für drei Euro mache ich und habe dann Werbung dafür.
Spotify macht es ja auch ein bisschen so.
Ja, ob das jetzt aber so nochmal so nachträglich geht, weiß ich nicht. Und dann ist ja sowieso der Werbemarkt im Schwinden begriffen, weil natürlich das immer was ist, wo als erstes gespart wird, wenn eine Krise ist, dann sagt man, ah ja, Werbebudgets. Und da sind dann gerade die, die schon etabliert sind, ein bisschen besser dran, als jetzt nochmal jemand, der neu kommt und sagt, ihr könnt hier auch noch werben.
Genau, TikTok zum Beispiel hat ja gar kein inhaltliches Budget, so wie Netflix, die ja dann echt so investieren einfach in Content. Das ist ja bei TikTok nicht. Weshalb da kein Sparpotenzial da ist. TikTok schrumpft also wirklich in der Belegschaft. Da geht es wirklich runter. Und jetzt hat Meta-Quartalszahlen veröffentlicht. Das erste Mal ist der Umsatz von Facebook nicht gestiegen, sondern sogar gefallen. Und die Umsatzprognose für das dritte Quartal, ja, hat alle so ein bisschen erschrocken. Also da wollten sie auch wirklich mal als Erwartungsmanagement so ein bisschen, mussten sie mal in die Hand nehmen. Google hat noch gute Zahlen vorgelegt. Die machen ja weiterhin ihre 60 Milliarden Umsatz mit Werbung. Zehn Prozent davon YouTube. Ich hätte gedacht, es ist irgendwie mal mehr, aber die Google-Suche ist immer noch riesig. Derzeit schon offenbar. So insgesamt gegen TikTok ist es dann doch schwer. Snap natürlich auch. Und man hat jetzt, du hast es gesagt, diesen großen, diese große Furcht, die große Angst vor dem Einbruch des Werbemarkts, weil der ist nun mal das, wo die Unternehmen, die werben wollen, als erstes ihre Budgets kürzen. Und das nächste Quartal wird da also interessant. Wir sehen also Geschäftsmodelle in Not. Man braucht was Neues. Und jetzt hören wir uns ein zwei Jahre altes kleines Werbevideo an, das so langsam ernst genommen werden muss. Es geht um die FIDO Alliance. Was das alles bedeutet, das ist natürlich eine Abkürzung. Hören wir alles. Der Sing-Sang ist so.
They're a hassle for customers and employees to manage and they're a liability for your organization. Plus they expose you to data breaches, which can cost you even more money and damage your reputation.
Passwörter sind schlecht und alle Argumente dazu sind ökonomischer Natur. Du willst als derjenige, der einen Service anbietet, nicht so sehr auf Passworte, weil die kommen dann weg von den Kunden, dann nutzt das jemand anderes. Passwort teilen bei Netflix und so weiter, dann nutzen zwei Leute den Account. Und kennt man ja alles, ist alles blöd im Businessumfeld. Es ist auch noch gefährlich, wenn irgendwie die Accounts kompromittiert werden, weil irgendwer sein Passwort nicht schützen kann. Aber da gibt es dann bald eine Lösung. Also wie gesagt, es ist hier so zwei Jahre alt.
Fido ist Bad News für Cybercriminals. It prevents even the most sophisticated fishing attacks.
Also FIDO tritt an, das Passwort abzulösen. So als Prinzip einfach ein neues Paradigma.
Und FIDO ist ein Start-up.
FIDO ist kein Start-up im klassischen Sinne, sondern es ist nur so strukturiert, sondern es ist eine Allianz aus allen, die bislang Passwörter nutzen. Also Microsoft, Apple, Google, alle. Alle, die Kunden haben, die sich mit Passwörtern bei den jeweiligen Anbietern authentifizieren.
Und die haben sich zu so einem G5-Gipfel zusammengetan. Oder wie stellt ihr das vor?
Also stellst du dir ruhig auf der Ebene vor, dass es hier infrastrukturelle Maßnahmen sind, als würde man das Internet selber mal kurz umbauen an einer Stelle, um danach die Services darauf anders betreiben zu können. Und das Ziel ist, das Passwort auszumerzen. So, damit ist das Ziel markiert.
Dann sehen wir auch schon eingeblendet, wer da alles dabei ist, die Ingenbank, Amazon, Samsung, PayPal, Facebook, alles.
Genau, es sind einfach alle dabei. Das kann man in dem Falle wirklich mal so sagen. Alle Banken, alle Internet-Services, alle.
Also es ist fast schon, es ist nicht G7 oder sowas, sondern es ist schon UN.
Ja, das ist hier Wasser, Luft, Erde, Pfeil und Passwörter. Genau, das ist so richtig all in. Und das ist sozusagen zum Einstieg in die Corona-Pandemie wurde das halt so veröffentlicht. Wollen wir mal machen, ist unser Ziel. Und da dachte man sich wahrscheinlich während Corona, ey komm, wir gehen jetzt mal so unsere großen Projekte einfach mal an. Und entsprechend spuren wir jetzt zwei Jahre vor in die jüngste Apple Keynote, die ja jetzt Ende Juni oder Anfang Juli stattfand. Und wir hören uns mal eine Minute 52 an. Denn ja, das ist natürlich tiefschöpfend, aber Apple steht natürlich auf der Bühne, will ihr Computer verkaufen und so weiter. Aber diese zwei Minuten haben sich dann mal genommen gegen Ende, um Folgendes vorzustellen.
Sie können auch direkt auf ein Website zu den Passwörtern, die auf ihrem Server gebraucht werden. Wenn die User einen Passwörter kreieren, wird ein einzigartiger digitaler Schlüssel für den Sitz, den er für sich kreiert hat, kreiert. Passwörter können nicht geflasht werden. Da Passwörter nie deine Appen verlassen, können Hackere nicht dich auf einem falschen Website verbreiten. Passwörter können nicht verleaket werden, weil nichts secretes auf einem Websever gehalten wird. Passwörter sind sicherlich über Apple-Devices gesinkt, mit der iCloud-Keychain, und sind sofort auf Mac, iPhone, iPad und Apple TV disponibel. Wir haben mit Industrielehrern in der Fido-Allianz gearbeitet, z.B. Google und Microsoft, um zu verhindern, dass Passwörter sehr viel auf der Plattform arbeiten.
So, er hat also hier ein System vorgestellt, mit dem du dich authentifizierst und es aber nicht mehr das Passwort ist, das dir abgefragt wird, das du als Wissen in deinem Kopf hast, sondern er hat jetzt in dem Falle Fingerreader und so, weil die auch im neuen MacBook drin sind oder Gesichtserkennung im Smartphone oder wie auch immer. Das heißt aber nicht, dass du mit deinem Finger einfach überall, sondern das Gerät, das du benutzt, musst den Finger kennen und liest dann, das ist der Finger von Wolfgang oder von Stefan. Dann generiere ich jetzt mal ein spontanes super Mega Passord, dass man sich wirklich merken kann und das auch nur einmal funktioniert und gebe das mal weiter zum Authentifizieren. Also zwischen dem Finger und dem Dienst, den man nutzen möchte, steckt also ein technisches Gerät, das den Fingerkotz für dich entschlüsselt, weil diese Daten sollen ja auf diesem Gerät bleiben. Also brauchst du zwingend immer ein Gerät bei dir, das schon mal eingerichtet wurde damit. Du kannst also dann nicht mehr ohne so ein Gerät rausgehen. Was das für Geräte sind, besprechen wir gleich. Es muss nicht zwingend der Computer oder das Smartphone sein. Es kann auch ein Schlüsselanhänger sein oder was auch immer. Also da ist die Bandbreite dann groß. Was wir hier also haben, sind Authentifizierungssysteme, von denen er sagte schon, das wird jetzt eine Reise. Wir gehen jetzt hier alle mal auf eine Reise. Die Transition weg vom Passwort wird nicht ohne. Und so eine Reise haben wir schon mal gemacht.
Ja, ich überlege gerade, es gab ja diese Sache, wie schnell wird sich das ergeben, dass wir sehr effektive Quantencomputer haben? Und inwieweit werden dann all unsere Passwörter null und nichtig, weil Quantencomputer über eine Rechenleistung verfügen, dass sie dann doch herausfinden, dass der jemand einfach nur sich Wolfgang33xx genannt hat. Und die Frage ist ja, ob man damit eigentlich dieses Problem dann gelöst hat. Das heißt, wenn die Quantencomputer diese Rechenleistung haben und man könnte sie nutzen, um Passwörter zu entschlüsseln, dann ist das über diesen Weg wahrscheinlich dann nicht so möglich, weil es immer nur so ein Moment-Passwort ist, dass man kommt, um das gerade freizuschalten, aber dann ist das wieder weg, dann gilt das nicht mehr. In der Zeit kann auch der Quantencomputer da nichts machen.
Genau, das ist wie das Tannenverfahren bei den Banken. Da hat man ja auch immer ein zusätzliches Gerät, so ein kleines Fotoapparat oder sowas, der dann diese Punkte irgendwie entschlüsselt oder das geflacker. Und ja, da gibt es nichts quantencomputermäßig besonders schnell herauszuraten, weil du hast immer nur ein Versuch für das Passwort und danach ist es halt ein anderes beim nächsten Vorgang. Und genauso ist das hier auch. Also damit löst man dieses Problem schon recht gut. Viele Probleme konnte man natürlich dadurch abfahren, dass das Passwort ja irgendwo abgegeben werden muss. Also der Server, der nach Passworten fragt, kann ja auch einfach sagen, also das ist jetzt drei Versuche und dann musst du eine Stunde warten und dann nützt ja auch der schnellste Computer nicht, diese Stunde musst du halt dann warten und so. Gut, also wir haben es hier mit einer kleinen Revolution zu tun, denn wir werden angewiesen sein, darauf nicht nur ein Wissen im Kopf mit uns zu führen, nämlich das Passwort wie bisher, sondern ein Gerät, das uns dann wirklich identifiziert. Und da möchte ich uns gemeinsam erinnern an einen Vortrag und späteren Text. Christoph Engelmann hat ihn 2013 im Snowden-Jahr beim CCC gehalten. Ich habe ihn danach angesprochen, ihn stundenlang ausgequetscht zu diesem Thema und dann für die FAZ das nochmal zusammengeschrieben. Und daraus referiere ich nochmal kurz, denn das ist wirklich wahnsinnig interessant. Diese Art der digitalen Authentifizierung, die dann auch verpflichtend ist. Also es gibt da nicht so ein, ich hab noch kein Passkey, ich will mal auf ein Passwort zurück, sondern Apple sagt, du brauchst ein Passkey, du kannst ja nicht mehr mit Passwörtern einfach weiterarbeiten. Deswegen auch diese lange Reise, davon dann wirklich weg. Die gibt es seit drei Jahrzehnten von der amerikanischen Regierung. Die wollte das schon immer, dass man nämlich wirklich weg vom analogen Ausweisdokument dann einfach mal hin zum digitalen Authentifizieren. Es mündet dann beispielsweise 2011 in der ANSTIC Initiative, also der National Strategy for Trusted Identities in Cyberspace. Man hat sich die besten Namen ausgesucht. Und wenn man so einen Rückblick auf die analogen Identitätsfindungen und Stiftungen macht, dann geht es wirklich bei Christoph Kolumbus los, der nämlich Amerika entdeckt, was den König hier vor die Frage stellt, wie regiere ich denn die eigentlich? Ich kenne die ja gar nicht. Und das einzige, was ich über die weiß, ist, die kennen mich auch nicht. Also das Reisekönigtum, was wir ja in Europa so kennen, so alle 50 Kilometer ist so ein Fürstenschloss und dann ist man da einen Monat und dann zieht der ganze Hof weiter, kommt an eine Grenze, wenn man so einen Atlantik überqueren muss, weil da fährt man nicht mal eben hin, um da eine Woche irgendwie da zu sein. Und der Historiker Bernhard Siegbart hat 2006 ein Buch geschrieben, wo schon der Titel, selten hat ein Buchtitel so viel ausgesagt, Passagiere und Papiere. Also mit der Moderne kam die Mobilität und damit das neue Problem der Anonymität. Man tauchte nämlich irgendwo auf und sagte Hallo, I bims. Und dann alle, ja, und wer genau sind sie? Da musste man Papiere mit sich führen. Also man musste sich sozusagen ausweisen. Damit startete dann, es war so ein Brandbeschleuniger für die Bürokratie als Betriebssystem unserer modernen Gesellschaft. Pergament gehörte ganz lang, einfach Kleros und Adel. Man hat so seine Spielreihen damit gemacht. Und mit dem Papier hieß es dann plötzlich jetzt endlich Dokumente für alle. So, jeder musste Papiere mit sich führen, weil sie auch einfach herzustellen waren. Und damit haben dann auch die Ausweisdokumente, Kleidung, Besitz, Narben, Farben und so weiter ersetzt. Also körperliche Merkmale, sondern man hat dann einfach Papiere. Und seit dem Konzil von Trient, also 1545, 1563, so 20 Jahre, würde ich mal sagen, das ist so Beginn der 400 Jahre Modernität, wie wir sie heute kamen, da hieß es ja dann, Taufen sind jetzt zu dokumentieren. Das heißt, schon in den Kirchenbüchern, da hat es ja dann begonnen, bevor der Staat da Zugriff drauf genommen hat. Also in den Kirchenbüchern hat man einfach angefangen, mal so eine soziale Landkarte einfach mitzudokumentieren. So wie es heute eben Facebook und Co. machen und so. Klar, es gibt keine Pflicht zum Account, aber wir wissen ja, dass Facebook auch über jeden nicht angemeldeten, so ein Schattenprofil, je nachdem, in welchen Adressbüchern man auftaucht und so, die da hochgeladen wurden, weiß dann auch Facebook, wer man ist. Und Foucault hat wohl damals ganz gut dazu gearbeitet, wie diese Art des Populationswissens, also der Wissensgegenstand, was ist eigentlich meine Population, die Existenzgrundlage des modernen Staates ist. Weil beispielsweise man braucht ein Heer, also hat man im Vorfeld des westfälischen Friedens oder dann zum westfälischen Frieden einfach gesagt, so wir führen jetzt Hausnummern ein. Jede Hausnummer, ein Mann, damit konnte man Heeresplanung machen. Wenn der nächste Krieg losbricht, wusste man schon mal, okay, wie viele Leute habe ich eigentlich? Da muss dann nicht irgendwie der Ritter über das Land ziehen und die Männer einsammeln, sondern da konnte man einfach Briefe schreiben. Die Hausnummern waren da und sagen, so ihr seid jetzt ein Heer. Darüber dann auch der Historiker Anton Tantner hat es beschrieben, diese Musterung der Bevölkerung, Ordnung der Häuser, Beschreibung der Seelen. Also plötzlich ist man so eine Reflektion. Was so viele sind wir? Ja wer sind wir eigentlich? Und so kann man so ins gemeinsame, ja die Erfindung der Politik würde man so ein bisschen grob sagen. Die französische Revolution hat dann zum Beispiel das Namenssystem per Gesetz eingeführt. Das ist also auch gar nicht so lang. Vorname, Zunahme. Damit hat dann jede Person einen Zivilstatus bekommen. Weil, kennen wir ja, der Bürger und der Nichtbürger und so weiter. Das hat man dann zur Einführung der Sozialversicherung in Deutschland 100 Jahre später auch übernommen einfach. Also die Rente konnte man eben nur auszahlen, wenn man wusste wem. Dann musste einfach klar sein, okay, vorname Zunahme, ja dann kriegst du auch eine Rente und so. Also relativ viel passiert über diesen Weg. Herrschaftliche Gewalt, politische Macht. Hier so wer einen Namen hat und den der anderen kennt, kann Verträge schließen, deren Druckmittel die postalische Adresse ist. Also man musste nicht mehr losziehen und mit Gewalt herrschen, sondern man kann da einfach politische Macht ausspielen und sagen ja, du bist jetzt entitled oder eben nicht. Man konnte den Status einfach entziehen, den man einfach den entsprechenden Brief geschickt hat. Und wenn irgendwer mit Ansprüchen kam, konnte man den Brief aus dem Archiv so sagen, ja du hast ja noch Schulden und so. Also diese Art der, wie soll man sagen, Duplizierung einer echten Person in ihrem Dokument wurde wirklich tief greifend. Es ist alles so selbstverständlich für uns, dass wir gar nicht reflektieren. Ja, auch Tote haben natürlich eine Namenspflicht. Niemand wird ohne Namen. Wir kennen John Doe in Amerika. Das ist dann der Name, der verwendet wird. Und in Deutschland wird so lange ermittelt, bis klar ist, wer ist hier gestorben. Also man hat ein Leiche, man weiß nicht, wer das ist. Aber diese Ermittlungen ruhen eben nicht, bis man dann mit Namen beerdigen kann. Und auch Totgeburten kriegen eine Geburtsurkunde und einen Totenschein. Da steht zwar dasselbe Datum drauf, aber diese beiden Dokumente sind absolute Pflicht.
Herrschaft funktioniert über Namen. Deswegen hatte Foucault ja auch mal diesen Traum formuliert, von einem Jahr ohne Namen, dass man mal ganz ohne das auskommt. Aber das ist in der modernen Welt nicht mehr konkret.
Ja, also man kann jetzt in unendlich viele Richtungen. Tourismus, was unterscheidet Tourismus von der Dienstreise? Ja, bei dem einen fährt man in volle Rolle hin und nur deswegen. Und das andere macht man nur als Person. Dann will man nicht erkannt werden. Da will man niemand sein, sondern ist man einfach als Tourist.
Also es ist dann genau anders wie in Up in the Air. Ich habe den Film jetzt noch mal gesehen mit George Clooney, der ja ein Vielreisender ist und diese 10 Millionen Bonusmeilen diesen Status erlangen will und der ja auch seine Identität die ganze Zeit ausweisen muss, aber so viel gereist ist, auch an diesen anonymen Orten wie Flughafenschalter oder so, dass er schon wieder erkannt wird als Person, als Mensch erkannt wird, wenn auch nur von einem Personal, das in Floskeln spricht, weil die eintrainiert worden sind. Also das ist eigentlich ein ganz guter Film, der diese Form der Identitätsstiftung über Namen und Check-In deutlich macht.
Genau, oder das Gegenmodell Terminal heißt er, glaube ich, habe ich nie gesehen, aber wo jemand auf dem Terminal lebt, weil er eben ohne Papiere im Niemandsland. Genau. Er kann nicht weiterfliegen, aber er kann das Terminal auch nicht verlassen, weil dann wäre es eine Einreise und dann hängt man da halt so zwischen den Welten. Es war also soweit alles in Ordnung mit wir leben und haben halt eine Adresse, wo man uns Briefe schreibt, bis das Internet kam. Plötzlich wusste man nicht mehr genau, also hier ist so ein Vorgang, aber wer nimmt eigentlich an dem gerade teil? Oder auch, wir sind irgendwo, aber unsere Adresse ist ja zu Hause. Ich sag mal, wir haben aber Smartphones dabei. Also wir sind irgendwo anders, sind dort auch adressierbar, aber nicht über die Adresse zu Hause, die im Melderegister steht, sondern einfach mit irgendwas anderem. Ökonomisch total einfach zu benutzen, aber der Staat dann immer, ja wer hat denn jetzt, wer steckt denn hinter der IP-Adresse, die den Filmintegral runtergeladen hat und so. Und große, große juristische Sorgen. Also der große Wunsch, ja dann müssten wir dieses analoge Adresssystem einfach mal digitalisieren. Und daran sind wir gescheitert bis jetzt. Wir haben eine digitale Gesundheitskarte und einen E-Pass und eine D-E-Mail und den ganzen Kram, aber wir kamen einfach nicht vorwärts. Und der Historiker Valentin Gröbner hat dann darüber geschrieben, dass zwischen Mensch und Maschine eine Lücke ist zwischen Person und Papier. Sie blieb also immer, sehr viele Versuche haben sie so klein wie möglich gemacht, aber sie blieb einfach immer. So und das haben wir eben jetzt auch. Die Lücke zwischen Maschine und Mensch ist eben einfach da. Lange sollte das der Cookie lösen. Man hat einfach jemanden identifiziert und in diesem Cookie untergejubelt im Browser. Also so eine Kennnummer, die dann immer wieder mitgesendet wurde, um zu sehen, ah ja, der ist das, dann schickt man dem mal die Werbung. Und wenn man sich aus dieser Richtung, weil das Internet heute anschaut, Google, Amazon, Apple, Airbnb, Uber und so weiter, das sind ja eigentlich gigantische Identitätssortiermaschinen. Du brauchst eine Wohnung, wer kommt denn da und bei wem wohnst du dann? So man kriegt das heute hin, ohne sich begegnen zu müssen, weil die das eben technisch lösen. Oder ich brauche etwas, was jemand in Shenzhen herstellt. Ja, aber das ist auf der anderen Seite der Welt. Kann man dem wirklich vertrauen, wenn man dem Geld schickt, dass da was kommt und so? Das löst halt Amazon, weil die stecken einfach dahinter und kümmern sich dafür, darum her. Und bei Uber eben auch. Fremden Leute ins Auto lassen und so. Dann hat man davon nicht immer gewarnt. Und es ist einfach ein Business, dass man sich die Uber herunterlädt. Dann fährt man den ganzen Abend fremde Leute durch die Gegend. Man weiß aber, wenn was passiert, kann das alles identitätsmäßig nachgearbeitet und aufgeklärt werden. 1993 zum Beispiel gab es den Clipper Chip. Die Clinton-Regierung wollte also in jedem technischen Gerät einen kleinen Crypto-Chip unterbringen, der Authentifizierung ermöglicht. Es ist daran gescheiter, dass die NSA eine Schnittstelle haben wollte und damit das Thema einfach verbrannt war. Also es war einfach ökonomisch überhaupt nicht umzusetzen. Die Kohl-Regierung hat erst 1997 überhaupt die elektronische Form der Unterschrift eingeführt. Denn bislang musste sie eben eigenhändig sein und das war eben digital überhaupt nicht möglich. Und mit eigenhändig war auch wirklich im Sinn des Gesetzes gemeint, die Spur des Körpers. Also der Stift, der Körper musste eine Spur mithilfe von Tinte auf Papier hinterlassen und damit, die durfte eben nur von diesem Körper sein. Niemand darf für dich unterschreiben, sondern es muss eigenhändig halt, ne? Also das steckt da alles da drin. Und dann, klar, das kennen wir dann alles. Eigentlich ist alles gescheitert in Deutschland. Also vor allem die Gesundheitskarte, der E-Personal ausweist, ja, da ist ein Chip drin, aber den nutzt da niemand. Das Einzige, was wir haben, ist ein elektronisches Entgeltsystem und die Steuer-Elster, das ist so das Einzige, wo sich Leute mit so einer kleinen Datei dann wirklich mal identifizieren von zu Hause aus und das Finanzamt dann noch sagt, ja, schicken sie uns keine Papiere mehr, machen sie es so. Es ist geradezu verboten, da noch Papiere hinzuschicken. Naja, und jetzt sind wir eben 2022 angekommen, alles ist bislang gescheitert. Wir haben keine staatlich gestützten Authentifizierungssysteme und das, was wir jetzt hier sehen, die Fido-Alliance, dass Apple das einfach so einbaut, das ist im Grunde ein großer staatlicher Wunsch, der aber eben nur auf public private und da ist ganz schön viel private dabei, Wege umgesetzt werden kann und unter dieser Maßgabe gucken wir jetzt diese Clips, wie eine Frau von Microsoft, die dieses Department da leitet, mit dem ich glaube, es ist der Technikchef von Fido darüber spricht, was Fido jetzt eigentlich ist. Also wir haben uns jetzt, vorhin haben wir den Kontext rausgenommen, jetzt haben wir mal so richtig Kontext reingeholt, um uns jetzt dieses kleine Werbegespräch hier anzuschauen, was die da vorhaben und wir können überlegen, wie lange dauert es und was bedeutet es am Ende dann wirklich. Also die Chefin des Microsoft Identitäts Departements redet mit dem FIDO Chef.
Hi, I'm Pamela Dingle, Director of Identity Standards at Microsoft and I'm here today to talk to Andrew Schickiar. He is the Executive Director and CMO at the FIDO Alliance. So tell me what FIDO stands for.
So FIDO stands for Fast Identity Online and FIDO Alliance is a standards organization that's creating open standards for better, simpler, stronger user authentication.
So, besser, stronger, Dingser, alles User-authentifizierter.
Und es ist ja zunächst mal bemerkenswert, dass diese Konzerne das geschafft haben, sich so zu vernetzen, da ja auch die Fragen zum Datenschutz mitunter unterschiedlich beantwortet und verhandelt werden. Also wenn man jetzt an Meta oder Apple denkt, dann gibt es da ja Differenzen.
Genau. Also das ist eine wirkliche Zäsur, diese Art der Zusammenarbeit. Wir haben das zuletzt in Ausschnitten gesehen, bei der Corona-App. Da haben nämlich auch Google und Apple gemeinsam die Dokumente geschrieben, die Departments wirklich zusammengelegt und gesagt, das machen wir jetzt so. Dann hat sich Google ja auch geschlagen gegeben und gesagt, wir machen das genau, wie Apple vorgeschlagen hat. Das bleibt alles auf dem Gerät, da werden nur Nummern, das ist alles Zufallszahl und so weiter. Da wird nichts, also da ist auch technisch fast unmöglich. Man hat ja bis heute nichts mehr davon gehört, deswegen gab es da keine Angriffe oder Sonstiges, sondern das hat ja auch wunderbar funktioniert. Und ich will ausdrücklich sagen, ich bin auch schwer beeindruckt von der Art und Weise, der Technologie, wie es funktioniert. Und wir hören nachher so Stimmen, denen ich auch erst mal vorgreife, ich würde mich auch geschlagen geben. Ich habe mein Smartphone sowieso immer dabei. Und diesen Art von Komfort nehme ich gerne entgegen. Dann wirklich einfach nur wie beim Bezahlen, das nutze ich zum Beispiel nicht, aber wirklich nur das Smartphone da dran zu halten und zu wissen, das geht ja gerade mit rechten Dingen zu. Und zusätzlich zu dem Verwenden der EC-Karte, wenn man Apple Pay benutzt, der Laden sieht nicht, wer ich bin. Und gleichzeitig sieht die Bank nicht, wo ich da gerade eingekauft habe, sondern diese Authentifizierung steckt alles in Apple drin. Die wissen es halt, die sagen dann, die geben es nicht raus. Aber man hat erst mal auch Privacy geschaffen durch solche Sachen. Also es ist nicht nur alles schlecht, aber ich finde, man sollte eben wirklich im Hinterkopf behalten, um was es hier eigentlich geht, dass es da so ein immenses politisches Ansinnen gibt.
Dass hier nicht politisch gelöscht wurde.
Also das ist ja jetzt gerade der Punkt, politisch gescheitert.
Jetzt kommen also die Privaten.
Genau. Und jetzt kommen die und stellen uns ihren Links hier vor. So und nicht nur hat der Staat das große Ansinnen, dass es irgendwann mal funktioniert. So er sagt den Leuten immer, was er macht. Ich schaffe Passwörter ab und dann sagen alle ein Glück. So also diese typische Übungszeit so.
Und du wirst es ja auch kennen. Man will irgendwas zum Beispiel lesen hinter der Payball und es liegt nicht an Betrag, den man zahlen muss, sondern einfach daran, dass man sagt, am Moment da hatte ich ein Passwort, hatte ich das mit der einen oder mit der anderen E-Mail-Adresse. Und während man so darüber nachdenkt und denkt, ach ja, da muss ich jetzt auf Passwort vergessen. Dann bekomme ich die Mail und dann klicke ich die an. Dann sagt man, naja, gut, vielleicht brauche ich den auch jetzt doch gerade nicht. Den Artikel 1 ist schon weiter. Also ich bin ja auch davon überzeugt. Also natürlich gehen auch manche Leute nicht in den Salon, weil man dann doch am Ende irgendwie ein Passwort braucht oder so. Also ja, ich glaube, das sind Dinge, die ich kann jetzt auch total nachvollziehen, dass man dann so sagt, ah ja, diese Hürde jetzt auch noch nehmen.
Ich meine, der Salon bei Apple kostet ein Euro mehr. Warum? Weil man da einfach draufklickt, dann wird man gefragt, bist du bereit, jetzt dein Gesicht kurz scannen zu lassen? Denn wenn ja, ist in dem Moment es bezahlt. Und es findet nichts weiter statt. Es ist wirklich nur dieses, ja, wir würden jetzt kurz dein Gesicht scannen, um das du es bist, zu bestätigen und dann sagst du ja. Und damit hat sie es erledigt. So wäre das dann da. Genau so ist das dann. Nur eben jetzt macht es eben Apple noch selber. So, hier wäre es dann, dass das einfach überall funktioniert.
Aber die Leute, die bei Apple eingeloggt sind, die müssen sowieso nichts abscannen mehr, oder?
Nein, du musst ja immer noch mal dein Gesicht in dem Moment dann wirklich zeigen.
Tatsächlich, wenn man bei Apple was kauft.
Ja, ja, also du kannst es so einstellen, dass du kein Passwort brauchst. Aber das ist auch so ein bisschen Kindersicherung und so weiter. Aber in dem Moment, du drückst halt zweimal auf den Ausbutton. In dem Moment hast du deinem Handy gesagt, ja, ich bin bereit, mich jetzt scannen zu lassen und es zu bezahlen. In dem Moment hast du eine drittel Sekunde lang kurz abgescannt. Also du wirst wirklich beschossen mit so kleinen Strahlen, die dann reflektieren. Es ist nicht einfach nur, es wird fotografisch, sondern du wirst wirklich kurz gescannt. So und in dem Moment weiß dann das Handy, ja, du warst, der gedrückt hat und niemand sonst. Also es ist eben nicht einfach nur die physische Eingabe, sondern es ist eine biometrische, es war der Körper, so wie eigenhändig, ja, du sollst unterschreiben, niemand sonst. Wird das kurz technisch abgesichert, dass du es warst, der da authentifiziert hat, aber eben auf dem einfachsten Wege.
Das macht Steady noch nicht, da muss man noch sich ein Passwort ausdenken, damit er sich anmeldet. Bei Steady braucht man noch ein Passwort, aber das kann man dann Passwort 1, 2, 3 zum Beispiel nennen.
Ja, man kann natürlich alles machen. Genau und darum geht es ja, dieses Steady-Passwort hier abzulösen. So er kommt also überall hin und sagt, ja, ja, ich löse das Passwort ab. Oh, ein Glück, er hat alles so, finde ich gut, mach das mal, denn ich hasse es. Entweder überall das gleiche Passwort zu verwenden oder mein Passwort mir nicht merken zu können und es im richtigen Moment dann auch nicht zu haben. So und dann, als er das hier sagte, das Folgende, da habe ich auch gedacht, ja, das stimmt. Wir haben eigentlich schon eine Sicherheitsstufe, nämlich die Two-Factor Authentication. Also wir haben eigentlich schon immer so ein zweites Ding noch mal mit, für das wir immer ein technisches Gerät brauchen.
Was ist es, was die Zuschauer sehen und tun, das so viel besser ist als Passwörter?
Es kommt ein paar Formfaktoren, von einem USB-Key zum NFC-Karten, oder was auch immer das sein kann, dass man das als zweiter Faktor oder als primarisches Login anbietet.
So, Second Factor Primary, diese Unterscheidung. Ja, das erste ist immer noch das Passwort. Aber wenn man sich überlegt, wie viele Dienste nutzen wir, wo es dann wirklich heißt, ja, dann kriegst du noch mal eine SMS zur Bestätigung, dann sollst du eine Nummer abtippen und so weiter. Für dieses Two Factor Ding brauchst du schon immer ein Gerät, weil irgendwo wird was hingeschickt. Irgendwo läuft eine App, die dir so einen Zahlencode oder sowas anzeigt. Und im Grunde geht es darum, das Prinzip umzudrehen, es nur noch über dieses, dir wird was zugeschickt, aber eben auf ein Gerät und dafür das Passwort aber irgendwann sein zu lassen. Also eigentlich sind wir schon ziemlich nah dran. Und jetzt ist ja die Frage für dich zum Beispiel. Du gehst dann in die Oper, willst ein Ticket kaufen, die sagen ja dann authentifizieren sich, machen die so.
Ich habe ja jetzt Karten gebucht, was passiert dann? Ich bekomme dann eine SMS auf mein altes Nokia, da ist dann die TAN und dann gebe ich die ein.
Genau, genau, genau, sowas. Aber die Frage ist ja wirklich, und soweit wollen sie es ja treiben, du gehst als 80-Jähriger zur Oper, weil der Tag noch auf den Türen ist, stehst da physisch an der Kasse, willst bezahlen und die sagen, ja sie müssen sich authentifizieren. Wie machst du das in dem Moment? Und du hast dann kein Smartphone und hast nichts dabei. Und auch dafür haben sie vorgesorgt, es wird große, große Authentifizierungsgeräte, Wellen wahrscheinlich geben, Schlüsselanhänger, Karten, was auch immer. So, hier ist es wirklich runder gedampft auf, sie drücken diesen Knopf.
Das ist jetzt einfach nur noch wie so ein USB-Stick oder wie so ein Anhänger, den man am Schiff hat.
Genau, das ist jetzt Bluetooth. Das Handy würde das halt einfach erkennen oder das Gerät und man würde einfach drücken und dann würde das Gott gesendet. Er hat eben diesen kleinen Dongle, wo du deinen Finger, wo ein Fingerabdruckscanner. Das sind hier, man denkt so, ja gut, da haben sie wieder tolle Ideen gehabt. Nee, aber das steht eben seit Jahren in dieser Instic-Initiative drin. Also das ist eine Vorgabe der US-Regierung. Bewerbt euch bitte. Das ist so eine richtige Ausschreibung. Wir suchen ein Identifikationssystem. Bislang haben wir die eigenhändige Unterschrift. Wir brauchen also eine Spur des Körpers. Bitte schlagt uns vor, wie man das technisch abbildet. Und daraufhin sitzen die da und sagen, ja, dann bauen wir so einen Dongle und dann kommt da ein Fingerprint rein und dann ist es dieser Körper, der sich da ausdehnt und so weiter. Das steht alles so in diesen Gesetzen drin, so dass man halt wirklich am Ende diese quasi hoheitliche Aufgabe irgendwann mal erfüllen kann. Wo ja auch wieder wirkliche staatliche Budgets dahinterstecken. Das ist dann eben nicht nur Spielerei und so, sondern da geht es dann wirklich zur Sache. Da geht es dann darum, ob du zur Behörde gehst und sagst, hier, ich bin es, ich drücke jetzt hier auf diesen Knopf. Und da wird es dann eben so verschiedene Geräte geben oder halt so ein Businessumfeld, dass es dann so spezifisch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, in diese Karten, die man so bei sich hat oder so. Ja, kennt man ja, dass man eh schon so einen Ausweis sichtbar mit sich trägt und da funkt dann halt noch so ein bisschen rum und erledigt solche Sachen. Aber, ganz wichtig, es braucht eben...
Ich will einen kleinen Unterpressur machen. Ich habe nämlich in Köln jemanden getroffen, wird zu Ende 20 gewesen sein, der auch bei dem Konzert an der Philharmonie war als Gast. Und dem gab ich die Hand und wir kamen ins Gespräch. Und ich erzählte so ein bisschen, was ich mache. Und habe dann auch gesagt, wir reden hier viel über Technisches. Und dann hielt er mir nochmal seine Hand hin und sagte, fühl mal und dann sollte ich über seinen Daumen fühlen. Und er hatte da tatsächlich einen Chip drin, in der Hoffnung, dass er sich bald damit überall authentifizieren kann. Den hat er vor ein paar Jahren sich wohl da reinsetzen lassen. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja und wo geht das? Und er sagt, es gab irgendwie ein Geschäft, wo es tatsächlich möglich ist, aber sonst nicht.
Als Spielerei geht das natürlich. Es gibt ja auch irgendwelche Bars in Stockholm oder so, wo du reinkommst und dann hältst deine Hand da hin und dann passt das alles. Der Chip erledigt ja auch nur die Aufgabe, irgendwas zu funken, was eindeutig auf dich zurückzuführen ist, wie auch dein Fingerabdruck oder eben deine Gesichtsform.
Aber das wäre ja jetzt der Schlüsselanhänger, der dann gleich in den Körper integriert ist, dass man den nicht verlieren kann.
Ja, aber du verlierst dein Gesicht ja auch nicht. Und für den Chip brauchst du eben auch ein Empfangsgerät, so wie eben auch für deine Gesichtserkennung usw. In deren Sicht, das ist so eine Spielerei, bei der man eben sagt, ja klar, der Chip, da ist halt eine eindeutige Nummer drin, aber die ist nicht eindeutiger als dein Fingerabdruck oder dein Gesicht.
Du kannst dir vorstellen, dass der junge Mann mich mit großen Augen ansah, als ich sagte, ich zahle eigentlich immer bar.
Ja, bar ist natürlich, also du hast das ganze Spektrum da einmal, es sind Leute bereit, sich einen Chip implantieren zu lassen. Und dann auf der anderen Seite, Leute wollen so lange wie geht bar zahlen. Und man muss irgendwie so alles noch abbilden in der Gesellschaft. Oder es soweit in der Stimmung drehen, dass der Ärger, der Volksaufstand nicht mehr droht, wenn man dann wirklich sagt, ja bar, da müssten sie jetzt schon, keine Ahnung, also so ab 20 Euro wird es schon schwierig, dass wir noch mit bar, weil das ist ja auch für uns ein Sicherheitsding. Was machen wir mit dem Geld und so?
Das ist ja schon auch Freiheit durch Anonymität.
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Wie dann bei Fido nicht so gewährleistet ist. Also dadurch, dass es ja doch über ein Konto, also das ist zwar jetzt anonym, wenn ich da in der Kasse stehe oder so, aber sobald ja dann Geldtransfers darüber stattfinden, ist es ja zugleich auf dem Kontorauszug. Mein Gott, ich spreche jetzt so, als würde ich hier ganz viele Kriminellen treffen zu tun, müsste ich da nicht verstecken. Aber es ist ja tatsächlich so, dass man dann durch die Zahlungen, die ja irgendwie erfolgen, nämlich nicht bar, nachvollziehen kann, was war.
Also guck nochmal genau, was auf dem Kontorauszug steht, wenn du, na gut, du machst es jetzt nicht.
Naja, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel einen Anzug kaufe in einem Geschäft, dann steht ja der Name des Geschäfts auf dem Kontorauszug, was jetzt nicht tragisch ist, aber nur als Beispiel.
Ja, also wenn du was bei Amazon bestellst, guck mal genau auf dem Kontorauszug, ob du dann erkennst, was hast du da gekauft. Ob das dieser Brücken schlagt geht oder bei Apple.
Das kann man nur noch über den Betrag nachvollziehen, das sagt man nach 67, 90 Euro.
Nur du kannst es, die Bank kann es nicht. Und bei Apple ist es noch weiter zurückgedimmt. Und es gibt auch sehr viele, es gibt so Sum Up und so, diese kleinen Buden, die dir einfach so viel Friseur läden und so weiter, diese kleinen hier Karte auflegen und so. Die machen, die schicken auch nur noch so Nummern hin und her. Also da sieht die Bank auch nicht wirklich, was hast du da gemacht. Diese ganzen Banking-Softwares, die dann immer versuchen, eine Analyse deines Haushalts-Dings zu machen, so für dich einfach, damit du siehst, was habe ich im Monat ausgegeben. Für die wird es immer schwieriger, das nachzuvollziehen. Für was ist jetzt das wirklich? In welchen Budget-Top kommt denn das hier? Weil man sieht dann einfach nur, also in der Ansicht, man kann da schon sehr viel Privacy reinbauen, die ja bisher mit EC-Karten und so weiter eben oder vor allem mit Kreditkarten nicht abgebildet wurde. Und hier hört man jetzt mal so ganz deutlich, was im Hintergrund so an Anforderungen der Regierungsinitiativen drinsteckte, dem sie da halt entsprechen.
Wir sehen jetzt diese Innovationen, die sich die Sicherheitslöcher für mobile Phone-User und Device-User anbringen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das sehen kannst, aber es gibt diese kleinen Touch-Points auf jeder Seite.
Ja, und jetzt kann man hier so denken, ja, da soll man halt so drücken. Ja, das ist halt nur ein Button, aber es ist eine Körperbewegung.
Eigentlich geht man damit wieder zurück zu dieser Idee der klassischen Unterschrift, wo du das eben beschrieben hast. Da muss noch die Körperbewegung, die eigene mit dabei sein, die eigentlich nicht mehr gegeben ist, wenn ich jetzt gerade eine digitale Unterschrift leiste.
Genau, und super interessant ist, die Unterschrift war ja immer fälschbar, was aber niemals bedeutete, dass sie besonders ausgefallen sein muss. Wir mussten nie wie Donald Trump unterschreiben, sondern es reichte so ein Strich einfach, wenn das deine Unterschrift war. Auch wenn die im Bürgeramt immer sagen, die sollen immer schon mit vollem Namen usw. Nee, gesetzlich ist das, du musst es halt sein. Und hier ist es eben auch so, sie hat so einen kleinen Dongle, er drückt nur den Knopf, und sie sagt, diese Geste muss da sein. Ob du die dann wirklich gedrückt hast, oder jemand anderes, wäre dann juristisch zu klären. So wie bei einer Unterschrift, die kann man ja auch fälschen. Und so ist es hier immer auch. Wer dann wirklich diesen Knopf gedrückt hat, wenn man keine Körperautotifizierung, also der Fingerabdruck, das Gesichtscan, macht es einfacher. Aber es würde auch beginnen, das System nutzbar zu machen, nur mit Drückgesten, wie ein Strich auf so einer Unterschrift. Also es ist in der Hinsicht schon sehr interessant, wie dieses analoge System hier wirklich einfach digitalisiert wurde, auch wenn man nicht genau wusste, was soll man entwickeln. Dann duplizieren wir einfach das analoge Modell, was wir bisher haben. Und hier stellt sich mal dieses Paradigma vor, was den großen ökonomischen Erfolg dann wahrscheinlich versprechen wird.
Ich bin auch ein bisschen verabschiedet.
Dich authentifizieren, wie bei der Bargeld Benutzung. Ich bin berechtigt, das hier zu kaufen, weil ich hab ihm genug Bargeld hingelegt. Sie müssen nicht wissen, wer ich genau bin oder so. Und so ist das hier auch. Ich hab mich jetzt authentifiziert. Sie müssen gar nicht mehr wissen, außer ich habe mich authentifiziert. Und dann soll das funktionieren und zwar egal, wo man in der digitalen Sphäre, mit welchen Geräten und so weiter. Und was spreche ich dagegen? Das wird wahrscheinlich technisch so hinhauen. Die mussten sich halt wirklich nochmal zusammenschließen jetzt. Haben das wahrscheinlich mit dieser Corona-App-Erfahrung auch so ein bisschen darauf aufgebaut, dass das so geht und diesen Erfolg von Apple Pay gesehen. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, das geht jetzt. Und jetzt machen wir es dann eben auch. Der Körper ist entscheidend. Also man braucht eine Spur des Körpers. Und, und das ist dann die technische Raffinesse, alles Weitere kann im Gerät verbleiben.
Und es ist nicht nur, dass man den Körperschneider.
Immer darum ging, soll man eigentlich Leute fragen, woher sie kommen, im Sinne von, wo kommst du wirklich her? Wo man dann erfährt, nee, ich bin hier aufgewachsen, ich sehe nicht ganz genauso aus wie du, aber ich bin ja trotzdem Deutscher. Wir hatten das mehr mal in Clips auch aufgetröselt anhand von merkwürdigen Kommentaren von Eike Heidenreich. Und das ist natürlich eine ganz andere Idee von Identität und Authentifizierung, indem man einfach sagt, hier, das ist schon jetzt einmal gemacht, ich bin jetzt hier und kann das hier vorzeigen. Und damit ist meine Identität, die muss dir reichen. Du musst nicht noch mal was nachfragen. Und wie schreibt man ihren Namen? Ah, ist das persisch oder sonst was? Das kommt alles gar nicht mehr. Und was ich hörte, wo ich jetzt keine Evidenz für habe, aber was doch FIFA hier im Diskurs zu vernehmen war, ist, dass Transpersonen wohl durch diese Authentifizierungsmaßnahmen während der Corona-Krise häufiger es mit Diskriminierungserfahrungen zu tun hatten, weil dann so Nachfragen kamen und wie und sind sie es wirklich? Und wenn ein System diese Identitätsfragen, nenne ich sie einmal, in einer ganz funktionalen Weise lösen kann, ist das eigentlich ein Riesenfortschritt.
Es ist ja, also diese Frage, wo kommst du wirklich her, ist ja diese Frage, darfst du eigentlich hier sein? Genau, die hat man dann geklärt, ja ich bin hier, weil ich hier sein darf. Das kennt man ja so ein bisschen, man denkt irgendwie, oh man Iron Maiden 90 Euro ist ja ganz schön teuer, dann ist man drin im Gelände und weiß, alle die hier sind, haben mindestens 90 Euro bezahlt, sind also berechtigt, jetzt genauso viel Spaß zu haben wie ich. Also man hat so eine Schicksalsvergemeinschaftung irgendwie über dieses, ja die haben sich alle identifiziert, die sind alle durch das gleiche Nadelöhr am Eingang gegangen wie ich, hier hat sich keiner reingeschmuggelt, wir sind hier einfach alle zusammen. Also man kriegt, das stimmt, mit solchen Sachen, dass man...
Nur besteht ja auch wiederum die große Gefahr, dass man auch ein System produziert hat, das würde Foucault jetzt gleich auch unterstreichen, der Explosion.
Aber solange du drinnen bist, siehst du ja nicht was draußen ist.
Genau, wir haben ja über dieses Buch damals gesprochen, Move. Und du erinnerst dich an die letzten Kapitel, die uns beiden missfielen, wo es darum geht, eigentlich muss es so sein, dass die Identität nur noch über einen Chip zu lösen ist. Und man kann dann überall sein und das ist dann eine Frage von Geld. Und man muss natürlich hier auch sehen, das ist jetzt auf so einer bundesdeutschen Ebene betrachtet oder so ein sehr egalitäres oder egalisierendes System sogar, aber natürlich global wiederum betrachtet oder auch vielleicht betrachtet, wer war irgendwo nicht zahlungszuverlässig und wird dann nicht nur bei Paypal gesperrt, sondern auch noch bei Amazon und da und dort. Da hat man natürlich ein Sanktionsregime, ein sehr hartes, nämlich dann verlierst du deine Identität. Du hast die Parted gesehen, diesen wunderbaren Film mit Leonardo DiCaprio. Und das einzige, was er am Ende will, ist seine Identität zurück. Und das hier ist ein System, das auch in diese Richtung gehen kann.
Genau, wir steigen mal in diese Diskussion noch ein bisschen ein, denn ich habe jetzt auch gesagt, ich finde das zum einen gut und auch bewundernswert, sowohl auf technischer, als auch auf so einer, ja, damit ist dann auch mal endlich was Neues möglich. Schon allein, weil es sehr viel komfortabler wird, mal eine Onlinesausgabe einer Zeitung zu kaufen, immer gleich einen Account anzulegen und der ganze Kram. Sondern ich sage, hallo, ich bin's. Ja, ich habe drei Euro, zack, wie am Kiosk aus der Bahn. Und es gibt halt einfach sehr viel zu bedenken, beispielsweise bei der Frage, wenn da so viel politischer Wille dahinter steckt, setze ich dann doch mal so eine NSA durch oder so? In so einzelnen Fragen oder ja, das, was wir eben kennen aus dieser Kanzel Culture. Wir entziehen jetzt mal Wikileaks, einfach alle Einnahmemöglichkeiten, indem wir das Paypal nicht mehr ermöglichen und so. Was machen die denn dann eigentlich? Und da gibt es ja ein paar Sachen zu diskutieren. Zum einen, wir hören mal hier nur kurz Unbox Therapy, da sitzt der Lu so in seiner Plauderstimme mit seinen Leuten da zusammen. Also eigentlich machen die so YouTube-Videos, wo die halt dem Namen nach so Sachen auspacken und sich darüber freuen, was immer wieder hergestellt wurde. Und hier plaudern sie so über diese Apple Keynote. Ja, also das ist eine Frage von 2008 oder so. Da sind wir nun wirklich weit drüber. Klar vertrauen wir unserem Smartphone. Das liegt mit drei Mikrofonen neben unserem Bett die ganze Zeit. Und sieht alles, weiß, wo wir sind.
Nur wir haben ja die Möglichkeit der Diversifizierung gerade. Also das ist ja schon etwas. Nein, wir mit unseren Identitäten. Also wenn ich jetzt meinen Facebook-Account verliere, weil ich irgendwas Böses geschrieben habe, dann verliere ich nicht gleichzeitig mein Twitter- und YouTube-Account und sonst was. Und das kann man jetzt auf so einer finanziellen Ebene auch sehen. Also wenn ich da als nicht mehr solvent eingeschätzt werde, wie sieht es dann auf der anderen Plattform aus? Und ist da Netflix am Ende auch noch abgestellt?
Genau, diesen System wäre man ausgeliefert. Das ist eine andere Dynamik, auch von Anbieterseite. Wir wissen ja, wie wichtig Apple so insgesamt das Thema ist, auch um so Marktvorteile zu erringen. Und als es damals hieß, nicht nur Google und Alexa, also Amazon schicken natürlich die Audioaufnahmen auf die zentralen Server, wo die noch mal ausgewertet werden, sondern Apple macht das auch. Es bleibt nicht auf deinem Device. Das war für die natürlich auch ein mega super Gau, der zumindest durch die Podcasts so gegangen ist. In deren Sicht, ja, aber eben, wie der Lu hier sagt, ja, wir vertrauen halt unseren Geräten doch irgendwie. Also da sind wir dann doch weit drüber hinaus. Und zwar für den Komfort. Ja, das kennen die halt zu genüge. Die kriegen ja jeden Tag einen neuen Computer geliefert, den sie dann austesten wollen. Und klar, wenn man erst mal authentifiziert ist im Gerät, kann man sich überall anmelden. Aber irgendwann musst du dich dem Computer gegenüber authentifizieren. Wenn du dann da sitzt und denkst, wie war noch mal mein Google, Apple, Dingsdaubungspasswort? Dann hilft halt kein Shortcut. Du musst es über die Tastatur eingeben, weil nichts anderes geht. Dann musst du es halt irgendwo rauskramen und kannst es nicht kopieren oder sonst was. Du musst es wirklich irgendwo. Und dann ist das jetzt eine Eins oder ein senkreter Strich. Dann kommst du halt... Und dann halt einfach... Also ich kann es sehr fühlen, ich lebe auch so wie er. Und Leo Laporte, den ich ja nun sehr häufig hier auch schon gespielt habe, also ihr kennt ihn alle, This Week in Tech und so weiter, für ihn sind das alles sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr gute Nachrichten.
Also ich dachte, das war ein großer Deal.
Sehr, sehr gute News, aber. Und jetzt gucken wir in die echte politische Lage, ins echte China, in die echte Gegenwart, was da echt mit Smartphones gemacht wird. Und kriegen in den Tagesthemen eben Folgendes.
Schauen wir auf eine andere Weltmacht, die ihre Bürgerinnen und Bürger immer mehr kontrolliert. China. Dies ist die Eintrittskarte für alles, was der Alltag hergibt, in Form eines grünen Codes auf der Corona-App des Landes. Wer den nicht vorweisen kann, dem wird der Zugang zu nahezu allem verwehrt. Auch dann, wenn ein Test eigentlich nachweist, dass keine Infektion mit dem Virus vorliegt. Chinas politische Führung beweist damit erneut, Kreativität auszudrücken, wessen Meinung ihr missfällt.
Ja, und wir hören das einfach mal so in Ausschnitten, weil das ist die pure Willkür. Und die regieren vollständig über diese Corona-App jetzt.
Die Anwältin Wang Yu kann sich in Peking seit einiger Zeit nicht mehr frei bewegen. Sie ist eine Kritikerin des Regimes, wurde schon oft in Hausarrest gesetzt. Doch neuerdings hat die Regierung offenbar eine andere Methode. Ihre chinesische Corona-Warn-App funktioniert nicht mehr. Selbst in die Einkaufsstraße kommt sie deshalb nicht rein. Überall im Land muss inzwischen gescannt werden. Als sie einen sensiblen Fall vor Gericht bringen will, springt ihr Code auf Geld. Obwohl sie dreimal hintereinander einen negativen PCR-Test gemacht hat.
Wir haben das gerade gesehen. Das Authentifizieren läuft hier so ab, dass die hintere Kamera auf den QR-Code scannt und die vordere auf das Gesicht. Und in dem Moment zusammenbringt, sie ist wirklich gerade hier und möchte da durch. Und dann sagt die App das nicht. Und sie darf nicht und hat trotzdem gleichzeitig dem Staat Bescheid gesagt, sie war da wirklich gerade da. Die Bewegungslandkarte kann dann trotzdem weitergeschrieben werden, obwohl man hier alles verwehrt. Man sieht dann so richtig, was sind ihre Intentionen, was wollte sie. Das ist schon wirklich brutal. Und sie kann eigentlich gar nichts mehr machen dort.
Die Stadt wird für sie zum Hindernislauf. Denn auch im Taxi muss der QR-Code für die Gesundheits-App gescannt werden. Glücklicherweise lässt sich der Taxifahrer darauf ein, dass sich nur ein Passagier einlockt. Was passiert, wenn das jemand nicht scannt?
Man muss das, so ist die Regel.
Aber wenn jemand etwa kein Handy hat?
Dann nimm halt kein Taxi.
Allerdings braucht es auch für Bus und U-Bahn den grünen Code der Gesundheits-App. Selbst der Zugang zur Wohnung wird inzwischen überwacht. Jeder in Peking wohnt innerhalb einer abgezäunten Anlage. Es gibt nur einen Zugang. An dem haben Wärter ihre Grenzposten überall aufgestellt. Hier im Vorort von Peking wohnt Wang Yu. In ihre Wohnanlage geht sie nach einem heftigen Streit mit dem Wachpersonal einfach ohne Scannen durch. Jeder Besucher aber muss sich hier einloggen.
Formal kommt die nicht mal in ihre Wohnung, sondern die hat einfach mit denen, weil da noch ein Typ sitzt, der auch die Tür noch aufmachen kann. Ansonsten wäre die da auch außen vor. Und hier in dem letzten Clip wird auch dieser Bogenschlag noch mal gemacht.
In ihrer Wohnung schauen sich Wang Yu und ihr Mann Videos von Protesten an. Sie machen gerade im Internet die Runde. Kunden einer angeschlagenen Bank wurde ihr Gesundheitscode auf Rot gestellt. Viele konnten daher nicht zu diesen Protesten reisen. Einem lokalen Kader wurde anschließend als Strafe die Parteimitgliedschaft entzogen. Die Strafe ist willkürlich. Der Fall hat einfach für so viel Öffentlichkeit gesorgt, dass ein Sündenbock gefunden werden musste. Das erweckt den Anschein einer Abstrafe. Aber das eigentliche Problem, das bleibt. Und das sei, dass die Polizei direkten Zugriff habe auf den Gesundheitsquot. Alles hinter sich lassen und China den Rücken kehren kann Wang Yu nicht. Die chinesischen Behörden haben ihr vor zwei Jahren den Reisepass abgenommen.
So, Reisepass war eh schon weg. Dann kam Corona und die Corona-App. Und jetzt hat sich auch intern sozusagen kein Reisepass mehr. Das ist die Partie in einer anderen Form. Und im heutigen Journal haben sie es auch thematisiert. Nachdem die Tagesthemen hier am 16. vorgelegt haben, haben sie sich im heutigen Journal gedacht, ey, das ist so krass, das werfen wir auch noch mal auf. Und sie haben noch mal so ein Tee noch reingebracht. Wie wichtig ist den Chinesen, also der chinesischen Regierung gerade, das Machtmittel über diese App zu regieren?
Null Covid, koste es, was es wolle. Das ist die Politik der Führung in China. Auch wenn das unerbittliche Ausgangssperren bedeutet, menschliche Dramen, Wirtschaftseinbruch und dennoch steigende Infektionszahlen. An der Politik wird nicht gerüttelt. Und ohne die staatliche Gesundheits-App geht nichts mehr. Wer keinen grünen Code vorweisen kann, kommt in Chinas Großstädten weder in Supermärkte, noch in Busse oder U-Bahnen und manchmal nicht mal mehr in die eigene Wohnung. Der Code springt allerdings schon mal ganz schnell von grün auf rot. Nicht etwa, weil ein Test positiv gewesen wäre. Es reicht offenbar, an einer Demonstration teilnehmen zu wollen. Zumindest beschweren sich immer mehr Menschen über Willkür und politische Kontrolle mittels Corona-App.
Ja, Willkür und politische Kontrolle. Also Willkür aus Sicht des Publikums. Für die Mächtigen natürlich ein mega Instrument.
Obwohl die Wirtschaft jetzt sogar schrumpft, machen die einfach weiter. Es ist so erstaunlich, dass man sieht, es geht jetzt per se darum, diesen Machtapparat zu festigen und die Macht zu stabilisieren. Und eine solche Dominanz aufzubauen, dass auch nicht in irgendeiner Weise mehr Zweifel angemeldet werden darf. Dass einfach Chi sich jetzt so absoluter setzt, dass es da gar keine Möglichkeiten zum Widerstand gibt. Denn hier werden ja die partiellen Kritiken in dieser Weise schon eingehegt. Und ich glaube, wir müssen uns das auch wirklich ganz deutlich vor Augen führen. Wir sind ja 100 Kilometer weit davon entfernt, aber wir müssen uns das doch sehr vor Augen führen, dass diese Identifizierung, dass diese Zugangsbeschränkung so, dass das grundsätzlich ein unglaublich schlimmer Weg ist für eine Gesellschaft. Und ich war ja auch damals so sehr schockiert darüber, als es Corona-Maßnahmen gab, die so aufsahen, dass man in Parks sich nicht mit größeren Gruppen treffen kann. Ich konnte das akzeptieren, ich bin eh nicht in Parks und so, aber es geht ja nicht um mich, aber dass man dann erlebte, wie aus dem linksliberalen Spektrum, Leute, die vorher noch gesagt haben, all cops are bastards, die plötzlich das toll fanden, dass die Polizei, junge Menschen waren es ja meistens, aus Parks vertreibt, die da mal mit zehn Leuten rumgestanden haben. Und da will ich nicht sagen, da sind wir ja schon wie in China, aber ich will sagen, ich finde es gut, dass es dann sehr viele gibt, meine ich nicht die Querdenker, die normalen Leute, die dann sagen, das geht irgendwie nicht, das ist nicht gut, sowas zu sehen. Und ich ist auch deshalb ratsam, wenn man eine fortschrittliche linke Partei sein will, dass man den Begriff Freiheit durchaus auch für sich annektiert.
Also diese Zäsur hier in China muss man nochmal ganz klar markieren. Das wird auch in diesem letzten Heudeschannel, da klebt ihr gleich noch, wo wir den Bericht dringucken, deutlich. Aber man muss es ausdrücklich sagen, bisher hieß es immer aus westlicher Sicht, naja, das Mittel, mit dem Chi für Ruhe sorgt, ist Wirtschaftswachstum. Er verspricht den Leuten einfach und so weiter. Und jetzt hat er eine Corona-App und kann sogar auf Wirtschaftswachstum verzichten, ohne Angst zu haben, dass es da große Aufstände und so weiter gibt. Und die gibt es ja gerade. Und die haben sie eben trotzdem unter Kontrolle. In deren Sicht ist diese Verlockung, diese Technologie so zu nutzen, also sie digital und verpflichtend zu machen, so wie es im Amerikanischen in der Ausschreibung drinsteht. Digital und verpflichtend, sodass man einfach eine breite Akzeptanz hat. Da kommt man nicht mehr drum rum. Das muss man dann dabei haben, sonst kriegt man kein Wohngeld oder so. In dieser Härte wäre es ja dann auch hier schon formuliert.
Und ich finde das ja manchmal so besorgniserregend, wenn man so Wirtschaftsvertreter, zum Beispiel Deutsche hört oder auch Amerikanische, wenn die China erwähnen, dann einmal als Konkurrenten. Aber manchmal hat man so den Eindruck, man blinzelt so ein bisschen rüber und sagt, ach so, so geht es, so kann man auch was machen. Und da habe ich dann immer auch bei manchen Politikern den Verdacht, sagen die jetzt, oh, das ist schlimm, oder sagen die einfach, das ist ein Konkurrent, da müssen wir mal schauen, was ein Konkurrent macht, was adaptieren wir.
Ja genau, und unter der Maßgabe gucken wir nochmal 30 Sekunden in diesen Bericht rein.
Unter dem Deckmantel der Corona- Prävention baut der chinesische Präsident Xi Jinping seinen Überwachungsstaat aus. Dafür nimmt er sogar schlechte Wirtschaftszahlen in Kauf. Vor allem der Konsum seines Landes geht zurück. Zehn Omikron-Varianten gibt es inzwischen im Land und in mehreren Städten wieder Massentest und Angst vor weiteren Lockdowns. Die bedeuten für viele nämlich auch keine Arbeit, kein Gehalt. Das ist problematisch für die kommunistische Partei, die ihren Führungsanspruch damit legitimiert, den Lebensstandard des Volkes zu verbessern.
Da scheint es so einen Wandel zu geben, dass man sich denkt, wir machen es, obwohl die ökonomisch leiden. Wir versprechen uns trotzdem Erfolg davon. Und letzter Gedanke dazu, diese Authentifizierungstechnologien funktionieren heute schon. Sie sind noch nicht sozial ausgerollt und juristisch so festgetackert, dass der Staat sagt, dann machen wir das jetzt auch für unsere Anliegen. Denn Apple hat eben nicht nur die Fido-Sache jetzt einfach als Betriebssystem immanent vorgestellt, sondern hat ja auch dieses Pay-later-System. Was ja bedeutet, ihr habt ja über die Klarna-Schulden und so weiter schon gesprochen, Menschen können sich jetzt bei Apple selbst verschulden.
Aber sie müssen keine Zinsen zahlen, soweit ich weiß. Und bei Klarna muss man ja doch erheblich Zinsen zahlen. Ich hatte es jetzt noch mal im Doppelgänger-Podcast gehört. Wenn man da jetzt fast 80 Euro kauft, hat der Pip Klöckner erzählt, dann bekommt man das Angebot, das ersten 30 Tagen zu bezahlen. Und dann sind das 3 Euro. Und dann hat er das aber mal so hochgerecht auf Jahr. So eigentlich hören wir dann bei so einem Zinssatz von 45%.
Genau, das ist halt die typische Dispo-Ausquetsche, wo man auch versteht, da steckt ein Renditeversprechen dahinter. So machen die das halt. Apple macht es so. Und das wirklich Bezeichnende ist, Apple hat so viel Bargeld, dass ihr einfach jedem Anbieter von irgendwas einfach sagen, verkaufst über die Apple-Plattform, wenn du es über Apple Pay bezahlbar machst, übernehmen wir die Convenience, dass dann der Kunde einfach sagen kann, ich will es in drei Monatsraten bezahlen. Und Apple schießt aus dem eigenen Barvermögen dieses Geld vor.
Genau.
So sicher sind sie sich damit in Verwendung.
Denn das Problem bei den Barvermögen, weil man kann es nicht einfach mal gerade zurückholen, und wir geben es in New York aus, sondern das kostet Steuern. Und jetzt hat man dieses Barvermögen als sichere Bank.
Richtig.
Das ist ja so eine Transformation in eine Bank.
Hat diesen sicheren Hafen, wir haben hier genügend Geld und können das machen. Und damit hat man dann noch größere Kundenbindung geschaffen und hat natürlich klarna empfindlich getroffen.
Ja, also das ist einfach crazy, was jetzt hier am Ende der Corona-Pandemie aus diesem Silicon Valley alles als so fertiges Ding herausgefallen ist. Während, und das ist eben die Eingeschäftsmodelle, die erlten gerade so ein bisschen Schwächeln. Und jetzt alle überlegen, was machen wir eigentlich als nächstes. Und da scheinen sich doch hier ein paar Wege aufgetan zu haben.
Wir bleiben im Digitalen und wir sprechen jetzt über etwas, das ich noch gar nicht benennen will, da du ja auch schon, als ich es eben sagte, was ich besprechen will, bevor wir hier aufgezeichnet haben, sagte, was soll das sein? Oder ich sag's einfach nochmal, da hab ich gesagt, Stefan, wir sprechen dann noch über Roblox. Was soll das sein? Das ist ein gutes Zeichen, wenn jemand, der so digital bewandert ist, Roblox nicht kennt. Und vermutlich geht es dir so, wie fast allen, die uns zuhören. Und mir ging es ja auch bis vor kurzem so, bis ich dann irgendwo so eine Meldung las, die französische Regierung oder so ein paar Politiker in Frankreich sagen, wir müssen mal Roblox stärker regulieren. Das müsste man am besten auf EU-Ebene machen. Und dann hat man aber auch so gut wie nichts dazu im Internet gefunden. Und dann hab ich gedacht, Roblox, ach ja, da war ja was. Das müsste man sich aber erst einmal ansehen, was das eigentlich ist. Und das werden wir jetzt tun.
Im heutigen Bro-Calvin-Roll-Play-Video bin ich eifersüchtig auf die neue Schülerin. Das ist der dritte Teil von der Trennungsserie von Sandy und Kilian.
Sorry, aber ich kann heute nicht.
Mila, sag mir bitte, dass du es auch komisch findest, dass Kilian gar keine Zeit mehr hat. Vielleicht, vielleicht hatte er eine neue Freundin und traut sich einfach nicht zu sagen.
Sandy, schau mal, schau mal, wer da kommt.
Das ist doch die Neue. Was? Er hat wirklich eine neue Freundin? Die sind Nina? Das kann doch nicht sein.
Ein Anliegen dieses Podcasts ist ja, mit Hilfe von Clips Kulisse zu schaffen, Sachen zu untermauern, Verständlichkeit zu fördern. Und jetzt frage ich dich, was wolltest du uns jetzt zeigen, was sind Roblox oder wie die heißen?
So, wir haben jetzt gerade gehört, Sandy Raul oder Raul. Sie ist auf Roblox aktiv und auf YouTube. Auf YouTube gibt es dann solche Videos, in denen sie im Prinzip Seifenopern aufführt. Was haben wir jetzt gerade gehört? Also Roblox ist eine Spieleplattform. Dort kann man selbst Spiele erstellen. Das heißt, man wird als Creator tätig oder man kann auch einfach nur als Spieler dort sein. Aber die Herausforderung besteht eigentlich schon darin, dass man selbst etwas mitdesignt. Das Unternehmen ist kein neues Unternehmen. Das wurde 2004 bereits gegründet von David Bazucki und Eric Cassell. Cassell ist verstorben 2013. Bazucki macht das jetzt alleine und diese Spieleplattform, die ist in enger Kooperation mit ganz vielen Unternehmen, auch mit Tencent, in China. Im März 2021 ging das Unternehmen dann an die Börse. Die Aktie wurde dann zum Starttag mit 64 Dollar gehandelt. Inzwischen ist das dann geschrumpft, hat dann im Februar, zum Beispiel in diesem Jahr, 27 Prozent dann nur einen einzigen Tag verloren. Nun, was ist jetzt eigentlich mit dieser Spieleplattform bedeutend? Nun, diese hat zehn Millionen Entwickler, also zehn Millionen Menschen, die solche Spiele kreieren. Und eine Art mit diesen Spielen dann umzugehen, ist dann, dass man mit den Figuren, mit den Welten, die man erschaffen hat, kleine Geschichten erzählt. Diese dann bei YouTube filmt und für YouTube aufzeichnet und dann da ausspielt.
Aber Entwickler im Sinne von, das ist eine Entwicklungsumgebung, die so weit vereinfacht wurde, dass man da einfach gestaltet.
Genau, das ist so wie Minecraft oder so etwas. Also man kann da als junger Mensch vor allem, kann man da präsent sein. Wenn ich die Zahl richtig im Kopf habe, dann haben die täglich, tägliche User von 60 oder 80 Millionen.
Das ist schon so Fortnight-Niveau.
60, 80 Millionen User sind täglich auf Roblox unterwegs. Jetzt haben wir diese Sandy Raugird, die erzählt also dort Seifenopern-Geschichten. Und das ist dann wiederum ein YouTube-Kanal, wo sie diese Seifenopern täglich oder alle paar Tage fortsetzt. Man braucht nur mal bei YouTube Roblox eingeben. Es sind unendlich viele Untergenres da und da ganz neue YouTuber hervorgegangen, die nur von ihren Roblox-Welten Berichten oder Geschichten daraus erzählen. Wir hören jetzt mal den YouTuber Seddy, der auch bei Roblox aktiv ist.
Wolltet ihr eigentlich von mir? Warum habt ihr mir denn gesagt, dass ich stehen bleiben soll? Oh, nun ja, du siehst aus wie ein geeigneter Kandidat für unseren Plan. Ein geeigneter Kandidat für euren Plan, mich zu überfahren oder was genau? Nein, keine Sorge, wir wollten dich nicht überfahren. Aber das, was wir dir anbieten werden, ist fast genauso schlimm wie überfahren zu werden. Das hört sich doch gar nicht so schlimm an, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Oh, du machst das kostenlos? Ich wollte dir eigentlich eine Million Dollar dafür geben. Aber wenn du sie nicht haben willst, dann ist das kein Problem. Eine Million Dollar? Ich höre auf jeden Fall sehr gespannt zu. Aber können wir das irgendwo bereden, wo wir nicht so auffällig sind? Auffällig? Warum genau denn auffällig? Na ja, vielleicht weil ihr mit einem goldenen Panzer gegen einen Krankenhaus gefahren seid. Und das könnte die Presse interessieren.
Also wir hören es ja hier nur, sehen es nicht. Aber wenn das visuell mit der Akustik mithält, ist das ja ein richtiges Standard-Kinderprogramm.
Das ist Kika und Nickelodeon und so ein Nickelodeon. Genau. Die User sind entsprechend jung. 47 Prozent der Roblox-User sind unter 13 Jahren. Wir hören mal weiter, man kann sich da auch große Häuser bauen.
Ich habe meinen Traum erfüllt und mir mein eigenes Apartment gekauft. Ab geht es, wir betreten das Ganze. Und so sieht es von innen aus. Zweite Etage, hier wird es bestimmt ein bisschen mehr geben und nö, anscheinend auch nicht. Das muss sich auf jeden Fall ändern. Deswegen wird unser heutiges Ziel zusammen sein. Unser nagelneues eine Million Euro Apartment von innen komplett einzurichten.
Ja, also 100 Prozent der Kinder in meinem Haushalt sind unter 13 Jahre und ich habe davon aber trotzdem noch nichts gehört.
Du musst mal deine Kinder fragen, vielleicht wissen die mehr als du. Wir haben jetzt den Roblox Creator Sentex gehört, der uns jetzt mitnimmt in dieses Haus. Wir wissen, die Hauspreise sind in der realen Welt hoch. Sie sind es auch bei Roblox. Also für eine Million hat er jetzt ein Traumhaus sich errichtet. Und das bedeutet natürlich auch, dass man Arbeiter unter sich hat.
Natürlich, oh ja, kümmern wir uns jetzt um die ganze Inneinrichtung von unserem Apartment. Da haben wir schon den ersten Worker am Start. Zack, zack, zack, ab geht es. Die ganzen Arbeiter, die hier unten arbeiten. Hier, zack, ab geht es. Yo, hallo, du heißt Tom, du heißt Tom, du heißt Tom und du heißt Olaf. Hallo, Olaf. Ja, Olaf hat einfach kein Gesicht. Die sind jetzt hier fleißig in meinem Apartment. Oh, cooles Cape. Hier arbeiten, ihr seht es. Und die bringen uns natürlich jetzt hier ganz, ganz viel Geld bei. Oh mein Gott, wieder 8000 Cash an mir am Start.
Der Arbeiter ist gesichtslos oder namenlos. Das ist das Entscheidende hier. Wir sehen hier schon, wie sich früh in die kindlichen Köpfe die kapitalistische Ideologie einschleicht. Und man weiß, Eigentum bringt nur was, wenn man auch in der Lage ist, es zu verteidigen. Was braucht man also? Waffen.
Und mit dem Geld werden wir natürlich jetzt alles mögliche kaufen. Solche Dekorationen in unserem Apartment, sehr sehr wichtig. Oder noch mehr Dekorationen. Oder eine Shotgun? Ja, eine Shotgun. Wer kennt es nicht? Hallo, wir müssen natürlich auch unser Apartment beschützen, falls es irgendwelche Diebe oder sowas gibt, die hier einbrechen wollen. Wir lehnen natürlich hier noch in einer Stadt. Wir können uns mal eine Sniper... Wir können damit sogar zielen. Weiter geht es. Was gibt es hier alles noch am Start? Ja, Olaf, schön, weiter arbeiten. Sehr, sehr gut. Eine Rifle am Start, alles klar. Natürlich auch hier nur zu unserer eigenen Sicherheit.
Es gibt insgesamt zehn Millionen dieser Experiences, so werden die genannt. Also es sind dann nicht als Spiele genannt, sondern es sind dann digitale Areale, die man sich kreieren kann, wo man natürlich viel Arbeit und auch Geld investieren muss, um dann so etwas zu errichten.
Also ich hab's mir gerade mal aufgerufen in der Bildersuche Roblox, um einen kurzen ästhetischen Einblick zu haben. Als damals der erste Lego-Film kam, hab ich die Rezension für die FAZ darüber geschrieben und fand das wahnsinnig interessant, in die Unternehmensgeschichte mal kurz rein zu gucken, weil die ja schon drauf Wert gelegt haben, das ist so ein animierter Film, aber jeder Stein ist unikat. Also sie wird nicht einfach ein Stein dupliziert, sondern jeder, wenn man nah ranzoom, sieht das aus wie ein echter benutzter Stein, der hat so seine Macken und so. Und die Unternehmensgeschichte von Lego war ja so, dass sie schon mal so eine Digitalisierungsoffensive gestartet haben und daran fast zugrunde ging. Weil das ganze Unternehmen, weil irgendwelche digitalen Jünger aus Amerika kamen und meinten, bürstet mal das Unternehmen auf digital, die haben diese Steine vernachlässigt. Absolutes Desaster. Lego war fast pleite. Dann haben sie gesagt, wir gehen zurück zu den Steinen, wir machen echtes Spielzeug. Dann sind sie die ganzen Partnerschaften eingegangen mit Batman hier, Star Wars da und so weiter. Das war der Knaller. Also das Unternehmen hat es wieder in den Orbit geschossen. Und wenn ich mir Roblox so angucke, steckt hier drin so eine Geschichte, bei der ich denke, ja, Lego selbst ist an der Digitalisierung gescheitert.
Aber die machen hier Lego.
Und dann kam aber Minecraft. Und Minecraft jetzt wieder mehr in diese Lego-Ästhetik-Richtung gedrückt, mit so einem, es muss irgendwie funktionieren, das digital zu machen, auch wenn es Lego selbst nicht hingekriegt hat. Und das scheint jetzt so die Geschichte von Roblox zu sein, weil das sieht wirklich amüsant aus. Und klar, vor einer Minute kannte ich das noch nicht. Und jetzt sehe ich die Bilder und denke, doch, das kenne ich. Das ist nämlich einfach Lego. Also die Sehgewohnheiten sind doch hier sehr abgeholt einfach.
Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass viele schon gesehen haben, es wird dann bei YouTube nämlich auch auf Empfehlungsseiten immer mal wieder angezeigt. Dann denkt man nur einfach, ach ja, irgendwas mit Kindern vielleicht, irgendwas buntes, aber man klickt dann doch nicht drauf. Nun wollen wir mal ein bisschen über das Finanzielle sprechen. Wir hören jetzt noch einmal so eine Roblox-Influencerin, Creatorin Mackenzie Turner, wie sie ihr Video startet. Und diese Mackenzie Turner, ich weiß nicht, wie alt sie ist. Also sie ist glaube ich Anfang 20, aber als Kindfrau verkleidet ganz in Pink. Und das hört sich so an, was sie von sich gibt.
Hey Cuties, heute werde ich nur mit der Farbe Pink für einen Roblox-Akkau.
Pink ist mein Lieblings-Fürstchen, also denke ich nicht, dass es zu schwer für mich wird.
Was sieht ein pinker Roblox-Akkau denn so aus?
Man kann sich das ungefähr vorstellen.
Und man kann sich auch vorstellen, wie sehr ich gelitten habe in der Portemonnaienvorbereitung. Nun, Pink ist sie und jetzt geht sie in den Shop von Roblox.
Ich muss den Asap-Ton wechseln. Okay, aber mögen wir einen Baby-Pink-Ton?
Wir müssen das Pink-Ton Asap ausmachen.
Aber bevor ich was von der Avatar-Shop kaufen kann, muss ich ein paar Robux bekommen.
Aha, was ist mit dem hier?
Das hier ist alles pink, es hat verschiedene Farben.
Erinnert mich an die 12-Ton-Musik, bei der jeder Ton den gleichen Wert hat und niemand soll hier mal rauspiken. Hier versucht man es umgedreht, es ist auch alles auf einem Niveau, aber eben zwei Stockwerke zu hoch. Also das ist nur angebrüllt die ganze Zeit.
Sie ist unglaublich beliebt. Ich kann mir das aussehen, was nicht funktioniert. Das sind alles Creator, die enorme Reichweiten haben und viel Geld verdienen, indem sie natürlich eigene Kollektionen herausgeben, also Skins, die man dort kaufen kann. Und natürlich sind längst bei Roblox die großen Unternehmen zu Hause. Und zwar hören wir jetzt mal hier einen in Twisted Pandora, der ein Gucci Event ankündigt.
Ja, wir sind ja hier durch die Stadt gelaufen. Louis Vuitton Leute gesehen, die einfach Schlange stehen, um da reinzukommen, um sich was auch immer von der Stange zu kaufen, was in China hergestellt wird, obwohl daneben Schneider ist. Aber es ist sozusagen nicht unikat für dich gemacht, obwohl du für den Preis das auch machen könntest. Und wir haben uns sehr darüber gewundert. Und ja, warum nicht sowas auch in der digitalen Welt? Der Irrsinn ist einfach überall.
Anders kann man es nicht ausdrücken. 2021 hat Gucci 400 virtuelle Taschen bei Roblox angeboten, für sechs Dollar ursprünglich. Aber der Run war natürlich so groß und natürlich auch gewollt. Dass das Ganze dann für horrende Preise weiterverkauft wurde. Ein User hat zum Beispiel 4000 Dollar für eine solche Gucci Roblox Tasche bezahlt.
Haben die eine Nummer drin? Ist das NFT-mäßig, kryptomäßig?
Ja, die sind dann limitiert auf 400. Und dann bist du einer der 400. Der Gucci Garten, der erstellt wurde in Roblox, hat bislang 19 Millionen User angelockt. Nike ist jetzt auch dort vertreten, oder Nike sagt man ja, mit Nike-Land. Dann Spotify ist dort mit Spotify Island. Und dazu heißt es bei Spotify, Through Spotify Island we are creating an easy opportunity for artists to connect with fans and to partner with Spotify on the creation of in-game virtual merchandise. Vermutlich könnten wir jetzt auch, weil wir bei Spotify den Podcast auch hochladen, auch in zu Island gehen, um uns dort zu treffen, zu connecten, wie es heißt. Es ist grauenhaft. Ganz viele Unternehmen sind jetzt dort. Das wird immer größer. Die Leute sind bereit, für diese digitalen Dinge Geld zu zahlen. So auch Tristed Pandora berichtet hier.
Das kommt mit einem ein wenig seltsamen Gimmick. Das ist in meiner Meinung absolut verrückt. Wenn du die Leute auf Quests machen würdest, dann solltest du die Item frei machen. Ich weiß nicht, das klingt nicht richtig in meinem Buch. Aber ich zeige dir, was es ist. Diese zwei Items im Anfang, sie sehen aus wie die gleichen, sie sind anders. Du kannst sie alle für 300 Roblox verkaufen, von jetzt an den 3. Wenn du auf den nächsten gehst, die Emerald Gucci Blondie Bag, musst du noch mehr machen, aber bei einem späteren Tag, ein Wochen später, am 10.
Ja, das ist doch gut. Du musst dein Commitment zeigen, indem du Geld zahlst oder deine Arbeit. Genau.
Oder indem du jemanden anstellst, der für dich diese Taschen ergattert. Man hat also auch da ein Geschäft von Click-Workern, selbstverständlich. Und das funktioniert nur so. Ich hab mir dann das angesehen, wie das so ist, wenn man eine Welt erstellt sich, dann gibt's dann so verschiedene Challenges, die man durchlaufen muss. Dann steht hier Brüte, das Basis-Ei und das Sonnengott-Ei am Anfang aus, um Pets zu bekommen. Also du hast dann so kleine Tierchen, Haustiere. Die Haustiere, die helfen dir dann wiederum, dass du mehr Klicks bekommst. Und das sorgt dann dafür, dass du pro Wiedergeburt, also desproduziert wieder Wiedergeburten, bekommst du zehn Edelsteine. Und diese Edelsteine kannst du dann auch wieder investieren. Das heißt, hier wird immer so eine Robinson-Croeso-Ökonomie gemacht. Und ganz früh wird wirklich dieses kapitalistische und unternehmerische Handeln internalisiert. Die effektivste Art Edelsteine in Roblox, Klicker Simulator zu farmen, ist der Kauf von Wiedergeburtshaustieren. Das heißt, du kaufst Tiere, die produzieren wieder diese Edelsteine und so weiter. Jedes Wiedergeburtshaustier erhöht deine Klicks um einiges mehr als die normalen Haustiere, die du beim Ausbrüten des Eis erhältst. Wenn du die Achievements erfüllst, wirst du mit Klicks, Wiedergeburt und Edelstein belohnt. Und gut ist natürlich, du hast eine Welt geschaffen, in der andere kommen und dort irgendwas machen, sodass du dann reicher wirst. Was bekommst du dann da? Nun, du wirst ausgezahlt in Robux.
Robux ist ein guter Name, finde ich.
Ja, Robux ist die Ingame-Währung des Spiels. Also du kannst auch direkt Robux kaufen und sagen, ich will 400 Robux haben, dann kosten die momentan zum Beispiel 4, 99 Euro. Und dann steigert sich das so als Premium-Abonnent, bekommst du dann regelmäßig etwas mehr Robux. Und auf der Seite ist dann immer von Einkommen die Rede. Wir hören da auch mal weiter, wie diese Partnerschaften da aussehen. Wir hören jetzt Manuel Bronstein, das ist der Roblox Chief Product Officer, der war bei Financial Times zu Gast.
Gucci kam und hat sich etwas gemacht, das sie den Gucci-Gardens auf Roblox nennen. Sie haben den Gucci-Gardens in, ich glaube, in Florence, und du musstest dort sein, wenn du es wirklich zu besuchen willst. Aber sie haben realisiert, dass nicht viele Leute in Florence gehen können und das Event in realer Leben ist. Also haben sie uns eine Replik der Gucci-Gardens in Roblox gemacht. Und eine der coolen Dinge, die sie gemacht haben, ist, dass sie jeden Morgen ein anderes und ein limited Item verliehen, das man eigentlich sammeln kann, wenn man mit der Erfahrung teilnimmt. Und diese limited Items wurden so wie die Erlebnisse, die die Leute auf einer Plattform verkaufen und wiederverkaufen können. Und viele von ihnen verkaufen mehr als die Kosten der echten Gucci-Bug. Das zeigt dir die Kraft der Menschen, ihre digitale Identität zu verbreiten und diese digitalen Items zu kümmern.
Vielleicht sind also die, die vor dem Louis Vuitton-Shop Schlange stehen, nicht die verrücktesten. Wie sehr das schon in der Mitte der Gesellschaft angekommen ist, diese Denkweise, ich kauf da Items und Skins digital, ich mein bei Fortnite ist das ja auch gang und gäbe, das können wir hier zum Beispiel hören von einer SPD-Bundestagsabgeordneten, die auf TikTok folgendes Video veröffentlicht hat.
Wir heben die Grenze von 450 auf 520 Euro an, sodass du 70 Euro mehr im Monat für Fortnite-Skins, FIFA-Packs oder NFTs ausgeben kannst.
Also Statussymbole hängen ja mal davon ab, wen man sie zeigen kann und wenn die einem hier suggerieren, dass die ganze Welt sieht, was du für eine Tasche hast, während du selber nur drei Freunde hast, wo es analog keinen Sinn macht, so zu investieren, aber hier dann schon, dann haben die dir noch mal einen Einfallswinkel gefunden, um den Leuten das Geld aus der Tasche zu ziehen.
Und auch diese schöne Idee, wenn wir uns gegenseitig digitale Produkte verkaufen, die keinerlei Wert haben, dann können wir gemeinsam reich werden, was natürlich ein Unfug ist. Aber wir hören jetzt mal, was People Make Games dazu sagt. Das ist ein YouTube Kanal, der sich kritisch damit auseinandersetzt.
Am meisten sind sie die Beziehung mit Branden wie Vans, der YouTuber KSI oder der schwedischen Popstar Zara Larsson. Und wenn diese Initial-Sale-Periode vorbei ist, die einzige Art, die Kinder sie bekommen, ist, sie mit anderen Roblox-Userern oder mit anderen Roblox-Utern direkt auszupacken.
Und wenn wir jetzt hören, Apple Pay Later und es gibt Glaner, und man hat hier lauter Produkte, die limitiert sind, das heißt zeitlich befristet erhältlich sind, dann kann man sich vorstellen, wie schnell Leute bereit sind, sich zu verschulden. Oder Kinder wollen, dass die Eltern es jetzt doch unbedingt kaufen, weil es das nur noch heute gibt.
Ist alles unglaublich.
Also das ist eine Form der Quengelware, die man da produziert hat, die gigantisch ist. Nun ist es ja so, dass man selbst dort als Erschaffer von Welten auftritt und das aber vielleicht gar nicht selbst machen will, beziehungsweise das System ist ja so aufgebaut, es ist ja wirklich auch wieder so eine Ponzi Scheme Sache und also noch viel mehr als das eigentlich. Denn die bauen eine Welt mit einem verrückten Regelwerk und dann versprechen sie einem, es ist ganz toll hier, du kannst hier reich werden. Du musst nur ganz oft klicken und ganz oft ein Ei ausbrüten lassen und so weiter. Und dann zeigen sie aber Abkürzungen, wie man schneller an Geld kommt, indem man Geld ihnen gibt. Und das ist auch bemerkenswert, ist ja keineswegs so, dass bei diesen ganzen Transaktionen, wenn du da dein Roblox wieder mal umtauschen willst in Geld oder so, dass die dann nichts dafür nehmen, sondern jede Transaktion, die da stattfindet, da erhält Roblox 30 Prozent.
Das ist einfach sehr gut. Manchmal will man ihnen auch einfach gratulieren dafür. Wir wurden früher mit Tamagotchi abgespeist. Was für eine Meisterleistung, so ein Ding da hinzusetzen.
Man will ihnen eigentlich für diese Treistigkeit gratulieren, weil man ja selbst nie auf die Gedanken kommen würde, dass das geht. Es gibt so Rechenmodelle, wo dann gezeigt wird, wenn man mal da 100 Euro reingegeben hat, hat Roblox dafür bekommen. Robux will die irgendwann wieder umwandeln. Also am Ende hast du noch 22 Euro von deinen 100 Euro übrig.
Ja, ich meine vor 20 Jahren hat man den Leuten Geld aus der Tasche gezogen, also den Jugendlichen, die jetzt auch hier wieder, indem man sagt, schick eine SMS an Viva für 50 Cent, dann wirst du für drei Sekunden unten eingeblendet. Ja, so kannst du den Gruß loswerden. Oder willst du diesen Musikklingelton runterladen, den gestern jemand, genau, wo einfach nur 15 Töne irgendwie aufeinander folgen, in MIDI reinfolge, ohne jegliche Raffinesse für zwei Euro und so. Ja, und in deren Sicht, warum nicht? Man hat die alten Geschäftsmodelle gesehen, hat sich gesagt, es gibt keine Untergrenze, was irgendwie so die Blödheit angeht und so weiter. Wir können das mit technischer Raffinesse alles verwirklichen. Ja, und dann hat man das gemacht.
Wir erleben jetzt einen YouTuber, der das mal getestet hat. Nee, bei People Make Games haben sie das getestet. Also wie bekommt man jetzt so einen Klicker Simulator?
Ich versuche es seit mittlerweile acht Monaten, mir ein Roblox Spiel zu kaufen. Und heute kann ich euch endlich meinen eigenen Klicker Simulator präsentieren. Ich habe mir das natürlich auf Fiverr gekauft und ich habe dem Typen geschrieben am Anfang, ich will einen Roblox Simulator. Ich will einen Klicker Simulator haben, der so ähnlich sein soll zu dem populären Klicker Simulator, den es zurzeit gibt. Aber ich kann euch jetzt mal den Preis sagen, den ich gezahlt habe jetzt dafür. Ich habe für den Klicker Simulator 160 Dollar bezahlt. Schauen wir mal, was ich dafür bekomme. Und wir schauen uns das Spiel an und hoffen, dass es gut ist. 250 Coins brauche ich erstmal für mein erstes Pet. Dann formen wir uns die jetzt mal zusammen und können unser erstes Pet unabhängig von Fox bekommen. Denn Epic Fox, yeah, I guess, cool. Und wir können gleich mal Rebuffen. Lass uns gleich mal fünf Mal Rebuffen, um ein paar mehr Coins zu bekommen. Wir gehen jetzt hier hin, haben jetzt fünf Mal gerebufft. Wenn ich einmal klicke, bekomme ich direkt 25 Coins. Davon kann ich mir gleich nochmal ein paar mehr Rebuff holen und mir dann auch die ersten Pets holen. Hier sind Portale. Wie komme ich auf diese Portale, Leute? Wie viele Rebuff brauche ich dafür? 100.000 Rebuff und 10 Millionen Rebuff fürs Lava-Land. Aber wir gönnen uns jetzt wieder ein paar Rebuff, und zwar für 2.750 Coins. Wir haben jetzt 10 Rebuff insgesamt schon mal. Und jetzt will ich mir mal die 10.000 Coins hier farmen, um mir vielleicht ein Legendary Pet direkt zu holen.
Unzählige Videos gibt es dieser Art auf YouTube, die einem erklären, wie man angeblich reich wird auf Roblox. Es ist an sich ganz einfach. Man muss nur dies und das und das und dann wird es immer verrückter und immer komplizierter, dass selbst dieser Experte von People Make Games sagt.
Und das war nur mit der Hilfe von Zehn Roblox-User, die mir Dinge erklären. Was hofft, dass die meisten Eltern und Politiker genau verstehen, was ihre Kinder auf Roblox tun, oder mit wem, oder die vielen und unterschiedlichen Wege, die Roblox-Korporation von ihnen profitiert?
Wir hören mal von dieser neuen Form. Ich würde es durchaus Kinderarbeit nennen.
Die Kinder sind nicht nur Hobbyisten, sie machen wirkliche Arbeit, die den Wert eines der größten Videogame-Publisierer in der Geschichte fährt. Aber mit einer Karte, die nur ein Drittel der Industriestandards ist und niemanden für ihre Gesundheit schaut, mussten wir fragen, ob die nächste Generation von Videogame-Developern als Ersatzgeber vor dem Schulabend noch erledigt wird?
Ja, damit hätten wir natürlich die Gewerkschaften auch fern, um mal ganz weit auszuholen, wenn man, wer die einfach sagt, ja, bei Roblox ist irgendwas, die, dass die click wirken da so. Und dann ist das so obskur, dass selbst die Typen Monate brauchen, um das nachvollziehen zu können.
Wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, ich lasse den Podcast von 11-Jährigen schneiden, dann würde jeder sagen, ja, es ist Kinderarbeit.
Genau.
Aber wenn die da irgendwas machen mit Coins und hin und her und die buttern auch sogar noch Geld selbst da rein, dann ist das nicht mehr nachvollziehbar.
Wer arbeitet da und was ist eigentlich Arbeit?
Hier werden die neuen Franchtheits herausgebildet. Und das Wählerpotenzial für die FDP wird da herangebildet. Also man kann es schaffen, man muss sich nur anstrengen, aber es ist natürlich wie immer in einem solchen System, es gewinnen die Gewinner.
Wenn du auf Roblox spielen willst, dann gibt es nur die 1.000 oder so Spiele, die von den meisten Spielern in den letzten 20 Millionen Jahren aussehen. Die Up- Du kannst auswischen und dein Spiel vor Streamern oder YouTubers versuchen, oder du kannst Roblox bezahlen, um es zu verkaufen.
Es ist ein geniales System, bei dem man erst einmal Geld mitbringt, das man dort Geld verdienen kann. Und damit man es aber wirklich verdienen kann, muss man ihnen dann nochmal Geld geben, um die Sachen beworben zu bekommen. Und die Idee ist, dass man selbst so eine Experience erschafft, so ein Spiel baut, das dann andere nutzen wollen und dass man dann Spielpässe verteilt oder da Avatare zulässt. Und dann kann man da auch zwischen 25 und 1000 Robux verlangen. Das ist also diese Idee, eigentlich dass man so eine Art Freizeitparkbetreiber wird. Also vielleicht kennen die Leute noch dieses Spiel Rollercoaster Tycoon. Und da war es einfach so, dass man so Freizeitparks bauen konnte. Und dann gab es auch so eine virtuelle Währung. Aber hier ist es wirklich so, als würde man wirklich jetzt Leute aus der Realität, die aber ein Roblox-Profil haben, denen sagen kann, besucht doch mal meinen Freizeitpark, kostet so und so viel. Und natürlich wird alles immer dann in dieser eigenen Währung ausgezahlt. Wie sind aber da die Erfolgschancen überhaupt?
Und dann sagt es die nächste Sache, oh, wenn du Leute an deinem Spiel spielen möchtest, dann kannst du uns Geld geben. Aber wie es so deutlich klingt, wissen wir, dass das funktioniert.
Manchmal denke ich, dass Roblox-Games eine virale TikTok oder eine virale Memo machen.
Es ist geradezu unmöglich, da Erfolge zu haben, das strategisch zu planen. Es ist dann eher so, wie man sagen kann, ja, es hat doch immer ein paar Kinderstars gegeben. Und ja, es gibt noch ein paar, die dann bei Roblox zu schaffen. Aber es ist natürlich kein System, das irgendwie egalitär aufgebaut ist.
Ja, vor allem, hier sieht man wieder, Knappheit ist immer da, die Knappheit der Aufmerksamkeit. Und selbst wenn du Erfolg hast, bist du in dieser prekären Lage, komplett dieser Plattform ausgeliefert zu sein. Irgendwer schreibt irgendeinen anderen Code und dann hängst du da als Creator. Und dann ist alles nichts mehr wert. Kann ja auch wirklich immer sein, wie bei TikTok oder bei Facebook ja auch. Dass die einfach diesen Algorithmus umstellen, auch immer so ein bisschen tabula rasa oder sowas zu machen, mal was Neues auszuprobieren. Wir hatten jetzt ein Jahr lang immer Nachrichten ganz oben, jetzt wollen wir mal wieder private Sachen. Und zack, ist dein ganzes Geschäftsmodell irgendwie hinüber. Und das ist ja hier dann irgendwie auch.
Wir können das, wo du das gerade ansprichst, mal gerade dahin switchen. Adam Mossery ist von Instagram und versucht hier mal zu sagen, was sie ganz tolles Neues sich für Instagram überlegt haben.
Und wir hören viele Probleme von euch. Wenn ihr eine neue, volles Bildungsschritte seht, oder ihr es hört, dann ist das ein Test. Es ist ein Test für ein paar Prozent der Leute, und die Idee ist, dass eine mehr volles Bildungsschritte Erfahrung, nicht nur für Videos, aber auch für Fotos, eine mehr Spaßvolle, engagierte Erfahrung sein wird. Aber ich will auch klar sein, dass es noch nicht gut ist. Wir werden es in ein gutes Gebiet bekommen, wenn wir es den Rest der Instagram-Kommunikation schicken. Die zweite Sache, die ich jetzt sehr mit den Fotos und wie wir mit Video schichten, ist, dass wir weiterhin Fotos unterstützen. Das sagt, ich muss ehrlich sein. Ich glaube, dass mehr und mehr Instagram Video über Zeit werden. Wir sehen das, wenn wir nichts verändern. Wenn man sich nur auf chronologische Feed anschaut, wenn man sich auf Instagram anschaut, ist das mehr und mehr Video über Zeit verändern. Wenn man sich auf Instagram anschaut, ist das mehr und mehr Video über Zeit verändern. Auch wenn wir nichts verändern.
Eigentlich bauen die da jetzt TikTok auch.
Ja genau.
Kopieren ist, wollen jetzt mit diesen Kurzvideos auch entsprechende Reichweiten erzielen und was sie jetzt auch ändern ist, dass sie eigentlich wie TikTok den Algorithmus entscheiden lassen wollen, was man sieht. Zwar wird einem noch angezeigt weiterhin, wie man so folgt, aber sie sagen auch, es soll eine tolle Erfahrung für dich sein, dass du Neues entdecken kannst. Und wir wissen von TikTok eigentlich um zwei Probleme. Es gibt ja einmal dieses Rabbit Hole Problem. Und das andere Problem, dass jetzt seine widerspricht sich so ein bisschen, aber ich komm, man kann doch beides beobachten. Das andere ist, dass man wohl auch schon herausgefunden hat, dass immer wieder Videos einem gezeigt werden, die einen mit etwas konfrontieren, von dem der Algorithmus weiß, das passt dem nicht, damit Interaktion stattfindet. Das ist ja schon etwas, was wir bei der Facebook Timeline immer gesehen haben. Man kann nicht einfach nur irgendwas posten oder Leuten anzeigen. Was ihnen gefällt, da passiert gar nicht so viel. Aber wenn die erst mal böse werden, wenn sie Kommentare wütend tippen, das nächste und nächste anklicken, dann hat man eine hohe Verweildauer und eine hohe Interaktion. So hat man wohl auch schon mal sehen können, dass dann Leute, die AfD-Content gucken, plötzlich queerfeministische Inhalte angezeigt bekommen, weil die dann richtig wütend werden. Was macht das da? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, weil das Facebook gut erprobt hat, auf Facebook schon, dass man jetzt guckt, wie können wir eigentlich mit Instagram da mehr Interaktion herstellen? Momentan ist ja immer noch so Instagram der Ort der Liebe oder was, aber wenn man jetzt so mehr auf Konfrontation geht über diese algorithmische Steuerung, dann wird sich auch Instagram sehr verändern.
Ja, Instagram macht derzeit ganz schön viele Fehler und man sieht auch, dass sie mit dem Rücken an der Wand stehen da bei Facebook irgendwie, um da noch letzte Dinge rauszuholen. Ja, man scrollt so durch und sieht relativ viel Kram, von dem man weiß, das habe ich nicht abonniert. Trotzdem erregt es so für eine Sekunde die Aufmerksamkeit. Und man bleibt deswegen wahrscheinlich auch eine Sekunde länger. Aber auf lange Sicht entwertet das die Plattform, wie TikTok für mich auch komplett entwertet ist. Da erwarte ich nicht irgendwas von irgendwem zu sehen, wo mir wichtig ist, wer hat's gepostet, zu welcher Zeit und was seh ich da überhaupt, sondern da geht's nur um, was steckt in diesem Video drin und deswegen hat das am Anfang so eine hohe Attraktivität, aber irgendwann hört man halt auf TikTok zu gucken, weil dann hat man sich auch satt gesehen und so und ist vorbei. Und diese Gefahr droht bei Instagram da eben auch. Bei Instagram folge ich Leuten und wenn mir das nicht angezeigt wird, sondern ich alle drei Posts eine Werbung bekomme und dann im Anschluss irgendwas, was ich gar nicht abonniert hab, das ist doch dumm. Also das müssen die doch selber irgendwie sehen, dass das irgendwie bescheuert ist. Oder ich falle halt auch wieder aus ihrer demografischen, entscheidenden Publikumsgruppe.
Ja, diese Doom Scrawling Gruppe, die man einfach nur lange dabei hat mit, als wenn du jetzt mal überlegst, ein junger Mensch, der vielleicht eine Stunde auf TikTok am Tag verbringt, das ist ja noch wenig. Also sind ja durchaus zwei, drei Stunden. Und so viel, wenn du das jetzt mal auf Instagram überträgst, wenn du 500 Leuten folgst, wenn du aber drei Stunden da verbringen würdest, auf der Plattform, da hast du ja von denen alles dreimal gesehen. Und ich glaube, da gibt es jetzt wieder so diese Idee, könnte die Zeit, die Verweildauer verlängern, indem man sie dann mit Inhalten konfrontiert, die sich nicht angeklickt haben.
Diese Affinesse ist ja irgendwie nicht dabei, sondern ich mache das ja auf abends, habe den ganzen Tag nicht reingeguckt und bekomme dann nur so ein Zeug.
Aber ich glaube, du bist damit nicht der übliche User, denn kaum jemand, der Instagram so nutzt, sagt, ich habe den ganzen Tag nicht reingeguckt.
Ich kaufe manchmal auch Sachen, die mir bei Instagram angezeigt werden.
Tatsächlich?
Also kleine Spiele, also so Hardware-Spiele, die ich dann Tage später mit der Post bekomme und so. Solche Sachen, das ist klar. Ich habe auch immer mal Uhren angeklickt, obwohl ich niemals mir eine Uhr für irgendwas super teuer, also nur weil sie schön aussieht oder sowas, kaufen würde. Aber bei manchen Sachen könnten die eigentlich so langsam merken, wo ich dann auch wirklich kaufe. Ich bleibe dann auch immer extra im Instagram-Browser, damit sie sehen, dass mich das dann wirklich interessiert hat und mir hoffentlich mehr anzeigen. Da aber sehe ich wenig Interessantes, was darauf folgt. Stattdessen kriege ich diese scheiße Videos die ganze Zeit.
Wir springen zurück zu Roblox und der eigenen Währung.
So, wenn du 100.000 Robux nicht für 1000 US-Dollar bekommst, bekommst du 350 Dollar.
Sie gehen nur rund und rund, mit Roblox, das ist der Unterschied zu den Jettons im Casino. Die werden einfach umgetauscht. Man hat das mit den Jettons erstmal, weil man ja glaubt, dass das Geld ein bisschen leichter sitzt, wenn man mit Schiff spielt und wenn es spiegelt ist, wenn es kein echtes Geld ist.
Man braucht eben auch große Münzen.
Ja und und es ist damit immer die über diese Bank geregelt und diese Jettons nimmt man ja auch nicht mit nach Hause, sondern die werden dann umgetauscht und hier funktioniert das Prinzip natürlich anders. Eigentlich soll alles bei denen bleiben, dann haben sie genügend Geld und das kann man dann vergleichen, historisch mit folgendem.
Und übrigens, die Lackung der Regulation in heute's Tech-Sektor sieht viele historisch illegale Praktiken wieder zurück mit einem neuen Schaden. Roblox zahlen Leute in Robux ist sehr, sehr ähnlich zu historischen Mining- und Logging-Camps in den USA, die zahlen Leute in Company Script.
Company Script, also da haben Unternehmen, große Unternehmen dann auch quasi eine eigene Währung oder Gutscheine rausgegeben, die man auch dann nur bei diesem Unternehmen wieder einlösen konnte und haben das als eine Entlohnung angesehen und das ist verboten, das auf diese Weise zu tun. Und hier wiederholt sich das System. Dann denke ich mir, da gibt es auch noch ein paar alte Gesetze, die müssen wir doch jetzt nur noch mal reaktivieren. Aber du siehst, da gibt es die Politik überhaupt auch noch, glaube ich, auf diesem, also bis diese Roblox-Thema. Da gibt es ja noch so ein paar andere ähnliche Plattformen, die so funktionieren, ist dann noch gar nicht da. Und das ist auch so interessant bei diesen ganzen angeblichen Familienpolitiker nur, denen die Kinder so wichtig sind. Die kommen immer, wenn irgendwie ein Horrorfilm zensiert werden soll, das können wir den Kindern nicht zutrauen oder so. Hier diese ganzen, oh nein, ist das Layla, der Text, das kann man niemandem zumuten. Irgendwie so Dinge, irgendwelche Sachen werden immer so, da müssen wir jetzt verschützen und wie schützen wir unsere Kinder vor Pornografie und so. Aber hier müsste man auch mal überlegen, wie schützt man eigentlich die Kinder da vor.
Und das ist das Herz des Successes von Roblox. Wenn man einen jungen Wunderkind auf Roblox macht, ist das nichts, was einen alten Team von Entwicklern oder von den Schauspielern, die.
Da ist zuletzt so ein Podcast dazu gemacht, dass es gar nicht so gut funktioniert mehr für Amazon. Und es erinnert mich aber auch an Eric Schmidt damals 2012 oder so, wie er in seinem Buch schrieb, dass er mit so einem anderen Typ, der auch so eine junge aufschriebene Karriere dabei Google gemacht hat, also so meinte, Marktwirtschaft ist noch voll gut und das brauchen wir auch. Und man dachte so, ja genau, zu eurer Inspiration, damit ihr so seht, was so los ist, weil ihr das alles, was an guten Ideen ist, dann einfach importieren könnt. Aber es ist niemals Konkurrenz zu euch. Also klar, wir brauchen den marktwirtschaftlichen Kampf und so die Konkurrenz belebt das Geschäft. Ja, genau, es inspiriert euch einfach, das zu sehen, was da passiert. Und der Markt ist ansonsten geschlossen.
Und es stimmt Amazon baut das jetzt ein bisschen zurück.
Ja, diese eigenen, weil sie es ausgereizt haben.
Ich war aber auch überrascht von dieser ungeheuren Zahl, also dass die, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, 43.000 eigene Produkte haben. Wir hören etwas aus dem Bloomberg Technology Podcast. Emily Chung befragt hier David Basuki. Das ist der CEO und Gründer von Roblox. Der äußert sich nämlich dazu, wie großartig das für die Schule doch wäre.
He went public in the middle of the pandemic.
2021, 45 billion dollar market cap.
It's going to be the way we communicate, how people get to go to school when they can't get into school. If I happen to be taking my science class and I can't get into the classroom and we're dissecting a frog, we'll probably dissect the frog in something like Roblox and a simulation, which I think is going to be very, very powerful.
Die Strategie ist ja ganz einfach, man versucht über den Education Weg sich zu rechtfertigen, da weiß ich aber noch nicht, ob das am Ende ein Schuss ins Knie sein könnte, denn über diesen Weg zu gehen bedeutet, dass sich dann Politiker überhaupt mal mit diesem Verkauf auseinandersetzen und dann sagen, huch wie und dann machen die da den ganzen Tag Geschäft und klicken da acht Stunden rum.
Vor allem, wenn ich so den Schulhof dominiere, wo ja wirklich alles erlaubt ist, geh ich doch nicht ins Klassenraum, wo plötzlich so Regeln gelten und so, das ist doch also sehr eigenartig.
Er hat auch eigenartige Vorstellungen von Werbung und wie man da in Balance zu steht, gerade auch die jungen User.
Ich denke, dass es einen bestimmten typischen Advertisement gibt, der für Kinder safe ist, der immer mehr und nicht in deinen Weg kommt. Ich denke, die Leute an Roblox sind da, um sich authentisch mit ihren Freunden zu verbinden, so lange wir mit diesen Branden sehr klaren, non-deceptive, für diese Ärzte zu verantworten sind. Ich denke, sie werden sich die Balance ausfinden, wie lange wir in einen Stor gehen, wie lange wir in einen verrückten Abenteuer-Tickeen gehen.
Die Kinder machen das ganz eigenverantwortlich, ob sie sich Werbung aussetzen wollen oder nicht, oder nur die Freunde treffen, das ist ungeheuerlich. Unserer Nordstar ist, dass wir am Ende der.
Digitale Produkte, digitales Inhalt, verschiedene Dinge, um sich selbst zu verbreiten, sowohl das Kleid für ihre Avatar, verschiedene digitale Produkte für ihre virtuelle Heimat, oder Dinge, um ihre virtuelle Konferenz-Rufe zu dekorieren.
Utilitäten, um mehr produktiv in virtualen und aufgewachsene Realität und im Überall der Metaverse zu sein.
Ich denke, es wird eine riesige Wirtschaft um die Metaverse führen.
Deswegen höre ich so viel über die Schauspieler-Ekonomie. Anstatt die Dinge, die sie heute machen könnten, weil sie sich so fühlen, dass sie es brauchen, um Geld zu machen.
Ja, Meta hat noch nie irgendetwas für Creator getan, noch nie.
Ob er weiß, dass wenn überhaupt aus der Entwicklungsbude Meta, wenn was erfolgreiches kommt in der Richtung, dass da auf gar keinen Fall irgendwo Facebook dran schreiben darf und dass auch Mark Zuckerberg das niemals selber promoten darf, sondern das ist so ein ganz eigenständiges Ding, wo dann alle Jahre später ach so, das ist auch von Facebook so ungefähr sagen, eigentlich so wie Twitch. Es muss einfach komplett entkoppelt sein. Es gibt ja auch wirklich Forschung dazu, dass manchmal die Markennamen stören. Also dass du wirklich so dieses ganz bewusste, die E-Netzbetreiber in Deutschland, die haben zum Beispiel so eine Webseite Curved, E plus hat Curved. Und bei Curved, also auf der Webseite curved.net oder so, haben sie einfach so eine Lifestyle-Berichterstattung zum Thema mit dem Smartphone-Leben gemacht und haben dann rausgefunden, wenn wir da irgendwo dran schreiben, dass das von E plus ist, ist das alles nichts wert. Sondern die müssen diesen Lifestyle in der Hoffnung, dass die Kunden dann schon einfach zu E plus gehen. Aber sie durften es nicht miteinander verbinden, weil dann, ah so, es geht ja nur wieder um Werbung. Und dieses riesige Problem hat ja Facebook auch irgendwie. Der Name ist komplett verbrannt. Die Leute wollen so was richtig originell Neues und nicht so was Rangebautes, weshalb eben auch TikTok so wahnsinnig gut funktioniert. Und dieses, ja, wir drehen jetzt mal Instagram ein bisschen auf. Was weiß ich eigentlich? Und man stellt nur fest, die zerstören eigentlich Instagram damit. Die schaffen nichts Neues, sondern die machen das Alte kaputt. Und ich bin mal sehr gespannt, was man in fünf Jahren über dieses ganze Mark Zuckerberg und sein Metaverse scheißt. Ich wünsche ihm ja nur das Schlechteste, was das angeht. Und an deren Sicht Glück.
Und er hat diese eigenartige Vorstellung und das verbindet ihn mit Roblox, die ja eigentlich schon so ein kleines Metaverse da erschaffen haben.
Das Mega Metaverse.
Oder ein Mega Metaverse. Diese Idee, dass eigentlich, also das sind zwei Ideen. Einmal die Idee, dass man wirklich in eine Welt geht, die genauso gut ist wie die reale Welt, also die analoge Hardware Welt. Und diese Idee, dass da wirklich gewirtschaftet wird, im Sinne von, dass da Wohlstand entsteht. Und wir hören jetzt aus dem Unternehmenspodcast von Roblox noch zwei Clips abschließend. Einmal zu genau dieser Idee, hier kannst du auch genauso wirkliche Welt erleben.
So in the real world, right? When you visit New York City, you walk around Times Square on a Friday evening. The whole experience in Times Square is about those brilliant, shiny billboards and they are all ads. That's the prime time attraction there, right? So why not Times Square walkthrough on Roblox experience? This emulation of reality in terms of variety of experiences, like shopping, creative ads, transacting with our virtual currency Robux, buying, selling, creating various items is what I think about virtual economy in terms of metaverse.
Dass es noch sowas wie Präsenz gibt, leibhaftige Präsenz, ist für diese Leute überhaupt nicht mehr bewusst sein. Das kann man aber erleben, wenn man einfach mal rausgeht oder zum Beispiel, wie eben ja ausgerufen ins Konzert geht. In Iron Maiden.
Das ist mal Präsenz. Als sie jetzt bei Corporate Therapy so über ihre Virtual Reality Erfahrung sprachen und man so hörte, für Hörer, die die Brille jetzt nicht aufhatten vorher, ist das irgendwie schwer nachzuvollziehen, was sie da sagen, aber präsent. Und dann im Stadion zu sitzen und die Masse zu hören, das ist halt so Präsent. Wenn die das irgendwie nachbilden können. Schön und gut, wenn sie das so sagt. Ich mache ja im Buch auch so eine Idee auf, von was brauchen die Alten nach ihrer Arbeitswelt, nach dem Arbeitsleben, Urlaub bis zum Lebensende. Das ist ja nicht so schwer zu gestalten. Eine Stunde pro Gramm pro Tag, wo es heißt, und deswegen bist du hier, deswegen ist das Urlaub. Den Rest liegst du halt nur rum. Ob du jetzt zu Hause im Garten oder auf eine Liege irgendwo in Südeuropa, ist ja auch egal. Und die eigentlich entscheidende Frage ist, falls wir Urlaub bis zum Lebensende machen, ist ja nicht wohin oder sonst irgendwas, sondern einfach nur mit wem. So, wenn die das in dieser virtuellen Realität hinbekommen, um diesen Avatar mal wieder mit Lebendigkeit zu füllen, irgendwie, dass es eben nicht diese Attraktivität ist, hier sind irgendwie alle, aber es ist eine anonyme Masse, was ja Social Media mäßig alle in die Verirrung führt, weil die helfen dir nicht in deinem normalen Leben, sondern wenn sie das darstellen können, dass man hier tatsächlich mit jemandem ist, der aber nicht wirklich da ist, sondern wirklich nur virtuell repräsentiert, aber trotzdem näher als über eine Videotelefonie oder so. Das ist eigentlich die Herausforderung. Da bin ich mal gespannt. Bisher bin ich noch wenig überzeugt. Gerade hier, das ist ja auch wieder so ein, da rennen halt so viele Figuren irgendwie rum. Ja, das ist ja, man hat ja so eine ganz komische, keine Ahnung, man sitzt auf dem Fahrrad und steht neben dem Bus. Und in dem Bus sitzen sehr viele Menschen und sehnt dich auf dem Fahrrad. Und in dem Moment hast du ja so eine Idee von, jetzt will ich aber gerade eine gute Figur machen, weil viele gucken mich an. Und wirst ja total verwirrt dadurch, dass es eigentlich total egal ist, weil wer sitzt denn da an dem Bus? Du hast nie was mit den Leuten zu tun. Du weißt nicht, wer die sind. Die wissen nicht, wer du bist. Warum willst du jetzt hier eine gute Figur machen? Bleib doch einfach auf dem Fahrrad hängend und warte halt, bis grün wird. Und so ist das ja hier auch. Da wird ja wieder so ein ganz tief in die DNA einprogrammierter, hier willst du eine gute Figur machen, der völlig bedeutungslos ist. Weil wer sieht dich denn mit deiner Gucci-Tasche da oben rein? Das ist doch komplett bescheuert.
Und auch diese Idee von wir erwirtschaften dort irgendetwas. Noch einmal dieser Unternehmenspodcast.
So, Roblox Virtual Economy ist nicht nur über die ganze Top- und Bottom-Line wie andere Unternehmen. Wir sind nicht besorgt, Geld zu machen, sobald wir uns besorgt sind, eine Plattform und Tools zu kreieren, damit unsere Entwickler und Schwerter unsere Endgänger in diesem Prozess mit Geld ausüben.
Die Idee ist hier tatsächlich, wir machen ja Bruttoinlandsprodukt. Das ist ja wie ein Staat, aber in einem Staat wird ja real etwas gebaut. Da werden Nahrungsmittel hergestellt. Für die Reproduktion gesorgt der eigenen Bevölkerung und dass das natürlich in einer virtuellen Welt nicht stattfinden kann, sollte klar sein und das einzige, was die aufgebaut haben, ist ein sehr komplexes Code System, dass es erlaubt, dass Leute sich untereinander irgendwelche Beträge abluxen, am Ende aber immer das Unternehmen gewinnt und nichts Neues in irgendeiner Form dabei entsteht. Nichts entsteht ein Produkt, das man für irgendetwas Sinnvolles einsetzen kann. Man könnte jetzt dieses ganze Roblox-Ding mit seinen 80 Millionen täglichen Usern oder 60 Millionen täglichen Usern nehmen und sagen, wir schenken das jetzt Sri Lanka, da habt ihr es. Und dann könnten die trotzdem nicht eine einzige Mahlzeit mehr am Tag essen.
Genau, es ist also...
Ich wollte es mal aufgreifen, weil es doch so kurios ist. Und ich denke, wir müssen ja im Neuen Zwanziger Podcast immer so ein bisschen schauen, was verändert sich wirklich. Und es sind ja die inkrementellen Sachen, die eigentlich so richtig durchsickern, also wo so schrittweise Veränderungen gehen. Wenn ich mir das jetzt mal ansehe, wir haben diese Dating-Apps, wir haben die Video-Sex-Plattform, wo man so eine fluide Prostitution eigentlich entwickelt hat, wo dann Leute gegen ein bisschen Bezahlung irgendwas mit Sex-Toys oder so machen. Dann hat man mit OnlyFans so eine fluide Pornografie entwickelt, Leute, die sich zeigen bei Instagram ein bisschen freizügiger. Die werden dann noch freizügiger über OnlyFans. Und was wir hier eigentlich sehen, ist so eine Fluidität hin zum Kinderunternehmen. Also Kinder sollen früh lernen, wie man Geschäfte macht, wie man selbstständig ist. Und zugleich sollen sie sich auch an Schein-Selbstständigkeit gewöhnen. Denn was anderes ist das ja nicht, was da hergestellt wird. Man arbeitet also früh schon für ein Konzern. Da kann man schon sagen, dass diese Plattform eigentlich Subjekte prägt. Es gibt ja diese Idee vom ideologischen Staatsapparat von Althusser. Und er sagt, gut, in der modernen Welt ist das nicht mehr die Kirche. Es ist aber die Schule, die ganz stark das bürgerliche Subjekt hervorbringt. Und hier wird eine neue Form von Subjektivität hervorgebracht, dass also Kinder schon daran gewöhnt werden, sich als Unternehmer zu betätigen, dass alles, was sie spielen, nicht einfach nur des Spiels wegen stattfindet, sondern dass dazu gleich ein finanzieller Nutzen bei herausspringen soll. Und meine Forderung jetzt an die Politik wäre natürlich eine krasse Regulierung oder auch Verbot eines solchen Systems. Aber es gibt ja offenbar das Bedürfnis, eben virtuell irgendwas zu createn. Sonst hätten diese Leute nicht so viel Erfolg. Da würde ich sagen, wir haben öffentliche Spielplätze, muss jedes Stadtteil oder was haben. Wir brauchen eigentlich auch, am besten von der EU direkt produziert, öffentliche digitale Spielplätze, wo man tatsächlich als Gegenangebot dann seine Welten erschaffen kann, ohne dass man auf irgendeinem Company-Script-Dinger fällt.
Genau, wir haben ja vorhin leider besprochen, dass der Staat sowas nicht schafft. Egal wie groß der Wunsch ist, ein Digitalist, da geht es nur darum, Zufallszahlen auszutauschen. Und selbst das ist schon zu kompliziert. Ein öffentlich-rechtliches YouTube, man macht halt Funk und publiziert dann trotzdem wieder bei YouTube. Und ich habe das da auch nicht technisch nachzurüssen. Und zahlt den sogar nach Werbung, Werbegeld, ballert dann nochmal die Million raus, damit man gut platziert wird und so weiter. Und ja, hier ist es eben auch wieder im Grunde einen digitalen Spielplatz. Es wäre so wünschenswert, nur sehen wir, wenn es nicht mal Facebook hinbekommt, obwohl sie wollen. Es ist halt für so eine stattliche Dings auch schwer, ob man es irgendwie in den Unterricht einbaut. Lehrer zu ertüchtigen, was das angeht, ist super schwer. Lehrer, die erst mal zehn Jahre drin sind, im Job und so.
Ich meine, wir reden jetzt über Roblox ein paar Jahren. Es ist was anderes. Und da braucht man ja, um das mal so halbwegs abzudecken.
Also wir brauchen, was wir auf jeden Fall brauchen, ist hier eine Aufklärung. Ich machs im Buch. Ich muss leider immer wieder darauf zurückkommen, aber ich machs da ganz deutlich. Nachdem ich die Zahlen in Kapitel 1 nenne, ist das Kapitel 2 allein dem Oxytocin gewidmet. Mit dem Argument, alles, was wir in Deutschland haben, an Diskussionen dazu ist, hat uns in die Irre geführt. Wir hatten von Merkel dieses Neuland-Ding, wie es ist für uns alle Neuland. Wir haben alle darüber gelacht, aber es ist für uns alle Neuland. Dann haben wir von Manfred Spitzer dieses Buch Digitale Demenz, was wir einfach nur zum Anlass genommen haben, um jede Kritik am Internet zu verreißen, anstatt das einfach mal ernst zu nehmen, was da drin steht. Und so sind wir überhaupt nicht vorwärts gekommen. Und dann kam diese Corona-Pandemie und plötzlich hieß es Homeoffice, Homeschooling und so weiter. Niemand hat sich irgendeinen Gedanken dazu gemacht.
Den Roblox verölten Text, den kann ich mir jetzt auch schon schreiben. Dann sagt man dann, wie toll Kreativität wird, dann Falte und so. Es wird gar nicht über die ökonomischen Strukturen gerät, genauso wie bei dem Spitzer, wo man den sicherlich an manchen Punkten kritisieren kann, hat man aber nicht gesehen. Ja, es gibt halt eine ganz große Abhängigkeit. Leute kommen von diesem Smartphone nicht los, werden unglücklich darüber, haben Konzentrationsstörungen, Schlafstörungen und so weiter. All das hängt damit zusammen. Aber man sagt, wir können jetzt nicht, seht doch her, diese Kreativität bei TikTok, ist das nicht eigentlich die antike Tragödie? Nein, ist es nicht.
Genau, und dann kommt Facebook und kauft für 19 Milliarden WhatsApp, das ungefähr von jedem vierten Deutschen verwendet wird. Und das Kartellamt sagt, die haben ja nicht die Preise gedrückt oder sowas. Es gibt ja keine Preise. WhatsApp hat mal einen Euro gekostet, aber gut, das funktioniert alles nicht. Also die ganzen Gesetze funktionieren nicht. Und eigentlich bräuchten wir so eine neue Romantik. Wir hatten ja schon mal so eine große Schwemme an Literatur, die den Menschen einfach Liebe gezeigt hat, was Liebe ist. Das hat auch viele in die Irre geführt. Also wir haben sehr viel unglückliche Menschen, weil sie da einfach sich verlaufen haben. Aber diesen Moment, dass eine einzige Person, die man nicht selber ist, sondern jemand anderes, noch mal wichtiger sein kann, wenn auch nur für einen Moment, als die ganze restliche Welt.
Nicht Me-Time.
Eben nicht Me-Time, sondern ich liefere mich mal aus Time. Ich ergebe mich mal einem Gefühl Time, ich mache jetzt mal nicht das mit dem Smartphone, nur weil ich da so Selbstwirksamkeit, es ist ja mein Daumen, der das steuert. Nee, sondern sich mal ausliefern lassen, sich ausgeliefert fühlen. Aber eben nicht einem Gerät, sondern einem anderen Menschen. Darüber bräuchten wir eigentlich mal eine neue. Wie kriegt man das ohne sich selbst zu schädigen und so weiter? Wir wollen uns nicht alle unterwerfen oder so was. Aber einem Gefühl mal folgen. Wie kriegt man das in so einer digital vollseuchten Sphäre noch mal hin? Weil am Ende ist es Biologie. Also Oxytocin lässt sich nicht heraustrichsen. Da kann man machen, was man will. Der Körper irgendwann zieht eine Bilanz, wie viel Oxytocin, wie viel Dopamin. So und wenn das zu viel Dopamin und zu wenig Oxytocin war, ist man einfach unglücklich. Und da hilft auch nicht das nächste Versprechen zu noch mehr Dopamin, sondern da hat man sich einfach verlaufen. Und diese Aufklärung ist da von bitterer Nöte. Aber wir haben sie ja hier auch geliefert, würde ich sagen heute. Ich denke schon. Wer sich das hier angehört hat und jetzt auch weiß, was Roblox ist, weiß ja Bescheid. Machen wir ein klotzes letztes Thema ohne Clips, würde ich vorschlagen. Ich hätte auch welche, aber muss ja nicht alles zwingend verklippt werden. Demografie. Die Vereinten Nationen machen also alle zwei Jahre ihre Revision der Weltbevölkerungsdaten. Also die 2022 Revision of World Population Prospects sind jetzt im Juli veröffentlicht worden. Das machen sie seit 1950. Wir haben also viele Daten. Die 8 Milliarden werden noch dieses Jahr erreicht. Kann man sich also darauf einstellen. Spätestens 2023 reden wir ganz offiziell von 8 Milliarden Menschen. Der Peak, sie sind bei 10, 4 Milliarden für das Jahr 2086. Das wird noch ein paar Mal revidiert. Und dann liegen wir auch ein bisschen früher, aber ein bisschen niedriger. Die Tendenzen sind ja ganz klar. Die UN rechnet mit 15 Millionen Todesfällen durch Covid. Was bedeutet? Bislang sind vor 2020 niemals mehr als offiziell berechnet 60 Millionen Menschen pro Jahr auf der Welt gestorben. Also so ungefähr ein Prozent der Weltbevölkerung, ein bisschen weniger. Und 2019 waren es eben noch 58 Millionen, 2021 68 Millionen. Also wirklich ein krasser Sprung um 10 Prozent. Hat auch mit der Alterung natürlich zu tun. Das ist nicht alles Übersterblichkeit durch Corona. Aber man muss sagen, Corona ist hier schon sichtbar. Also das ist schon ganz deutlich. Und die aktuelle Fertilitätsrate pro Frau, also Kinder pro Frau liegt bei 2, 3. 1950 lag es noch bei 5. Also wir nähern uns hier rapide. Nicht nur, es ist mehr als halbiert, sondern wir nähern uns auch rapide. Diesem 2, 1 eben weltweit, wenn wir jetzt hier Afrika, Nigeria und so weiter, das sind ja alles 200 Millionen Menschen. Und das Durchschnittsalter ist so 18 oder so. Also wenn man solche Ausreise mal aus der Gleichung rausnimmt, sieht man ja, die Hälfte der Welt schrumpft mittlerweile. Also da liegen die Länder einfach weit drunter. China wird, jetzt pieken sie gerade bei 1, 4 Milliarden, nächstes Jahr schon überholt von Indien. 2023. Also 2023 wird Indien das bevölkerungsreichste Land und das historisch bevölkerungsreichste Land sein, mit dann 1, 4 und in der Spitze dann 1, 7 Milliarden in 40 Jahren. Und das Statistische Bundesamt hat auch nochmal Aktuelles gemacht, nämlich Jugend in Zahlen, nennen sie ihre kleine Serie. Sie haben also passend zu meinem Buch dann auch nochmal Zahlen geliefert. Denn in Deutschland leben so wenig junge Menschen wie noch nie. Zum Ende des Jahres 2021 werden gut 8, 3 Millionen Menschen im Alter von 15 bis 24 Jahren sein. 8, 3 Millionen, 83 Millionen, hm. 10 Prozent, also die U25er, liegen jetzt bei 10, 0 Prozent Gesamtbevölkerung. Man kann also in Deutschland an zwei Bundestagswahlen teilgenommen haben, altersbedingt und trotzdem noch zu den 9, 0 jüngsten gehören. Das ist schon irgendwie beeindruckender, muss man echt mal sagen.
Nun hab ich diese Zahlen auch mitbekommen und die wurden ja auch vermeldet. Aber dann wunderte mich, dass wir zugleich über Personalmangel sprechen, und zwar nicht nur bei den Superfachkräften, sondern überall. Flächendeckend fehlen Leute. Und dann wird das aber sehr wenig zusammen gedacht. Oder wenn es mal zusammen gedacht wird, dann wird nicht weit genug gedacht. Ich habe mir den Spiegel gekauft. Ich dachte, das ist doch ein schönes Titelthema. Wo sind sie alle hin, so in etwa war das. Also wo sind all die Leute hin? Überall fehlt es dann. Dann ist das so eine typische Spiegelreportage über acht Seiten. Man geht zum Handwerk, man geht in die Pflege, man geht überall hin und fragt und spricht mit Leuten. Immer szenischer Einstieg. Du kennst das, du hast es. Und dann hat man auch noch so Zahlen, die man in der Grafik präsentiert bekommt, wie viele Leute in Rente gehen, wie viele nachkommen. Und man hat noch Zahlen davon, wie lange Stellen offen sind. Und dann liest man so in der Pflege 218 Tage oder so was. Es ist einfach eine Stelle offen, wird nicht besetzt. Und das gilt dann für ganz viele Branchen. Also es ist keineswegs nur die Pflege. Und dann ist der Tenor des Artikels nicht, wir müssen jetzt das Thema Migration ganz groß aufgreifen oder wir müssen jetzt wirklich über die Demografie im weiteren Sinne sprechen, sondern man sagt dann, ja, was haben dann die Unternehmen versäumt, um für Nachwuchs zu werben? Und dann denke ich mir, ja, aber jetzt müssen wir noch mal logisch bleiben, wenn es weniger werden, dann werden es für die Volkswirtschaft Deutschland weniger. Punkt, dass einzelne Unternehmen durch geschickte Werbe, Aktionen, hohe Gehälter, tolle Kickerspiele und Chill-Out-Lounges es vielleicht schaffen können, dass sie nicht so arg davon betroffen sind und dass die Leute lieber da arbeiten als woanders. Das mag ja sein, aber das bringt uns ja volkswirtschaftlich betrachtet nicht weiter. Wir müssen ja das als ein grundsätzliches Mangelproblem erkennen. Und dann möchte ich einfach immer das Thema Migration daran gekoppelt haben. Wir haben wieder schlimme Zahlen und Bilder bekommen zu Frontex und so weiter, wie erbittert jeder, der kommen will, abgewehrt wird. Und ich kriege das einfach nicht zusammen, wie man da so eine Barriere aufmacht in der Argumentation. Und einfach nur sagt, ja, da müssten die mal mehr darum werben. Das suggeriert hier, dass einfach 10 Millionen jetzt gerade da sitzen, an jungen Menschen, die sich weigern zu arbeiten und nur eine gute Werbung brauchen. Nein, es gibt sie einfach nicht.
Genau, es gibt sie einfach nicht. Es gab früher diese Fachkraftemangel-Lüge. Die Rechnung war so, wenn ein Unternehmen eine Stelle ausschreibt und es bewerben sich weniger als sieben Menschen auf diese Stelle, dann spricht man von einem Fachkräftemangel. Denn dann geht ja davon aus, die bewerben sich ja eh bei fünf verschiedenen, und dann summiert man das so auf. Davon sind wir weit entfernt. Also wer das noch im Hinterkopf hat mit, ja, das ist so eine Lüge, das ist so eine Industrielüge, die wollen einfach nur mehr Auswahl haben oder sowas. Nein, das ist wirklich weit weg. Und auch dieses ganze Jahr, da sind die gestürzten Lieferketten und die haben sich so andere Berufe gesucht und wollen jetzt nicht zurück und so. Nein, es gibt eine Corona-Nachwehe, aber es ist vor allem der Einstieg jetzt in diese Altenrepublik. Also jetzt sind das halt diese Jahrgänge einfach. Genau, und man muss halt deutlich sagen, die gibt es dann einfach nicht. Und wenn man jetzt so Diskussionen hört wie, ja, wir haben ja eigentlich eine Impfpflicht mit den Pflegeberufen, es sei denn die Unternehmen zeigen, dass jemand, das Wort ist nicht systemrelevant, aber die müssen irgendwie darstellen, dass derjenige super wichtig ist für das Unternehmen. So und diese Behauptung, es sei so, ist nicht, die muss nicht inhaltlich begründet werden, sondern da ist einfach ein Häkchen auf dem Formular, wo du anhackst, der ist wichtig. So, wir haben so einen krassen Pflegemangel, dass natürlich jeder Einzelne da wichtig ist. Also es gibt keine Impfpflicht, nicht mal für diese Berufe in Deutschland faktisch gerade. Da braucht man auch nicht anfangen mit diskutieren oder so, es ist da einfach wie es ist.
Das wissen die Ungeimpften auch übrigens selbst. Ich glaube, dass die sehr genau wissen, der Marktwert und dann die naja, gut, ihr wollt das nicht.
Also es ist gerade nicht die Frage, sind sie geimpft oder nicht, sondern wir können ihnen nur das Gehalt bieten und dann, nee, ich gehe zur Konkurrenz. Also da ist jetzt auch so ein gewisser Druck, einfach da Preise einfach oder über Arbeitszeit mal zu reden. Also solche Sachen.
Ja, und ich bin da wirklich schockiert. Ich meine, wir haben das Buch Move im Salon besprochen, wer sich das nochmal anhören will. Ich glaube, wir haben das damals ganz gut aufbereitet. Einige Monate her, also Move hieß das Buch. Und es ist wirklich verrückt, dass das nicht jetzt mal so thematisiert wird, in einer sinnvollen Weise. Ich sehe das schon vor mir beim nächsten Bundestagswahlkampf, wird man nochmal irgendwas mit Flüchtlingen finden. Und da wird dann auch die CDU sich nicht zu fein sein, dann nochmal drauf zu hauen. Also es ist wirklich katastrophal. Und auch hier würde ich wieder sagen, allein über so eine ökonomische Argumentation. Und jetzt sage ich noch was. Also es gibt natürlich die Fragen der Menschenrechte und so. Und eigentlich müsste die Flüchtlingspolitik in Europa sowieso ganz anders laufen. Da sind wir uns denke ich einig. Aber ich glaube, wo wir sehen, dass das alles so ideologisch verbohrt ist und wir, naja, die Regierungskonstellation nun mal haben, wie sie ist, glaube ich, muss man jetzt mit so funktionalen Argumenten kommen. Denn am Ende, wenn das auf dem idealistischen menschenrechtlichen Wege nicht möglich ist, muss man ja doch noch eines tun in einem Pragmatismus, dann wenigstens sagen, es gilt, Leid zu verhindern bzw. zu minimieren. Und jeden, den wir aufnehmen, der muss nicht irgendwo verhungern oder sonst irgendwelchen Repressionen ausgesetzt sein. Insofern kann man wenigstens da etwas tun, dass man das Leid global betrachtet minimiert, indem man mehr Leute aufnimmt. Und wenn das dann über eine Argumentation läuft, die rein ökonomisch ist, dann ist es halt so.
Ja, ich würde es krasser formulieren, man muss funktional argumentieren, ansonsten wird man selber trübe in der Birne, wenn man sich nur mit diesem Trübsal so rumschlägt. Sondern es gibt einfach funktionale Argumente. Gut, das Statistische Bundesamt hat natürlich jetzt erst mal nur über die Jugend gesprochen, weil U25 unter 10% fällt. Also jetzt ist die Zäsur oder zumindest diese Haltelinie oder wie auch immer diese wichtige Linie wird unterschritten. Heißt allerdings für Ostdeutschland, Brandenburg, die sind natürlich schon bei 8%, Sachsen-Anhalt bei 8, 3%. Wir reden hier von den U25-Jährigen. Wenn wir jetzt nur die Wahlberechtigten nehmen und dann man darf ab 18 Bundestags wählen und mit 25, das sind so sieben Jahre, wir haben in diesen Bundesländern wirklich doppelt so viele Leute mit Pflegestufe als Erstwähler. Wenn man dann immer hört, ja, da hat sie aber die Grünen ganz schön viel Erfolg bei den Erstwählern gehabt, dann muss man sagen, ja, bei den 0, 1% oder so, die irgendwie in Gewicht dann ausmachen, nachdem selbst mehr die wahrscheinlich ist, die Wahlbeteiligung der Menschen mit Pflegestufe höher als bei den Erstwählern. Das muss man dann auch immer einpreisen. Und ich wollte es zum Ende noch mal koppeln mit dem Anteil der Alten. Also die U25-Jährigen sind eine wichtige Grenze, weil mit 25 irgendwie steigt man dann so ins Arbeitsleben ein. Mit 65 fällt man oben raus. Wir können also auch die U65er-Grenze mal aufmachen. Als Konrad Adenauer 1963 das Amt verließ, das Bundeskanzleramt, waren es 12 Prozent über 65-Jährige. Also wir hatten damals schon mehr Ältere im Anteil als heute Junge. Helmut Schmidt 1982, da waren es dann schon 15 Prozent, also drei Prozent. Bis zu Helmut Kohl 1998 waren es dann 16 Prozent, also noch mal ein Prozent drauf. Wir haben also von Adenauers Abgang bis zu Helmut Kohl Abgang vier Prozent mehr über 65-Jährige innerhalb von 35 Jahren. Und alleine der Sprung zu Angela Merkels Abgang 2021, der nur 23 Jahre später war, brachte noch mal weitere sechs Prozent. Also wir haben nicht immer nur mehr Alte, sondern wir haben auch immer mehr mehr Alte. Das ist sozusagen eine Beschleunigung in der Beschleunigung. Und in der Ansicht ist das wirklich gravierend. Was für die Rentenkasse und so wirklich bedeutet, da geht nicht nur jemand in Rente, sondern da fällt auch jemand aus der Einzahlerseite raus. Man muss die also im Kopf immer doppelt verbuchen. So ein Migrant kann man dann einfach verbuchen. Da kommt einfach als Zahler dazu. Und man muss sagen, die kommen wirklich als Zahler in Deutschland. Sind diejenigen, die kommen so nach zehn Jahren spät, sind eigentlich nach fünf Jahren sozialversicherungspflichtig beschäftigt. Also da führt gar kein Weg drum herum. Und die kommen immer als im Grunde 25-Jährige. Also wenn man sich das Alter der Migration anschaut in Deutschland, da kommen keine alten Leute, die in Sozialsysteme als Auszahler oder so einwandern. Berechtigt wären sie eh nicht, selbst wenn sie demografisch da reinfallen würden. Also Migration ist ein wichtiger Punkt.
Die machen sich ja auch nicht auf den Weg aus. Selbst jetzt auch bei der Ukraine zu sehen, dass viele Alte dann sagen, ich bleibe da. Also ich will nicht.
Genau, sind wir so ein attraktives Land in Deutschland? Ich meine, die Leute gehen selbst jetzt lieber nach England, weil sie einfach die Sprache kennen und wissen, worauf sie sich einlassen. In Deutschland ist es alles superschwer. Und naja, klar, Migration ist, kann ein guter Ausweg sein. Das müsste halt wirklich politisch gestaltet werden.
Ja, ja, man muss das dann richtig politisch gestalten. Und dann auch, also damit sind ja auch Schwierigkeiten verbunden. Also es ist ja nichts, die kommen ja nicht an und dann klappt das alles reibungslos. Das ist natürlich nicht so. Aber ich glaube, dass man eigentlich das als die positive Vision ausmalen könnte. Man könnte sagen, eigentlich können wir hier, geografisch halbwegs gut gelegen, eigentlich als reibendes Land, noch schöne Jahrzehnte verbringen. Wir brauchen nur mehr Leute. Und dann ist aber auch dafür gesorgt, dass dann mal Klimaanlagen installiert sind. So ein Solarpanel auf dem Dach installiert werden können. Denn auch von einem Bekannten, der einen Dachschaden hat, nach einem Hagelschaden und vom Dachdecker bekommt, ja, da es ja mal ihnen nicht rein regnet, es also nicht akut ist, würden wir das gerne so auf den Januar verschieben.
So sieht es aus. Ja, ist einfach brutal. Und man muss immer dazu sagen, bei Migration kann man noch politisch gestalten, auch wenn es super schwer ist. Bei Alter, was willst du denn da gestalten in Deutschland? Also kannst du die Leute ja nicht jünger zaubern oder plötzlich mehr Geburten zaubern oder sowas. Klar, ich mach im Buch auch ein paar Vorschläge, wie man es so ein bisschen gedämpft kriegt. Aber in diesem sauren Apfel muss man dann beißen, wenn man einfach nur festhält, wir sind alt und wir klammern mal Migration aus. So wie Olaf Scholz im Bundestag in seiner letzten Rede als Bundesfinanzminister, als er über alles gesprochen hat, außer über Migration, aus Angst vor der AfD. Und dann busch man aus der FDP und rief ja mal jetzt Demografieleugner oder was. Wieso reden sie da einfach nicht? Also wieso sparen sie da so Themen aus und so? Und ja, in deren Sicht sieht das wirklich düster aus. Und Alter ist eben das unser Schicksal jetzt in Deutschland. Da muss man jetzt gucken, wie wir das schaffen.
Gut, wir wollen noch auf den Salon zu sprechen kommen. Da geht es auch wieder um die Zukunft. Wir beschäftigen uns mit Sex. Wir sprechen also diesmal über Sex. Und zwar gibt es ein Buch von Alfie Baum, der Kulturwissenschaftler, Theoretiker, Philosoph, das er auch schon über Gaming publiziert hat. Und nun sein neues Buch heißt Dreamlovers, The Gamification of Relationships. Er schaut sich also Dating-Apps an, Sex-Toys, alles. Was macht das eigentlich mit unserer Liebe? Wie verändert die sich? Stimulation and Stimulation from Games to Porn heißt zum Beispiel ein Kapitel. Darüber werden wir gemeinsam reden. Dann werde ich einen Erzählungsband vorstellen, der hat den Titel Brauchbare Menschen. Magdalena Schrefel ist eine Autorin, die sich in ihren Erzählungen mit der Arbeitswelt auseinandersetzt. Die erste Erzählung liest man und denkt, das ist ja wirklich ganz aktuell. Das spielt nämlich unter Sicherheitspersonal und Flughafen. Es ist sehr interessant, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen. Dann habe ich eine Studie anzubieten, wie die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen im Internet, vor allem auf den sozialen Medien, agieren. Da sind doch oft sehr schrille Titel. Auch die Themen, die da behandelt werden, stellt sich heraus, dass auch die von der Macht der Algorithmen ziemlich beherrscht sind und das zum Teil auch freimütig zugeben. Also diese Studie werde ich vorstellen. Mir ist ja immer ein bisschen langweilig. Dann konfrontiere ich mich hin und wieder mit Inhalten, die ich ablehne. Also habe ich zu einer rechten Öko-Zeitschrift gegriffen, aus dem weiteren Kreis um Götz Kubitschek, weil die auch das Thema Ökologie und Nahrung jetzt haben. Und wir schauen uns mal aus ideologiekritischer Perspektive dann an, wie die Rechten dieses Thema versuchen, für sich zu behandeln. Und da kann man vielleicht auch das eine oder andere ableiten, wovor man gefeiert sein sollte, beziehungsweise auf was man gefasst sein sollte, was da kommen könnte, wenn dann tatsächlich so was passiert, wie ein Volksaufstand oder wenn sich Krisen zuspitzen.
Sehr gut. Ich werde, aber ich habe noch nichts davon gelesen, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher bei den zwei Texten, die ich jetzt nenne. Die Geldverteiler, Berichter aus dem Inneren des IWF, erschienen in Monde Diplomatie.
Ja, das ist der, den ich schon gerade einen Abschnitt zitiert habe. Das ist gut, wenn du den nochmal uns vorstellst. Der ist hervorragend.
In Länge von Lamberne Lesen, sehr gut. Und in Spektrum der Wissenschaft, das werde ich nur, weil es mich auch interessiert so ein bisschen. In Futurama, einer Sendung, die ich nicht kenne, haben sie ein mathematisches Problem gelöst, nur um eine Pointe zu setzen. Keine Ahnung. Ich, jetzt wo ich so viel Conan O'Brien höre, der ja auch aus diesem Simpsons Autorenpool kam und so und wahnsinnige Geschichten von damals erzählt, was sie so versucht haben. Und klar, das ist Zeichentrick, die können im Grunde innertlich alles umsetzen. Und dann plötzlich so viel Realität, dass sie da so echte mathematische Probleme lösen, die vorher noch niemand gelöst hat, weil sie das im Futurama irgendwie brauchten. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt. Und dann bin ich hier auf was Interessantes gesteuert. Elliot Page, also inzwischen ein Mann, im Gespräch. Und da ich zuletzt mit Humor und so, wie er auch in der Oper so über diese Problematik mal sprachen, dachte ich, warum nicht? Es ist irgendwie nicht so mein Metier insgesamt, aber scheint mir interessant zu sein. Ja, so in die Richtung vom Rest lasse ich mich auch noch überraschen, denn ich fahre noch viel Zug nächste Woche. Und dann bringe ich uns was mit. Genau, deswegen gibt es Salon auch erst eine Woche drauf, am Montag, dem 8.8. Wir sind diesmal nicht im, also sonst mal eine Woche später.
Ja, also es sind jetzt drei Tage Verzug. Aber dann mit geballter Kraft werden wir dann über diese Texte sprechen. Und dann sehen wir uns im Salon und wünschen einen schönen Monat.